Two one
fight companion 2016 returns ladies and gentlemen wide from Salt Lake City.
Yeah,
year Rodriguez vs Alex Caceres.
All real slobber.
Knocker a slobber knocker with me here.
If you've never heard the fight companion before,
you're like,
oh great.
A pot.
What,
what was a fight companion?
It's sort of a podcast.
Um,
it's,
it is definitely a podcast,
but we're sort of watching the fights and calling the fights,
but probably most likely not that much,
but it's fun and the nonsense meter hits red hot.
It gets his highs.
It ever get ever in the history of us age.
Uberize here you did Eddie Bravo.
Hello.
Fresh out of recovery.
His fucking back is beautiful.
Amazing gentleman is some fucking new technology going on.
A Bravo has displaced and we were going to get to that Brian Calendars here.
Lean Shaven,
clean shaven,
all Kopi shit out.
Look beautiful.
Thanks buddy.
Brendan motherfucking job isn't the biggest,
strongest guy in the room and handsome and young shit low.
That's right.
I got to show you guys something because yesterday changed my fucking world.
Okay.
I did Duncan [inaudible] Duncan Duncan trussell's podcast,
and he introduced me to the world of virtual reality goggles.
Ho Lee Shit.
I'm going to show you something,
going to show you this game.
This is a boxing game.
Look up in the upper left hand corner.
All right.
This is a boxing game.
So I have these gloves on and it's kind of wacky because a,
the gloves aren't the way you punch your,
you're holding onto these handles and I'm,
I'm fighting this,
this Russian boxing coach.
Dude,
you're punching looks good.
It's okay.
But here's what's goofy about it.
In order for your fist to B level,
like parallel with the ground,
you have to hold them like this.
Like a joy stick.
Yeah.
So you're looking at your,
like,
if you're holding your hands like this,
I sold in your hands with your,
uh,
like your,
your,
the,
the heel of your hand facing the ground and your songs up in the air.
Right?
Like your skiing's.
That's if you're holding your hands like that,
your punches are parallel with the floor.
Okay.
So it's,
it's twisted.
Oh yeah.
They should make it so that you could hold your hand like an actual punch.
Right.
So like wherever your hands are,
that's where your gloves are.
So I'm holding it like this and I'm punching like this.
It's real weird cause you're not,
it looks like really good exercise though.
Is that a prototype shop by the,
by that there's a bunch of games for these things now.
But here's my point.
I was moving around this guy like,
like he's throwing punches at me.
I'm moving around.
I kept hitting him in the back of the head.
I would sneak around behind him and beat him in the back of her head and upper
cut them and I'm,
I'm doing this.
And I'm like,
oh my foot words.
All awkward.
I didn't know what I was doing.
I felt weird like I'm in this virtual world.
But after I did it a few times,
I started to get the feeling of it.
I'm like,
this is an amazing shadow boxing programs.
But he's sick.
That's amazing.
I think you can do more tie with it too.
I think you could have it so that you could throw kicks,
because it was getting me,
it was getting all my movement from these two cameras that Dunkin has set up in
the room there,
motion detectors,
so the cameras,
they scan you when you're standing there and then they build a perimeter around
you and there's a blue line on the ground.
You look down and you're in this three d world,
but you see this blue line on the ground.
You can't go pass that Blue Line because that's the amount of free space that
you have in your area.
Wow.
Can you imagine?
You could download the opponent you're going to fight and they can come shadow
box against.
Exactly.
That's exactly
what he was saying.
If you could make a a training simulation of a god,
you could fight him a hundred times before you ever actually fight him.
That when I was seeing him in front of you,
and I'm telling you,
man,
what I was looking at was kind of cartoonish.
Like this Russian boxing guys [inaudible] he's got a wife beater on and headgear
and shit.
It's kind of cartoonish,
but it doesn't have to be,
right.
It's only cartoonish now.
Like you could get to a point within a few years where you know you're going to
be boxing and it looks exactly like Joe Schilling and has his tendencies,
you know,
big of a deal.
That would be,
you can do that can be a big of an advantage.
That's insane.
Certainly be a great training tool often Stein,
but we got a ways to go look at it.
This is,
this is what it looks like.
See,
so your,
your,
your gloves.
It's weird like you have to kind of turn your gloves fucky so that they look
normal on the screen.
Right.
But other than that,
it's Kinda dope.
It's fun to do.
And I'll tell you what,
this isn't nearly as fun as the archery program.
There was an archery one.
When you're in a castle and you all a roof and you hear and he's fucking
warriors come storming at you and they have helmets on and they have shields and
you're shooting arrows at them.
Sounds send you.
And you have,
it's the same handles though,
right?
Or do you have the same goofy hand?
Yeah,
but,
but there's haptic feedback.
So this is the archery one that I was playing.
Those graphics are fucking tough too.
It's like an a tall,
it's like Nintendo 64 but I'm telling you,
it's because you're dealing with massive amounts of rendering in real time,
360 degrees,
up and down.
And these are all new things,
but you get to use them.
But I was jacking these motherfuckers up.
Oh Hey,
I was giving some angle on horseback.
I am so,
it's weird.
So when you pull the bow back,
there's no resistance,
but there's this vibration,
it's like shaking as you pull it back.
So it really feels like you're pulling it back and then it gets to the point
where it's locked out.
You feel it like click as a fucking cool dude.
It's dope.
I shot,
I shot this stupid fucking game until my arms were so sore.
They were shaking.
I was gonna say homes now video.
Now gamers are probably going to look like MMA fighters,
or at least runners.
They're gonna be in shape.
But I think,
man,
if you remember last dance dance revolution,
kids,
hell that we're losing like 30 pounds on dance dance.
Okay.
First fight is on.
It's between two ladies.
Uh,
we do not have the names yet.
Jay.
Jay Mckee pull up the card.
So we'll uh,
let people know.
So I've seen this tall woman fight in a,
I think tough round one of three.
It's at four 43,
two one zero harmful rash guy.
Yeah.
You know,
they've just passed new rules today.
They're going to make women wear a tight fitting clothing.
They're not going to allow a loose fitting clothing worn loose.
This girl's got shorts.
I mean,
how tied of those,
I think they should all wear spend X.
I think mentioned too,
I've seen guys grab shorts.
You have to,
if you go back to the chill son and Anderson Silva fight is a famous picture of
Anderson Silva straps on short round check Congo.
I feel,
I feel like last year alone,
I feel like women have gotten exponentially better.
Oh yeah,
that's true.
Well,
there's some fucking jacked in that picture.
Okay.
So we got married.
Mary now Ma Marina,
marina morrows.
Is it marina marina and marina and Danielle Taylor and Ukraine or lady is a lot
of women from the Ukraine.
Man.
A lot of us say some hard ass Soviet bloc women.
It will come from those fucking boxing programs to Valentina shift.
Chanko the woman who just beat Holly Holm,
she,
she's so solid,
man.
Man,
she's so solid.
You can be trouble for lunch.
She's got it in her DNA where she's throwing them spinning back fist calendar.
She's got that down better than anybody,
right?
Yes.
She does everything man.
She does that real good.
She's got that sweet counter right hook pull.
She saw that girl's a multiple time Moy Thai champion.
So like the girls are going to give her problems are not the girls like Holly
girls like Holly,
like Holly's gonna like stand there and strike with there and Valentina has so
much fucking striking experience.
The girls were going to give shift Chanko problems with the girls were going to
be looking to tanker down.
She's a good password,
Kate.
Yeah,
well girls not going to just stand in front of her.
The girl's going to present a bunch of options like Misha Tate is,
you know Misha Tate.
The striking would be an issue is she?
Yeah,
she,
the child scramble.
Her assets can shift Chanko ship tango can wrestle really well.
Fucking strong as shit.
She's strong.
She's not like Ameesha is loves far as grappling.
But when she fought Sarah Kaufman and her first fight,
she out grappled her.
It was almost like I did.
She's a Pfizer with the date.
She did surprise and I think she and she took that photo 500 super short notice
if I remember what she's a beast man.
I feel like Holly's hesitant lately.
Hey Man,
no joke dude.
Fuck.
She called crap with that counter right hook.
That lead counter hook.
She kept taking her head off the sound line and just
was Holly though?
Yeah.
Yeah,
she has.
But don't you think that Holly is in more of a boxing world but she's a 19 time
boxing champion?
Like Holly's boxing,
like as far as her footwork or speed or movement especially are counters like
when someone should count it after she's brilliant.
Counter striker.
I feel like Holly is the fastest,
probably the fastest Stryker as far as just being able to get her shots off,
like if you were at a time.
She said when she throws to somebodies face,
she's certainly fast,
but I mean in her weight class maybe she's the fastest is going,
huh?
You don't want to shut your fucking mouth.
You ever seen you want to do those videos on Twitter where her trainers holding
pads and she's ripping into him?
Yeah,
it's fake dude.
She's insane.
She's the best striker in there.
Jamie.
Jamie,
if you could pull some of those up,
if you could try this even even among guys,
that's a huge thing to say.
Well,
I would say Wonderboy would argue with that.
You know,
would say that there's a few other fighters that are just strikers over and
being k one Grand Prix champion.
But you know what man?
You want it just like what the real problem is like saying she's the best or at
one person's the best.
Like it's so subjective,
especially if they'd never gonna fight each other.
Right?
We all love to do it.
It all depends.
A caliber of person you're fighting to watch this live this,
she's doing these sprawls and then she's getting up fire combinations.
You look at pure technique though,
man.
She's a fucking nightmare.
Oh Dude.
She's so sharp in the fight too.
Yeah,
she's super don't see over in with that same technique.
Granted,
he's a k one world champion.
Well,
it's different too,
but he wanted to compare 115 pound girl,
202 Gilliam pound man and kind of tough.
He smoked junior dos Santos with one shot to Kilian bound that.
I don't know why.
That's funny to me.
He smoked junior dos Santos one left hook.
I mean Alistair Overeem is a beast.
Yes,
he's a beast of the beast.
It's a hard,
it's hard to look at him the same way you look at anybody else because first of
all,
he's in a division where anyone connects,
everybody goes night night,
right?
Correct.
It's like it's such finding different,
such a totally different kind of see his technique because at one of his jabs
we'll knock him the fuck out.
So you don't see five rounds of over him like you do with y'all.
Like y'all will go the distance and her technique will be flawless from minute
one in the first round to minute one in the neck.
You know what I'm saying?
But she can also tend to be somebody at that size can afford to be and take more
chances and actually standing in the pocket and,
and throw out.
Whereas you guys at your weight,
you gotta be so careful because one mistake the market is,
I got other,
I'm saying heavyweights one,
the margin for error.
It seems like it's so much smaller.
Hundred percent you're totally right.
100% Brian.
I think that these guys,
you know,
you're looking at like Ben Rothwell,
like Ben Rothwell knocked out over him and the first round and now Overeem was
going to be fighting.
So the title against steeping,
but Ben Rothwell just got like a full five round beating by junior dos.
Santos dealt with Juno sentos boxes face off.
It was crazy.
It was like the best junior has looked in you and kicked him front kick and then
you gotta think that Alister knocked down junior.
Mm.
MMM.
Math and the heavyweight division is bananas.
Yup.
There's silly,
super silly.
Yeah.
Everyone is so powerful.
Everyone is so big like Steve Bay knocking out for doom like that.
Jesus Christ.
Nothing,
nothing crazy ass division in the craziest sport.
And it's also an older division.
That's what's amazing to me to meet any young heavyweight tour,
2122 like that age,
even in the mix,
tell you who everybody should be.
Despain taking their,
uh,
putting their attention on it.
And I guess,
yeah,
go ahead,
Derek Lewis.
Frances can know.
Oh,
he talking,
you talking about the camera ruined dude.
Who's a to plaintiff's d dude whimsy him.
Drabble did.
Did,
did,
did Cameroon.
Dude,
he's a fucking powerful man.
He looks like straight Predator.
I am telling you when that dude moves in on guys and he throws bombs on them,
I'm just,
I'm waiting for a really solid opponent for him because like we have not seen
him test.
He's fought all scrubs.
We have and starched.
Yeah.
We have not seen him tested,
but I'll type out,
I'm telling you.
And he's got very sharp technique.
How old is he?
He's young.
He's 28 28 how old is he?
28 young.
It's in the heavyweight division.
Shawn,
I think in the heavyweight division.
Guys just need more time.
No,
29 29 damnit.
Third.
Yeah,
he'll be 30 in September.
Actually.
He's a monster though.
He's,
I think you know,
he's in his prime for sure.
Like as a,
as an athlete.
We don't know what him first.
Derrick Lewis with the BBC that Derrick Lewis looks so good in that Roy Nelson
fight.
God Damn,
he looks tough.
Fight to man.
You look good man.
It's combinations were fast.
He was,
he looked like really improved.
Like,
you know,
you see a guy fight and you go,
Whoa,
this guy hit another level.
Like that's how it was he the guy who got knocked out by Mitzrian?
Yes.
Yeah,
we were in the,
he just wasn't ready for that.
But that Roy Nelson is a huge step and to go three rounds with Roy,
there couldn't be a better thing for his career because he's just starching
guys,
you don't learn shit.
Trust me,
And then you go three rounds with a vet.
Like Roy.
I was just so impressed with his combinations is most impressive.
So like wow.
The way he's putting it together and his endurance too.
Cause I thought it was just a meathead like throwing bombs but down for a lot
with you look at his previous sites kind of like,
all right.
He's just a big powerful guy.
Yeah.
You went through at hand.
The guy's going to sleep,
but you look at Roy like shitty splitting combos together,
man.
Yeah,
he was carted.
Oh He,
uh,
he put real good combination so you can see him for sure.
Boy,
the Predator,
the,
that would be a very interesting fight.
Uh,
he's had much more experience against,
uh,
like higher level guys,
I guess you'd say.
Right.
Mitre own.
And now Roy Nelson,
but Mitchell and stuff can you got starched so didn't get a lot of experience.
He didn't really learn as true.
But how many fights is Derek had now in the UFC?
I to say four.
Five fibers.
Right.
The thing is with both those guys,
if you give them,
you know,
cause we can get the top,
not every guy's going to sit there and bang with you.
Right.
You can get a wrestler.
See,
but the thing about good,
no is his Moy Tai.
What,
what makes me super interested in him,
not just his,
his speed,
his size,
his ability to put guys away.
Like what we're seeing.
I mean he puts guys away,
but it's also the way you're watching a movie.
Very like fluid athlete.
Like when he's doing things,
everything's f shoes and he throws blooded hard fucking kicks man.
The only x factor with him as the grappling.
Yeah.
So he's had,
so Derek's had four more wins.
He beat Gavriel Gunza Gabriel Gonzaga.
He beat a Grabowski and he'd beat up Victor Becka before he fought.
Nelson looks good man.
He looks real good dude.
Real good for or fight win streak and getting wins over Gonzaga Nelson.
Too Bad.
Remember that fight was Shawn Jordan too,
but I think Shawn Jordan Hook kicked him in the head.
Yeah did.
That was crazy.
It's crazy that a short time anybody has ever,
and he's a huge guy,
but the first time anybody ever like hey owed somebody with a hook kick.
I don't think so.
Did he change your like you did maybe.
Wow.
Great guy though.
Really Nice.
Calm like and he was,
he's short for heavyweight man.
A large man.
He's a tank though.
What does he play?
Football.
Lsu Full back on the national championship.
By the way.
You can do back flips.
Why he's to 60 does a bad fucking sticks.
It stupid.
He's nice as fuck.
It was anti Greg.
What's up?
What is it easier to become?
UNTAKE downable as a heavyweight or as a lightweight or a welterweight?
Probably depending on who you're asking.
Guys at heavyweight,
there's more technical.
There's a lot of us.
There's a lot less,
uh,
explosive.
Guys,
I'm gonna take you down with explorer,
so it promo,
it's harder to disagree with that.
There's some explosive fucking guys,
that heavyweight man stuff taking shots.
There's this Russian dude who's going to join the ranks of MMA after the
Olympics.
You know what I'm talking about?
You're talking to Russian heavyweight dude,
not Carella and just put,
pull this book on motherfucker up style.
Everybody.
Everybody's fine.
Everybody's Russian scientific experiments and live in Siberia.
Dude is so good.
He's so technical and so fucking stupid strong.
He's freestyle.
Freestyle is fucking take downs are ruthless.
He runs through guys.
He just keeps it there.
George,
to keep running backwards just keeps running for you.
Just trip.
But I'm hitting one take down after the neck.
Various Cain Velasquez pull up video homeboy and gave me his full name.
He didn't want to butcher his name here and a peep out of any wrestler.
He comes up against k.
Well MMAs dude,
friend Billy bill.
Ya'll McAvoy.
Hey Brian.
How do you say that?
I would say I would.
I would say Billy Al Macoff bill got disability.
I'll go [inaudible].
So why watch this motherfucker wrestle?
He's so fucking fast and so big.
He's too nice.
So strong.
And when he gets to MMA,
when he gets to MMA,
he's running through mother fuckers.
You are not,
you are not stopping.
Take down.
This is not happening for sure.
He's going to I yes,
100% a hundred percent it.
Dude.
I'm telling you,
he's just going to be throwing dudes around.
They're not going to know what the fuck to do you know how it is Joe it MMA
wrestling is different than what he's doing though.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
It looked he's going to have more trouble.
There's going to be guys who figured out how to push them off.
They're going to be more defensive.
These guys are forced to engage with them.
Right.
There's gonna be guys that are not gonna wanna engage at all.
So they're going to have much more distance.
They're doing are going to be easy to take down.
That's right.
And even when even when you do take them down and joy that yeah,
cause a lot of problems.
He's got problems.
He's not going to fight.
We're doing right off the bat obviously.
No,
he's getting on that Derrick Lewis and the Francisca no track.
And by the way,
who's to say this guy can't punch off fucking hole through your universe?
I'm not saying he can't look at the way he's built.
I bet that guy took it throw fucking hammers and know who's to say he's not been
boxing anyway since he was eight.
Listen,
if he's rushing hearing for the UFC,
is this him right here?
Yup.
Oh don't show me.
This is terrible.
Goddammit
elbows in Sir.
He's just shadowboxing.
I want to see him hit something stiff is fucked you guys' hands or his wrists.
It's like he's trying to grab people as he's punching him for the record.
I'm not the one laughing.
How's going to say I'm this much
waste throwing some punches.
Great.
Yeah.
See he such a big fucking gorilla though.
He could just haymaker on you.
It's true.
He could be on that Brock Lesnar say fuck.
Strike and check this double leg.
He's definitely got to work on his kicks too,
but hey man,
he's a super athlete.
Yeah,
that's doable.
Dammit.
Timing's off so bad.
Who knows how long ago this is and by the way,
he probably could get better in a month.
Like bring him to Duane Ludwig.
Yeah,
his learning curve is probably,
oh yeah,
man.
I know he's such a c should fly right to AK right now.
I'm just like,
what's up?
You know,
he's a fucking super athlete,
man.
Look at the size of this.
Fuck.
I might like seven,
eight j.
We help big as this fucking gorilla.
Oh my God.
In six five two 96 it's a huge fucking Christ.
How?
How's it going to get to to 65 and it's all,
you saw the test better than the Olympics.
You saw us going to be sniffing his ass.
[inaudible] muscle,
probably on some straight fucking Russian manipulation.
He's out of a moon rock from teenage bean ninjas so far ahead of the curve.
They don't even need steroids.
They just put this dude in like one of them easy big microwave ovens.
He's like,
Bang Ben,
good luck with that.
Fucking dude is a big guy.
Just wrestling in the problem is like,
okay,
say he does get down to two 65 and then he starts fighting and MMA and if he's
to 90 I don't know if he competes it to 90 well he's a heavyweight alpha he has
to lose anyway.
Right.
So maybe if he just watches his diet and incorporates more striking and it's
running and shit like that,
he might get down to two 70 anyway and just use,
so the slide under.
Yeah,
there's a skin though.
The steam room was a couple of 10 pounds.
He's going to be that hard.
I got that guy takes 10 pounds,
shits he a,
he has a long road ahead of them.
Either way.
Yeah.
Well he does,
but she know what man,
guys that become like that level world champion at anything that's combat sport
related.
They figure it out,
man.
I look at DC DC's a perfect example.
The case,
a monster,
perfect example.
Yeah.
I kind of work ethic.
I wouldn't DC's not physically.
You know this bill posey though.
Yeah.
And posing and I'll look at what this,
I don't want this guy hitting me.
You don't want this guy hitting you with this.
You might be stiff,
dude.
This is a big motherfucker.
You do not want this guy hitting you.
I'm telling you man.
I mean,
he's not even doing it like perfectly yet.
He's off his feet when he's punching.
He's not sitting down enough.
He's not torquing his hips enough.
But good luck.
If you take one of those on the chin,
that's a big fucking dude,
man.
Yeah,
he's getting a lot of people prompts.
I mean like if you look at the way he's striking like fluidity,
you want to look at like a big fluid guy.
Look at Rico Verhoeven,
Rico,
Vera,
Laurie heavyweight champion.
Yeah,
he's doing both,
right?
He's gonna Fight 'em Badr Hari though.
But Rico,
see if you get a clip of that guy fighting,
he's,
he's like,
what you want to see when you look at like a heavyweight striker.
So if this gentleman's Russia gentlemen just figures out out a sit down more on
his stuff,
he's so athletic.
Rico's not hindering up.
He better of that rush and polar bear.
Not a fucking,
well,
you don't think that guy could take Rico down dog?
No,
he's that Ak.
Just training.
Take down defense.
Fucking needs to end your world.
I wish I had so much faith.
I don't know man.
Rico and the Ricoh is more of a beast,
I think.
Oh,
he's a bad motherfucker when it comes to kickboxing.
God,
What's interesting about him is his pace because he puts a pace on heavyweights.
It just can't fuck with,
and he's not a little heavyweight.
No,
he's massive.
Biggest fucking legs are awe does left Beth.
Hi Cook and people in the face when his front leg as a heavyweight.
It's a big dude.
What what he's doing is more impressive to me as a big guy to be that athletic
and smooth and just worldclass kickboxer and some nuts.
Well,
yeah.
I mean,
look,
it's super impressive,
but you the both deny how impressive it is that the Russian gentleman is just
dominating.
They're both impressive.
I'm saying if I had to invest in one,
let's say they're both 21 years old.
Here's where it goes back to kick your fucking face off.
The guy's gonna taking scrap motherfucker.
Well,
that guy might not,
I don't know.
He might take you down your neck and you might pull your face off.
Face off
will sass.
I was telling us about that.
Who Was it?
Samoan rustler.
Uh,
he was at WWE and he was so big.
He got in a fight in a bar and he reached new and Dude's mouth.
The guy's gonna.
He reached with him up with his giant Samoan fingers anywhere and granted the
bottom of his teeth and just kind of hit and broke his teeth out of his mouth.
He's talking to her.
Good day.
Hey Pat.
Oh my God.
This bottom teeth out broke them off.
Some big guys.
Hey,
you know at this party needs,
oh,
you use the right one.
This one sending out the Brian Signal.
I just forgot what the fuck I was going to ask you guys about.
We're talking about Rico in the Russian doorbell.
I wanted to talk about the Russian doping program because they almost pulled the
entire Russian team out of the Olympic because the government was in on it.
But I got,
I got a great Russian doping story.
All right,
we'll wait on it.
There's a whole fight going on.
We're not even pay attention.
I didn't see any campaign is not,
I've been balls deep in this Russian.
I haven't seen one fucking ounce of this bite back to this fight real quick,
unless you guys got more shit.
But you were talking about a new rule change about tight,
tighter clothes and like,
yeah,
there was a,
one of the things that I,
I might have read it wrong.
I want to make sure I get it right,
but I believe that one of the new rule changes is no loose clothing for female
fighters.
It's been a problem.
I don't know.
You would think that,
you know,
we gotta stop them.
How do they like doing changes to six elbows might've happened once or twice.
I do not know.
They know they change all these rules,
right?
Eddie,
the sanctioning body changed a bunch of rules like,
uh,
what wins around 10,
eight round,
stuff like that.
And I'm like,
sweet.
I bet they do.
12 to six elbows.
Yeah,
they should have done that.
But what they did do,
that's even more interesting honestly,
is um,
this new rule about putting your hands down the mat.
You have to have both your hands flat on the Mat,
both hands to constitute being in a position where you can't get kicked her
need.
That's better.
Oh,
that's way better because it makes it less of a fucking gay man.
Real Shit.
I agree.
I think that's the beginning of just crushing that altogether.
Yeah.
It needs to be crushed because we have to be honest about what the sport is.
Okay.
And there's a sport of fighting and if you take away some really super effective
maneuvers,
but you leave in a bunch of other super effective maneuvers,
like we got to be consistent and we're not consistent.
And there's a position where you can be kind of safe when you have your hand on
the mat and you can't be needing the face.
He can't be kicked in the face,
but that causes like safety first kind of behavior,
but also guys are taking advantage of it.
So higher game,
it's super unrealistic.
Gone from this point on.
It's fuck,
it's super unrealistic,
right?
Yup.
And then there are also a,
they're putting more emphasis on 10,
eight rounds.
You're gonna see more frequently,
10,
eight rounds now,
you know,
I was like,
what if,
what if they decided to not fucking finally,
that's way better.
Way Better.
12 to six elbows.
Those,
that's the one thing I went through the list.
I'm like,
how the fuck do they know how to address that?
Yeah.
But they did allow this new rule,
the hands on the mat rule.
I think soon to be more,
uh,
it's going to be more of a factor than even the 12 to six elbow.
I think it's very smart that they did it because I think you can still protect
yourself in those positions.
You know,
you're,
you're talking about someone who's trying to make their way back up to their
feet and ideally to strike or to grapple again,
it's a transitionary period.
So to say,
this guy can't kick you in a transitionary moving period.
It's stupid.
It's very stupid.
Yeah.
No,
they also changed a open hand policy.
You Know Jon Jones and trash brown.
You have,
you open it,
they're going to warn you and then I take a point.
If you're fighting with open hands,
you're going to have some issues that smart.
I think they should change.
The gloves are really do I think should be bad and pride.
I think they can go back to pride gloves.
I don't think it's going to be a,
I think if you look at the amount of,
I pokes in pride versus the amount of Ipos in the UFC.
I don't think you can.
That's because those guys are so juiced up.
If you hit their eyes,
they didn't give a fuck.
You know,
it was like sharps.
It's like I don't care what the rule.
I would like change as well,
and this sounds brutal,
but when you have someone's back,
you should be able to elbow him in the back of the fucking head.
Why can't can you can front of the head that's so intense.
In the front,
the back of the heads to no,
no,
no.
It's to tap quick.
You know,
back in the day when that shit was legal,
you didn't even have to have a good rear naked choke.
You put your own,
you get on their back,
you throw a couple of these and we're tapping quick,
different game.
Now my man,
you can't have that back to the lab.
You could had kicked someone with your Shin,
but here's the,
I kick them in the eyes,
but not just no,
but you can't kick him in the back of the head.
That's where it's weird transition.
When you're fighting,
you're standing up.
If you throw a head kick and you hit a guy in the back of the head and he goes
to sleep,
you don't get penalized at all.
You won by knockout every single time.
Guys,
brutal sport.
Almost always when they throw high kicks,
you'll see,
especially if like it goes like over the left shoulder safety,
both sand an orthodox and you throw a right high kick and it goes over the left
shoulder,
the first place it's hitting as the back of your head a lot with it wraps around
to imagine what everyone's records would look like in the history of MMA.
If that was never taken out and you'd been,
there would have been a lot of wins and losses switched up.
Oh yeah.
People forget that in the beginning when you'd get the back,
he's getting naked.
Do you remember?
You just ride the duty,
you fuck them up and they tap.
I'd rather see knees to a down opponent.
Is it was the guy saying,
what's the big deal?
Is it Ben Spiker versus Henzel Gracie?
Is that who it was?
And it was a judo guy and I remember John Lewis did it to somebody and the
tickets.
John Lewis,
the guy tapped him,
was fucking over.
That was done back of the head.
It's tough.
Eddy with the elbows,
man.
I don't know,
but isn't it really effective?
Explain how you people are getting kicked in the back of that and no one's
complaining about excuse.
You can control it.
If you kick,
you can control that.
If you throw a head kick and she goes over the shoulder,
lands with the instep,
it's almost always hitting the back of that.
I agree.
But same thing,
if you're throwing a huge right hand,
the guy goes to slip back of the head,
but there's a difference.
You can't control that.
You can't control for game.
It doesn't matter if it's on purpose or an [inaudible].
We just saw a guy get hit happens it guy,
it was just exactly what we were looking at.
Someone did a cartwheel kick and kick the back of someone's head.
Oh yeah,
he did a cartwheel kick and it's not intentional,
but that back of the head gets hit all the time with kicks gets hit with wheel
kicks to
what if you add,
uh,
what do you think?
Hit it with a hard impact.
One of those kicks that you're talking about or when you're riding on someone's
back and you're throwing an elbow,
those aren't nearly as hard as the head kicks there.
Not nearly as hard as her way on her stationary and you're really stuck dudes.
But really they should come gel up and they should.
You got to realize they can't just sit in that position and defend the choke.
No guys,
guys are punching away anyways.
Like you look at,
you look at a cane,
Travis Browne,
Cain just punches.
They're going to stop the fight when they get back there.
Guys really aren't going for the choke and let's sort of Jujitsu based.
Yeah,
they're really just rain down.
There's a big fucking difference between punching someone in the back of the
head on the band and then Jack is Elvin,
you're going to have so much fun last smash.
We're just going to tap unless you're rumble Johnson Rumble Johnson to brutal
leap when he had his back in that same way.
You know,
I mean that guy hits so God damn hard,
but I'm sort of shame Carlin Eddie in a lot of ways.
I agree with you.
I mean we should really consider it like it is a very effective technique.
The real question is like how dangerous is it?
Why is it more dangerous?
I guess it's cause the brainstem is there.
There's not as much for and pulling back the brainstem.
But uh,
well it seems that that is an area that's vulnerable.
Much like your eyeballs,
much like your temple.
It's like these are vulnerable areas and it's weird,
real weird to me that we take like even if it's the most vulnerable one,
why are we taking that spot and not really taking it out of the game either.
Like you can still hit guys there with head kicks and you did.
Why not just get guys in the dental thing?
If you want to end the fight,
just forget the cup.
Let's just start kicking the Dick.
Let's make it a real fuck.
You know what I'm saying?
You stop right there.
You stop at the Watson Man.
That's a real good question.
It is a good question.
Listen,
it's a good question because honestly,
if you look at the early UFC,
there was a lot of Dick fucking kick in.
Do you remember Keith Hackney and Joe Sawn Buck Yas Hackney's inside control
drop him bombs on Joe Sons',
Dick
and
Dick.
A big difference.
You can't fuck someone with the back of your head.
I'll go you the most fucked up one ever.
Big Dairy Goodrich and the Pedro.
Do you know this one?
I do.
Pig Daddy Goodridge reach into that dude's shorts and crushed his deck and brush
the paint.
Are we talking about on the podcast with phone
playdough?
Yeah,
that fat Dick like,
uh,
he uh,
he turned us nuts second that peanut butter.
That's what he said.
That's unacceptable.
The back of the head.
So how,
how,
how do you not understand the difference between your Johnson and the back of
your head?
How do you feel?
I'll probably get kicked in the fucking Johnson in the back of my brain.
Oh,
I dunno about,
wow.
A full blown kick from,
uh,
Mark Hunt or somehow bring the giant smile.
I let them kick my head.
Oh my God.
No,
pick your poison.
Both aren't,
yeah.
If he kicks you in the head,
your Dick might never work for him or you won't remember fucking again.
He would choose the Dick over the back of the head.
Hundred percent.
Wow.
Ooh,
that's the back of the head.
The head.
You're not gonna remember doing shit.
She could uh,
potentially can die.
Die from being kicked in the Dick.
It depends on like where is he kicking you in the Dick.
What if he kicks you like across the,
the like if your Dick is like kicks you like the Shin across the top.
Bring it.
I say bring it.
You know you might be able to deal with that.
It's just going to smash your Dick down a little bit and then let it go.
The trunk.
You hit the trunk.
I'm all good though.
Right?
But
yeah,
I guess
I never wore a cup in football.
I get fucking clean it all the time.
I think it looks like the front of a great white shark nose.
Just battle.
Just
sheer.
Jamie's got it up there.
I'll play it again.
I'm sorry.
That's what I want.
Cause this is Keith Hackney.
Me Mile.
He could have gone for the von flue choke.
Eddie Bravo.
Right?
He just said,
fuck the von flue choke.
Check out this von flu flu is there.
He'll give a fuck about the von flue when you're punching the man's Dick off.
I know.
It's amazing how many guys still hold on to the headlock when they,
when they get taken down.
Unbelievable.
They still there inside controlling.
They're still clamped down there and bring them a choice in which you want to
see.
That drives me fucking nuts.
Last time I saw it and get used though was a OSP against Cotita come off.
He did it against,
uh,
they,
I think,
oh no,
he took Cody down.
He's looking for it.
Yeah,
he did do it against nut Nikita.
I did.
It's an Akita.
A lot of power to fuck.
Yeah.
That fucking Krill off.
Holy Shit.
Did you see him against Ed Herman?
That head kick?
God,
not just the head kid who's
everything.
He kept kicking his body,
me and his body and just march,
remember he was a heavyweight start off at heavyweight.
Oh Dude,
that guy's 23.
God Damn.
He's like 23,
24 might be 24.
He's trouble.
He's super young and heavyweight and heats him real talented.
Middleweight he's middle weight.
He's middle way.
What do you mean by that?
Middle Week?
Yeah.
He's lied to everybody.
He's a big boy.
When did that Herman go to light?
Heavy.
We went to [inaudible].
This is his second fight.
It,
it is.
It really is.
Middle Way.
He won by knockout has no ed Herman's definitely light every way now.
He won by knockout and um,
his last fight before this,
uh,
Kurloff fight krill off just man,
he saw something.
He saw he's hit his stride for Scott.
Damn.
Karate is so good.
He's got that like kill Kachin karate style.
Who,
who did it knocked out?
Tim Boetsch.
That's right.
That was at light heavyweight.
Yeah.
Um,
this krill off guy man.
He something.
Yeah,
it's really cool to see that.
And they need that young blood there too.
Yep.
That's great man.
How about fucking Woodley too?
You won't talk about a smart business decision not fighting signal for that
title shot.
And it paid off.
Hey,
can you do,
can you explain to me,
uh,
still update,
feel that the selling of the UFC and how that works?
I know Dana's still on board,
right?
He's still part owners still.
He's still minority,
honestly,
have not even asked a single person with the dealers.
Oh,
really?
Yeah.
Is it a public though?
Yes.
I,
uh,
you know,
selling it or this is what I know they're selling it and Dana stays on.
Correct.
But I don't know what kind of deal.
Yaz or it's sold.
He's already,
he's still the president and the Fertittas are no longer involved in it at all.
There's different guys and all,
if there's a bunch of people involved now,
but nothing changes really.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
Dana's still still,
he's still on board as the president.
Yes.
He's somehow to make all the decisions,
like,
I don't know as much power.
I don't know.
I don't know that those details.
I don't,
you know,
I don't know how they did it,
but for one franker out done.
Wow.
They went such give us,
give us our billions.
We were fucking bought it.
That uh,
that agency only me and some other part,
I don't know how that works,
what they call it.
If it's a new organization that's bought the UFC,
I don't know how it works if they just came together and formed the new
underground.
So there's no more three and the beginning no more Zuph no more phone.
Just you up saying the same company.
But the road is too and you know what man,
we as fans that are sitting here watching the fights right now,
we owe the Fertittas everything.
Fuck yeah.
If they didn't have the balls and the money and the,
the,
the risk taking an acumen.
They didn't know when to stay in and when to bail and how they could turn this
thing around.
They're brilliant.
They deserve,
if they are with Eddie and I used to always dream of every Eddie and I when we
were fans back in the old days when nobody,
you couldn't give dark,
didn't get it.
You couldn't even get it on cable was banned from cable.
You had to get direct TV.
I had direct TV specifically so I can get the UFC.
You need a two scrooge McDuck to go.
Yeah,
we'll see what we can do with this thing.
Dude.
Those guys,
they,
they came in at the perfect time.
It was dead in the water and through all their risk taking and all.
They're just smart business decisions,
smart promotional decisions,
and then they're brilliant man,
and then putting together the ultimate fighter.
It's amazing.
That guy just need a minute.
You know what they're going to do.
You know what I think they're going to do and their,
their,
their passion is football.
Yup.
They're going to bring the Raiders to Vegas.
They might,
that's what I think too.
They might just,
they're trying to do you hurt.
You must've heard that you can't just make that shit up.
Might be,
they might build a gold space ship and just fly over Vegas
or they might be able to go
like those fucking star Trek just fucking circle.
Just like a big giant hovercrafts fucking swim naked on the roof of it and just
fucking teleport mad.
Bitches and lives don't,
I mean if nothing changes,
they're still going to get killed.
Seats at the UFC.
They don't give a fuck about seats.
They can sit right next to me.
Is Really gonna change when their line,
no,
they can go backstage anytime.
They can just walk and just be like all of us in here.
So for rogue and they could buy all of them.
Skies are beautiful.
We all,
we owe them,
we owe frank and we all the sessions.
Football go them big time.
Especially Lorenzo.
So that's what I love.
So and their sons and their sons a fucking stud at Notre Dame.
He's passionate about and me too.
But he knows that MMA,
it's like their work is done as far as like getting it mainstream.
It's on Fox.
I mean it's,
it's on television all the time.
It's,
it is.
Main street's a mainstream,
crazy,
super popular sport.
So cash out.
You don't get to their level without yeah.
They're like,
look,
we got this.
We're good.
I'm giving you guys a fucking killer business.
Give me the cash.
I'm just going to watch it from the outset.
Fucking with the exact same seat.
Nothing changes.
He can enjoy it with Dana.
Dana,
you good?
You stay here.
We're the fuck out.
You good.
See Ya.
He was our billions.
Probably enjoy it more,
you know,
cause he can just relax and clear.
The tightest stayed.
That's great.
I mean it's made a big difference.
Look at this position.
It's great that you stayed too.
You know,
Amanda came real close to not real close.
Did you really?
Oh,
you're telling me that I'd never bought it.
I was real close.
Really?
Yeah.
I had to make sure that I was thinking about it correctly.
You know?
I really had to spend time thinking about what I was doing.
I definitely knew that I had a reduced the schedule that was a,
there was no way I was going to go back to doing as many times as I was doing it
before.
It's just,
I don't think it's good for you,
man.
I don't think flying that much is good for you.
Ah,
no.
It's not nothing.
No,
we're not made to be in there.
And anything that recycled air and shit flying every week.
You're like,
road guys like comics too.
They have this look about them.
They look like shit.
They look weary.
Yeah.
I just don't think it's good for you and by the way,
man,
I wrote about radiation and space.
Pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure I'm an expert.
I guess it is radiation though,
right?
When you go up in space,
I think it's probably worse,
I think.
I think I read that it's more radiation than you get when you get an x ray every
time you get to plan.
Really?
Yeah.
Let's see if that's true.
It might've made that up and then you're on the plane for what,
12 hours?
14 hours on time.
I just went to Italy.
That was,
that was at least keep that shit.
I don't fly along the five hours,
five hours,
but it's in Italy.
He's amazing.
It's worth getting a little radiated.
Nah,
you don't think so?
No,
I won't do it real now.
What did you go through?
Do we have great Italian food and security line?
Do you opt out,
but do you opt out in the security line?
I got to,
I got the fastpass son.
Well he was never as opting out of the scanner.
Hell no man.
Fucking u s of a,
they don't let you opt out.
Wait a minute.
Yeah,
you can opt out,
but then they pat you down and shit and go through your luggage Dick.
Dude.
It's the craziest thing how they're allowed to touch your Dick.
As long as it's with the back of the hand they tell you.
Yeah,
cause we're going to have to check on my hand.
That's where I'm going to hit your sensitive areas.
Is that cool?
I don't mind.
As long as it's the back of the hands.
Fuck yeah,
go ahead.
There's less nerves on the back of your hand.
Does it feel good?
It's not
exactly,
it's the back of my head.
If I did this,
that now it's up now.
Well there you go.
Risk on a flight as small as cosmic rays sound scary,
but radiation risk on a flight as small.
See if that was right about you get as much as you get when you get x Ray.
See if that's correct.
That might be total bullshit.
What the fuck is pilots and the flight attendants or get twice the incidence of
melanoma compared to general population,
which could be part of where that comes from.
Oh yeah,
no shit.
Fuck all that shit to you Epstein.
The Hanson pilot.
They'll look up till one o'clock yeah,
that's what you saw sky.
Hell No.
All the time.
Breathing,
recycled air and other people's farts and just fucking hanging with the guy next
to you for hours.
Dammit.
Fuck that job.
We haven't said a word about this fight.
I've fucking
fighting each other recently and we get together.
We have so much to talk.
It's good fight so far.
Those guys got us back.
Now,
Eddie Bravo p case in point,
elbows dropping,
right?
You get that back mount.
You immediately go right there,
right?
You have that shit on Fox son,
boom,
boom.
Saved the back of the head.
But wouldn't it be a position where you would have to protect that?
Okay,
no cup.
How about you just fucking,
he'll kick him in the nuts.
How seriously,
how come it's okay to,
he'll kick a guy in the temple because you didn't say,
well the elbow guy,
the guy could have his head sideways and you could smash down the point of your
elbow into his temple and that's illegal strike because I think with the
brainstem and you don't have as much protection back here.
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
Well sits like the connections,
the critical connection to the brain.
Yes.
The fight would be over.
Yeah.
I wonder like what,
I mean obviously it's dangerous to get hit anywhere in the head,
but I wonder like how much more dangerous it is a bit to you.
It's
fine.
It's already happening all the time.
What's your on promoting it?
No one's,
no one's promoting it,
but we're not,
we're not changing the result of a fight.
If somebody wheel kicks a guy and clips the back of his head,
if he says shit happens all the time.
Yeah,
it's almost that serious.
They should like Dq,
the guy for those head kicks and they,
if they do the replay,
the instant replay that goes,
you know what you lost.
Did you ever see a Ernesto hoost versus a Maury Smith God forever ago.
Check this.
Oh Jamie,
pull that up.
This is um,
this is like a classic example of a behind the head head kick.
Me Too.
And,
and Maurice as well.
I love more from Denver son.
Boy.
He's a bad mother.
Rutgers kicking in the fucking face.
Maurice's seriously skillful.
Kickboxer to hell.
And I look at this,
watch this go boom.
Well that's right on the back of them.
Yeah,
I mean absolutely perfectly.
This is exchange,
but look how good who's two is,
check this exchange out in the middle of it blocks the knee and Kinda hip
dexterity.
I mean,
he's always done a full split.
Well look how he comes back down.
Yeah,
look at this.
But look,
watch,
look at this distance though.
Me and check.
Check this.
Uhmm I mean that is just artwork or was it over the top of the shoulder?
That's the correct reaction.
Your opponent throws a knee.
You know that you got time,
there's no way he's going to get that neat back.
He just timing the movement and like a guy like Anderson,
like he would time like when,
how,
when you would put your feet down when you would,
when you would mill.
So he knows that if you're doing this,
you're going here and then maybe you have a pattern.
Maybe you have something to do afterwards.
Maybe you stay in the pocket and grab,
maybe you back up.
But he just timed it perfect.
As soon as that knee came down he had a feeling more east would be there.
That's why I was just on that kick 10,000 times too.
Yeah.
And the way brought it around behind his shoulder but from that so hard crazy
thing there is from that distance is fucking nuts.
They'll do,
they were like,
like uppercut.
Yes.
That's nuts.
And he can't catch it head and is the,
the flexibility of the hips as what you really have to have.
Cause you've got to have that ability to drop down over God.
Damn,
that was beautiful.
That was amazing.
Fucking clip.
And he's such a beast.
Ernesto,
who's was so I sat him.
Bob Sapp.
Fuck yeah,
that I can't Bob Sapp beat him twice.
I can't believe it.
Well,
cause he fucked up
his shoulder on one than Bob.
Just kept kicking at it.
Oh Man.
That they fucked up shoulder bad.
And Bob realizing and kept kicking it.
Oh
look at this.
I'm still waiting for the first Japanese necktie and look at that,
right?
That boom right there,
right.
Dropped down to that level.
It would be over right there.
It's done.
Put Your Lego.
But he might even go forward and you don't think he knows it,
but you know what he still has?
He sees,
Oh damn,
that's pretty good doors.
He short arm in it,
so it's the guy.
Stay good.
Stay in flat.
Explain that today.
Oh bill,
he didn't really have a full,
it wasn't sunk in.
It was like this.
That's why on short arm and neck,
the guy get defense to saint flat.
See the handout,
deep hand is if you're like the fingers are right here,
you can just tell that and keeping off.
You'd know who I still want to fucking seat in the UFC before all this bullshit
is out.
Let me tell you.
Yes.
Hold on.
He,
he hasn't fought in the UFC APP wrestler.
He's a wrestler.
Latin American electric low.
Jesus Christ.
You know it is.
Yeah,
I know who it is,
homeboy.
I forget.
[inaudible] been around.
They might do it.
Well,
they might do it now
and us fucking smile with his arms.
Jesus crashed.
Sinewy steel courted,
courted flesh.
Hardened the heart man.
Um,
do we have a bottle opener and glasses?
It's about to get loose now.
New Shit.
You thought Dick talk was too much.
What about Jelly?
D is getting his fucking blue belt right?
Isn't that amazing?
Cool man.
It's so beautiful.
So come on man,
that's amazing.
So beautiful soul into Jujitsu.
Loves it.
Really did.
Like it is saving his life.
He's so into it.
He talks about you to get to every time we talk on the phone and talks about how
we did it,
he's training all the Goddamn time.
He goes in on Sundays and,
and,
and does Jujitsu show into it.
And he's incredibly humble about it.
Like he never eats always.
Every time we talked about Jujitsu,
he says,
listen,
Eddie Bravo,
I'm terrible,
I'm terrible.
But you know,
every day I'm getting a little bit better,
a little bit better,
but I'm terrible.
I suck.
But he's tapping people out.
He's getting taps.
Of course he is passing the guard.
He's getting,
he,
he loves twist her side control.
He gets the Camorra from twitch.
Just I control it was Eddie Bravo,
that torture side control.
He said that to me once.
I wasn't even sure he's being serious about Joe Rogan.
Now I know why you liked that twist is side control dog.
That's your spot.
I could see you camping out there.
Joe Rogan
turn it towards your feet.
He is so,
I love it.
It's,
it's really um,
it's given him a like something to work towards and like it's given them an
awesome way to do like
real rigorous exercise.
Yeah.
And get healthy man.
That's what you want.
If you want to be healthy.
Yeah.
Well,
you also,
you can't ever give Joey advice,
you know,
to Joey's a strong man and he's a,
he's a proud man and you know,
he's beautiful.
This is just,
he's the rarest of rare birds.
What makes him who he is though?
There's certain guys like that,
man,
you don't want to change that for,
you can't,
you know,
I've known,
I mean,
I've known Joey for a long time.
You got to just let Joey be joy.
But what he is,
is awesome,
you know?
Yeah.
And I just loved the fact that he's a,
he's gotten like really into being healthy,
really into Jujitsu,
really into comedy man,
his comedy,
he's killing it.
He's traveled all over the country now doing gigs every way,
selling out everywhere.
Joey's sound out like five shows before he even gets into town.
It was destroying.
Destroying this podcast is bigger than ever.
Yeah.
He's just,
I'm so happy for that guy.
I'm just so happy.
I know him.
His jujitsu story of how he got into it is very,
the most inspirational digit two story ever.
Man.
There's a,
that needs to be a documentary is uh,
uh,
um,
how he got turned on to Jujitsu and,
and following,
following him around,
train,
you know,
videotaping his training and all that.
That's so inspirational.
His story.
Yeah.
You know,
if you listen to that story and you don't want to do Jujitsu,
you need a psychiatric evaluation.
This is a good fight,
man.
We're missing a good fight.
Yeah,
I agree man.
Um,
but you know,
kind of Jujitsu has that effect on people,
so it's a really exciting,
fun thing to do.
What are you showing me?
Their buddy?
Is that Japanese necktie?
Um,
I can't see.
Yeah,
it looks a like a Doris.
Let me see it again.
It looked like a,
like a guilt.
You gotta take it from the top,
go back,
go back.
It's kind of like it.
No,
not as is,
it's like a guillotine type doors,
right?
The body.
Is it,
what he's doing with his body is he's placing it in the exact same place as you
would with the Japanese necktie.
Just his grip is different.
Right.
So it's like a Japanese necktie with a different grip but similar.
It's like a guillotine.
Japanese men.
Yeah.
It's in between and Jamie for all the people that are listening,
what was that fight that we were just watching them and just talking about some
retarded and I couldn't tell by that name or something.
Maybe it was a Japanese necktie.
Say it one more time,
Jamie.
I was pulled out and you can look and read them.
We'll say it one more time anyway.
It looks like a Japanese name.
Talk to me.
I mean if you look at his placement of his left elbow.
Yeah,
his left shoulder.
Those way down.
See how far down his left shoulder,
his and his,
his perfect dickheads.
Perfectly locked in.
Go back.
Here it is again.
Here.
You're saying this,
the Japanese necktie.
It is.
Wait a minute.
No,
no.
It's close.
It's like in between and between a guillotine and the Japanese actor.
He might have his own version of his work.
No,
it's not quite the same,
but it's still the fact that you could see his hands in the front.
It has got to stay in the back of the form of guilt.
Yeah,
but isn't it interesting though that there's like a lot of different ways to
grip the guillotine?
Right.
There's a lot of different ways to hold your hand,
but they're all,
they're all considered gay teens but this choke,
which is like pretty similar,
like the head is trapped.
It's twisted,
left shoulders down,
hands are coming up like this.
The neck is getting wrench and crank.
It's getting wrench and cranked in both positions.
Right.
Manpower for that.
It's getting cranked and [inaudible] has arm evolved because the guy got that
under hook on you.
He's got like say if I'm getting it and he's got his under hook on the left
side.
Yeah.
My,
my arm is a over hooking his arm and then that's going behind his head and
that's why I'm clamping down.
I clamped down with like a scissors grip,
but that guy looked like he had like something like this.
It was like almost like a gable grip right out on.
I could be wrong,
but that didn't look like a Japanese Necktie,
but I couldn't.
It was hard to tell what the,
I dunno what it runs like an arm and guillotine,
but whatever it was.
That guy's neck was getting cranked too.
It wasn't just a the choke.
It was a,
it was a neck crank.
Real bad trap.
Where the chest?
One more time.
Let me see it one more time.
It's super similar.
Look at his right elbow.
If he's doing a Japanese Necktie,
his right elbow should be t rex here,
but he looked like he was like that.
Yeah.
Maybe he just has a wide open way of doing it.
Can we see it again Jamie?
Maybe it's just not the best way to do it.
Mother Fucker,
her Amy do.
You don't want to show it to him and y'all talk to him on the show.
Bro.
Don't do this like he gets passionate about his work.
This is important as Kim is calen stomping on the grapes or some shells coming.
I know it's coming in my sink.
A teenage girl,
he went in there and got blueberries and cheese.
You I'm wrong.
Are So strange.
We're going to start with a light by bad ESCO.
I'm wrong about that though.
The right elbow wouldn't be t rex in it because he couldn't be,
because you have the overlook.
There's a way it can be can be t rex cause it's got the overhead.
So it is a Japanese necktie.
Fuck.
It's so hard to tell.
But he got the left shoulder down.
Right,
which is where you,
you wouldn't be necessarily there in a Doris,
you would want the right shoulder down.
Right?
Correct.
So the way he's doing it is totally a Japanese necktie.
Yeah it did because the head's trap the exact same way.
Trap the head.
The neck is cranked in the exact same direction and also he's got the leg tied
up,
which I like.
I liked how he did it to how he tied up the near side leg.
It's for sure not a dark because his hips,
his shoulder always wondered gentlemen,
gentlemen to fight companions.
Companions.
That actually answered a question that I had.
I'm looking at it right now and I was always like,
what's the best leg to tie up?
Cause I would always tie up whatever legacy matter.
I always said that.
But if you look at that,
if he ties up the left leg,
he doesn't have that.
He can't move with that right leg.
Or excuse me if he ties up the right leg,
the way he's got it,
like there,
he can't,
that other legs aren't helping them as much.
Correct.
If he ties up the other leg,
then he can get that right leg under him and he can use it to manipulate.
Is Russia more pressures is he wasn't using.
He immediately,
Shit stomped on dudes.
Right thigh with his left foot and that's how you escape you.
You'd get your leg out and spin.
You got to get,
if you can get that leg free,
you're fucked.
I know.
Like look,
look,
look how he has his legs.
He's got to kick his leg free.
He's got to kick it free or you're done.
That's the first thing you gotta do this.
You would kick it.
He would kick out the right leg.
Yeah.
Push it away.
The leg that's caught.
Use your free leg.
It's just like a leg lock.
Someone's attacking that leg.
Kick it free.
But here's a question.
Here's a real good question.
If you were in a position like that or somewhere similar,
and will you have access to kick the knee?
Can you kick someone's knee on the ground when you're grappling with it?
Yeah.
How come no one's ever done that?
No one's like attack the knee.
Like no one's ever been in a position.
Like maybe they have site control or something like that and they'd drop acts
kicks down on someone's knee,
just attack their knee from there.
I'd have to see it,
but it feels like you should be able to definitely attack the thighs.
You're saying,
you're saying in a grappling tournament like,
no,
no.
In a grappling position,
someone who has someone in but does it,
you ever see it?
No.
Maybe that'll fuck up your balance,
but,
but in that guy,
in that situation where that guy is getting choked,
if he could have kicked,
if he kicked at the knee itself,
like that would be,
this isn't a good position for it.
No.
He's like,
can do his job.
He's got his shit that like free.
He's got to kick that leg.
Freeing and it's,
this is not,
I guess not going to exam.
You have flat on your back.
Is there ever a time where you can kick someone's legs when you're holding them
down
and pride.
A good combo would be if you get them out,
pop off,
stand up stones.
Yeah.
Walk away.
He did that to Dan Henderson.
Pop up on the mountain and you stand up.
Boom.
Like that's something you'd have to Pratt.
That's a,
that's a combo as a combo and it's so effective.
Move.
It's weird.
Like what effective moves are legal and what are not.
One of the most under utilized kicks,
um,
in my opinion are those,
uh,
Hixon those that a trail leg curl kicks while you have someone's back that's
legal.
Now it's legal.
It wasn't,
no,
it wasn't a tax to the kidney.
They were considered a tax to the kidney.
It's one of the new revisions in this.
No,
no,
I'm not talking about from full guard.
I'm not talking about,
you're talking about from back mouth.
You have the guys back.
Remember what Hickson was doing to Zulu.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Those kicks to the abdomen.
So the abdomen,
why aren't they doing it?
Why aren't people doing that?
Who was the last guy that did write a book?
I feel like Cole Miller did.
That should be normal shit.
Yeah.
Cole,
Cole Miller do that in front of you and then the guy's defendant and then he
comes up and chokes exactly how you set up the jokes.
It's true.
Well
budgeted Penn was now at least guys can attack when they're on their back.
They can kidney kick and it makes someone to bark.
Oh beautiful.
I'm happy they're making preps are very good.
Barry shot.
So,
so when you,
when you're,
when somebody is in your card,
you can do kidney,
kidney kicked them rice.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's huge.
It's got to protect the kid.
Well you get not going to be able to just lay there.
There'll be,
it's another offensive option for the grappler.
So if you're in a full guard position and someone has good kicks,
like say if you get some Anderson silver type character was good kicks,
he can fuck your backup man.
God.
And when you do get free,
you break free.
You could be all bunched up and tightened up just from eating those heel kicks,
danger there that you can actually create.
You can cause internal bleeding.
That'll,
that'll mess with them later on.
Yeah.
This is going to be a lot of internal bleeding,
son.
Really?
You're in a cage fight,
man.
We gotta stop the kidney injury.
Listen man,
how can you say you could stop kidney injuries but you won't stop a spinning
back kick to the ribs.
Yeah,
but that's one kick.
I feel like it was.
It's a constitution as goes,
you know.
Listen man,
if someone like some elite guy like a,
a Wonderboy spinning back kicks you in the ribs.
Yeah.
You're going to be,
he's crying over him kitchen.
The real,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
Ask Brock how that dude over him that that left round kick to the ribs that he
landed on Brock before he put them away.
Ah,
fuck off.
Oh my God.
Giant thighs and that normous ass.
I'd rather get kicked.
He was an ovary and po and ovary.
When he fought,
when he fought Brock was Uber him too.
There was,
when he was at his biggest,
did you notice when Pilo gay take body shots like that?
There's a pause.
There's that like they're like they go and then they fall.
They say,
I'm not sure,
but they say that's because your liver gets lifted up and when it falls back
down.
Somebody told me that that's why there's that pause.
So you watch guys who get hit so of you guys got watch.
If you watch it,
there's anybody that takes,
there's a pause,
you know he used to train,
fall,
hit like that and fallen down.
Leo Machida,
he used to train as if he got hit in the body and practice falling down to his
back.
Whoa.
First Guy I've ever seen do it.
One of his buddies,
I forget who it was,
lost a fight by getting a body shot and he'd just kind of crumbled,
went to the ground and Leila,
I was like,
no,
we do this all the time.
And then showed him like that he kept doing reps like in Hin balling up into
into garden,
bringing the guy down and your card to give you time,
um,
is how is he suspended right now?
Yeah,
I'm not sure.
I think so.
I know he just opened up a gym in California,
but he,
something happened.
He tested,
yes.
Reverse with the same thing.
Dan Henderson.
Right.
And He tests positive.
What was it for?
I Dunno Jamie.
See if he could find that out.
That fucking card though.
There's your car to the year.
As far as number of white paper,
the number was
better.
The cards get better now cause you'd think you get new blood in there.
I bet the new owners want to go.
Let's fucking,
none of that's new blood.
The blood brother.
That's how new blood,
I mean the power of you mean,
oh you only might sailing the suits.
They might say,
Hey,
let's fucking make,
let's come in without fucking with some fire and blow up these cards.
Let's just get crazy with it or keep it the same.
Nothing.
Just so much you can do.
You need a guy who loves fighting and knows fighting did it.
Usually they'll suits,
don't know.
Yeah.
Corporate big corporations that get involved doesn't necessarily mean that's why
Dana stayed on board.
He,
you know,
he's a fucking genius with fighting,
so Joe silver,
he can't get rid of those guys and have suits who you can never,
it would never work.
You can never have a suit run the company either.
You need,
Dana was a complex design to a crazy place.
They knows.
You know.
You don't have to be a genius to come up with dream matchup.
This is going to be an interesting fight.
Average friend.
This is your boy,
right?
Correct.
Zak Cummings,
he's fighting this upon Zenobia Yoga.
Who is a beast.
Tad Cummings is a welterweight.
That is crazy.
That is such a big dude.
Is He really?
Oh yeah man.
Like he's happy.
He's a big fellow.
I mean he's got to walk around well over 200 pounds.
I think he's an underdog in this fight.
Ponds and Nobel's.
No joke,
man.
I no joke.
This fucking,
she's telling you I did yourself.
I know it's,
and this is a nice Barbaresco.
This is 2008.
It's like a meal gentlemen.
Look at that.
Oh yeah.
Pounds of,
nobody was a scary guy.
Serious knockout striker beast of a guy
who was [inaudible].
He's this handsome guy,
but just put in a headlock and him.
Yeah.
Everybody pretty buddy.
It's such a crazy,
crazy look even.
Yeah,
it's tough fight.
Tough fight to call.
Um,
what w what do we need to talk about?
We need to talk about the Tyron Woodley fine.
She spells a,
I'll tell you what I do.
If Woodley,
if I'm scrooge McDuck if I'm Dana,
this is what you do.
You,
so the,
the,
the loyal pure.
So the sport can say Wonderboy is next,
right?
We can't do that cause cell that paper,
you get 300 bucks.
That ain't happen.
And neither one's a big draw.
It sucks to say,
I love both those guys area.
Let's just be real here.
So you do the GSP fight to make Woodlea star.
So he can be a paper view headliner.
Let's cause he's not a headline.
Let's get more realistic.
Um,
if GSP actually wants to fight,
which he does.
Is that true?
He asked for the fight.
Um,
if he actually wants to fight,
I feel like GSP gets a free pass.
He gets a free pass right to the front.
Like Lesnar.
No,
no,
no.
I mean you got to let him fight for the title.
He's George.
Goddamn Saint Peters stepped away as the champion championing title.
I,
that's what I feel.
So the question is does he fight now and do they,
do they fight?
Does he fight Tyron or does he fight the winner of Tyron versus Wonderboy or
does Wonderboy get or does rather,
um,
does tire and get paid and he fights Nick Diaz.
Well,
he get paid more if he fights nick DSD.
Listen,
if I was Tyron Woodley,
I'd be asking for the Nick Diaz fight.
That's what he's doing,
why he wants,
he wants to GSP or nick,
if he's a bigger guy,
doesn't want wonderful.
He goes,
I want money.
You know how much stoner money is out there?
Not Nick Diaz.
If I don't think the UFC maybe even realizes what they have.
I think they do because they put up Nick Diaz,
hey,
they should be putting up with everything and more.
Listen,
he's the best.
All this like flying him to press conferences,
give him a pass,
give them a pass on that.
Like what is he going to say this going to be so you're just going to annoy you.
Just let them try.
Let them try.
We all know what Nick Diaz is capable of real,
you know,
it's scary.
It was how much press Nate Diaz is,
but I love it.
He's been doing a lot,
a lot of progress.
He's on that.
Conor McGregor press tours
bashes Wonderboy Thompson says he should be able to pick his next opponent.
Well as Dana White,
if we want to entertainment and you want numbers,
you do GSP or or Nikki is 100% if you're appears to have the sport,
you do Wonderboy.
I agree.
I agree 100% but the bottom line is Tyron Woodley is the fucking champion.
And when you're they champion,
you can say all the crazy shit you want that you can't take your magic.
My opponent.
Nope.
I want to get the money.
That's fucking triangle Wonderboy and fucking Fox sports one year on a Wednesday
night and you're going to shut your fucking mouth.
No,
no,
you can't say that.
That's exactly what they can do.
The same car GSP versus Nick Diaz and we'll do versus Wonderboy.
Same car.
Nah,
fuck that.
Cause you're him killing
versus Nick Diaz cards,
man call.
No super cards.
No listen,
let it spread it out.
Do you know that John Danaher made a post recently saying that GSP,
he put it on Instagram saying that GSPS camp for the Nick Diaz fight was one of
the best camps he ever had came out of it.
Injury-Free super healthy.
And then the night before the fight drank some watermelon juice that had been
sitting out for too long and got deathly ill,
was throwing up all night.
The watermelon juice drinking.
I Dunno.
Probably something crazy bet.
And so he was,
he came to that fight,
he came in a fight depleted and they devise a strategy of conserving his energy
and not engaging too much.
Wow.
And when to time is take down,
she goes crazy.
And then when the,
when they came in to see the wraps,
he was talking about they wrapped GSPs hands and uh,
the uh,
Ds camp wanting to see them wrap his hands.
So they had to come in and then he said that George had to like imitate this a
sense of vitality,
you know,
like,
cause he was like so depleted,
right?
He had to like pretend he feels fucking great.
I feel fucking great.
How did it go?
Kick some ass,
you know?
And he's like,
wow,
pump it up.
And then when they left here was like,
Oh God,
God,
I don't have time to do this shit myself,
champ.
But didn't make DSA that someone drugged him in that fight.
Could you imagine if someone drug both of them,
if that's what was going on?
They didn't even know it was so many drug.
Both guys,
some asshole.
It was like maybe two guys were gamblers.
Drug is bro,
fuck gamblers.
Let me,
let me tell you something man.
If you are around some shady degenerate gamblers and they put some money on you
and they see Eddie Bravo out for the night in the town and they know that you're
supposed to be fighting someone the next day and they can drug you and jack the
fight.
If you read the book about,
there's a book written by David Remnick about um,
the fight between Muhammad Ali and Sonny Liston.
And in round,
I think seven,
they put something on Sonny Liston gloves that blinded him and he said,
I can't see,
I can't see.
And I think it was done.
Dee who said kept moving.
Just moving.
Yeah,
just keep moving and keep boxing.
And it was a huge turning point.
I said they put something on the gloves.
Yup.
One but they did some shady shit.
But Henry Cooper,
that's a tinfoil hat.
He wouldn't let anybody touch his water bottle because they thought they were
going to poison him.
So he had his water bottle wrapped.
I sounds like he rap tape around as well.
I believe that
if you watch the Sonny Liston fight,
it's clear.
You hear him say it in the corner.
I've watched the fight.
It's a,
it's an interesting one too because I'm,
uh,
Mike Tyson's old manager was the narrator for the fight.
You know,
Mike Tyson's old manager,
he had that,
uh,
the Jewish guy that died,
who was his confidant?
It was,
God damn it.
There was a couple different guys that handled Mike Tyson after something.
Jacobs,
the black Jewish guy.
Now he's a white guy.
It was something,
God dammit,
it was a Kevin Rooney something Jacobs and that was like the whole crew that was
leftover.
Anyway,
this guy was the,
uh,
the narrator for those old fights because they didn't really have audio for them
to like was correct.
But more interesting example is when Ali's camp cheated,
when Henry Cooper caught him with a left hook,
Henry Cooper caught him with a left hook and sat him down.
Henry Cooper was his bad ass British heavyweight boxer back in the day.
And when Muhammad Ali was still Cassius clay and recoup or correct him and he
went down and when he went back to the corner,
he had no idea what the fuck was going on.
He was out on his feet.
So Angelo Dundee took a razor blade to his gloves,
cut his gloves open.
So you got to change the gloves.
The gloves are cut.
It moves smart.
That Dante's shit smart dude back then.
So Ali has a chance to recover.
Several minutes go by.
They change the gloves,
they retire him up there.
Retape them several minutes go by and then he fucks.
Henry Cooper up gets get some cut and winds up stopping.
I'm on cuts.
Did it work?
Yeah,
but don't want to see it.
See,
watch Henry Cooper drops Muhammad Ali because I mean dude,
he got Joe romped like that's very similar to your role at UL in the corner.
By the time you were just that Tim Kennedy fight,
Sam Kennedy should have gotten a wheel gate kept Tim Kennedy should have gotten
the wind because he was not willing to get off his stool and fight.
At the end of the round,
he knew correct.
It was the end of the,
uh,
the buzzer.
But then again,
when,
when are we going to see him fight?
Tim Kennedy Police would fucked up.
Tim Kennedy after that fight.
Is that here?
Those are the gloves,
the actual glove that it was split.
Wow.
She got the fuck out of that video of him cutting it.
They like covered each other up.
And if they weren't doing videos back then,
they had a film of the fight and then you know,
there was probably one hand you're saying there's no concrete evidence.
Well that gloves,
the gloves are caught up and then they have the gloves.
It happened naturally.
It could be,
it could be like,
hey,
you're losing brand.
See the biggest transparency theorist and he just
watches left hook,
check it out right here.
Right here against real fam.
Oh,
shot tog.
I've never seen him get dropped like that.
That's what I'm talking about too.
He got fucked up,
look at him and that's the end of the round.
The very end of the round he gets up and he sits down.
So,
I mean,
there is like one second before we get this check.
This left hook.
Ooh,
that shit is perfect.
British pounds.
The corner of the whole minute.
Can we see that?
I don't know.
It's a good question.
Oh,
you can see him in front of him and they put smelling salts to,
that was the other thing they used to do.
You smelling salts,
you know,
we're missing your boys that Cummins and ponds and Obo throw in dignity.
Dayday down my story with the cocaine and all that.
It's supposed to be legit.
Is that legit?
I never heard of liquid cocaine being drank like that.
That which is,
it could have been some other stimulant.
She doesn't have to have been you,
but everybody was like,
it's cocaine is cocaine speed could easily been speed.
I think you're dead,
right?
He did.
Yeah.
Either way.
Your party,
that Guy Panama Lewis was busted for a bunch of different things and one of them
was,
he had this fight,
uh,
between a Billy Collins,
I think it was Billy Collins Jr was his name.
And the other guy was a Louie Resto and um,
they took Louie Resto is padding out of his gloves and when he fought this kid,
Billy,
I think it was Billy Collins Jr I think that was his name.
GMC,
if that's correct.
Louie Resto.
It's a Louie Resto glove controversy.
So anyway,
Panama Lewis was the guy who did that too.
He was involved in that.
Like he,
uh,
he was banned from boxing after that.
He wasn't going right.
He was so,
it was a cheater.
He had went through that thing with Aaron Pryor and then he'd went through this,
this new one.
But who knows what the fuck was in that bottle.
It could've been anything.
It could've been a stimulant,
but it could have been like some sort of fucking sport drink.
It could have been,
you know,
something with some sort of a nutritional supplement in it that maybe is illegal
now.
It wasn't illegal then.
Who the fuck knows?
I don't know what he put in there.
I think they might've used speed a lot.
I know Andre Agassi in his,
uh,
in his autobiography he talks about how his dad used to give him speed head and
like in the middle,
cause you're not just getting those,
those matches last four,
five,
they're five matches until a long time,
four hours,
four hours or whenever it was.
And he would,
he would give his son and his brother's,
he'd be like,
Hey,
you got to take this.
And you know,
pat may up those little fuckers went nuts on it.
Oh yeah.
Well that was the,
to that,
to Mike,
his speed was a huge thing in baseball as well.
A lot of guys were taking speed and even Adderall.
It's always been that all still big medical school.
Medical school was always big.
It was always big among pipe fighter pilots.
Louie Resto and who,
who was it?
What was the other gentleman's name?
Billy Collins.
Was it Collins?
Everybody see the name is a documentary about it called counseling.
Have you used Adderall?
Billy Conn?
No,
I have not.
You haven't used the,
I don't know Billy Collins Jr.
Yeah,
so I was right.
That's good stuff.
I did it once in college with for some final write.
This paper I took it and dude,
I was a chatty Kathy.
I got nothing done.
I sort of walked by like,
Hey,
where are you doing?
Nothing fucking up for six hours.
Just talking straight.
You boy Zack comments just landed a hard body kick.
Dude.
I didn't watch one round on these guys.
These guys are welterweights.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
There's giants.
Cummings is a big boy.
How?
How big is he,
Brendan?
Six one.
Whoa,
that's cool.
We okay?
Definitely.
It looks like it.
Oh,
okay.
Clip.
Here we go.
Ooh.
He likes it.
Oh Shit.
Just get down and they'll be all right back up.
Woo.
Just missed with the hook of death.
The breathless to that six foot.
Yeah.
Jodie,
why one of these barriers and knocked your socks off?
No,
I'm good.
I mean they're,
fuck.
I've been balls deep in Paris and she might be the best black,
big kick to the body by coming to the end of the round.
This is,
this is so silly,
Jason.
Stay them is reviving is Charles Bronson character.
That guy would fuck both of you up.
Hey man,
easy and Olympic athletes.
He was an Olympic diver.
That's a big deal actually.
Sure.
Jessica Alba back.
Tommy Lee Jones,
a bad guy.
Oh,
he looks very day.
He loves
resurrect the same glasses.
If they made that movie good,
you'd be upset.
Yeah.
That was a really good movie with an awesome plot.
It's kind of hilarious.
They took the guy in tap than you had to wait for character development.
Where's the actions?
If somebody's gonna get shot with the fuck,
I've been 20 minutes and then it's Goddamn movie do.
He took the guy that made x Mokena and they made him direct the new mechanic.
You'd be like,
what the fuck is going on?
Who wrote this movie?
You were wrong about,
but that fucking Cloverfield.
How dare you didn't like that?
No.
The ending sucked,
right?
Yes.
I thought it was crazy.
I thought it was amazing until the ending.
Right?
And then he's like,
what the fuck?
Meanwhile that all that check could.
I'm,
I'm man,
I'm in.
I'll take both ends.
Damn it.
I like it.
I like the ending of the first one.
I like the ending of the sound was so psi [inaudible] stupid fucking Shit.
I love bigfoot.
I wrote this tweet the other day.
It was not even I was,
it was half joking but not even half.
It was at least 2% of my thoughts every day are secretly hoping that big foot's
real.
I'm retarded man.
I'm a bit big foot.
Have a loopy like we have thoughts like,
like you'll have a loop that you think about all the time.
You know what I mean?
Like you come back to the same thing.
I'll have arguments in my head with people that had never happened.
I have a really weird thing that I think about every day.
Wait a minute.
What you get arguments with people that like you
take RJ,
you're out at argument and they never think we talk about it all the time.
Like with my agent to no,
no,
no.
I talk to them.
It's,
it goes nothing.
How I thought it was going to go
cause we were talking about this,
a betrayal like that,
like a like with a buddy.
Like I know he's going to say something.
So in my head I'm like,
yeah,
he's gonna say this,
I'm going to do this.
And I think you can say this though.
I see me.
He goes,
nothing like that.
He's like,
yeah,
he's off talking about your planning an argument and then it doesn't go the way
you planned it.
There was nothing like that plan I arguments do you play?
I've hypothetical conversations with important people in my life and then when I
seen it goes,
nothing like the hypothetical adversarial conversations about important you.
You're ready for the conversation,
you're ready for the debate and you're like,
fuck,
he crushes,
you know,
becomes all friendly.
He's like,
what's up bro?
How's it going?
That's it.
I do the exact same thing and what I also do the fuck you talking about,
he's crazy.
He's what?
He's stolen.
What I use.
If somebody like did something that I was like,
Whoa,
that's kind of mean,
or whatever,
then I'll extrapolate and I'll be like,
what did,
he was that way all the time.
And I wonder if he shoved me and then I want to be called me a bitch and then
I'll just keep calling before now and I'm having the same exact thing.
I'm having a verbal argument in my car.
I have done that.
I have done.
Yeah,
you're right.
No,
I get you now understand he explained that better.
You're thinking,
okay,
this is going to come at me with this and he's going to come at me with that.
Well,
I got this ready to them and I got that right.
Correct.
And you're like practicing your,
yeah,
I do that.
And I think everybody does that.
I do something even I think I do something even more ridiculous.
I daily have a fantasy that I live in a part of the world where gangs are
running everything and you are terrorizing my village or my Los Angeles run.
And what I do then is I secretly,
I push a cart of food cart.
I'm humble,
but I have a small gun with a silencer and I kill all the bad guys quietly and
they're like,
well fuck,
it's killing us man.
What the fuck is going on?
And I'm like,
would you like another plot of the professional?
Yeah.
That's literally how I think about how I protect myself.
Totally Sane.
All of you.
I feel
weird.
I thought something similar.
I thought,
no,
this isn't what I'm talking.
What if?
What if you could figure out how long it takes to kill someone with a choke and
then how long it takes to put him in a vegetative state permanently.
Well,
you can do that.
You mastered that.
So like anybody,
like you're like a vigilante and anybody who deserves to be a vegetable,
you're not going to kill him.
Child molesters and you hope you have a timer,
you got 45 seconds,
you let them go in their vegetable.
You didn't kill him.
That's genius to kill him.
But they're like,
hold on,
I hold a timer high.
Hold the time.
One by one.
You just turn
vegetables.
That's amazing little maker.
But then there's a guy that you didn't hold that choke long enough and it wasn't
lined up right.
Oh look.
Oh,
you're like fuck.
You've got to put them in another harm trying to,
you're like,
Oh shit,
you change it.
You change it to an arm triangle and you fucking,
oh,
I need 15 more seconds.
Fuck.
The cops are showing up and then you let them go and then so basically you guys
want to be like fake superhero.
He's a vigilante to play.
You're going to be super,
there's a sick play.
There's a sick plant called the Toyer that's called veggies.
Like there's festivals everywhere and they're like,
detectives are just like,
figure it out.
They're all bad guys.
Yeah,
exactly.
Festivals.
Would I go to jail for holding the tires?
It's like Jujitsu Dexter's jet.
Do you remember that conversation?
We had ones about guys getting hit so hard that it turns some gay and can
imagine went off for at least we went off for at least an hour like children
about how incredible it be if like dude's like how to get revenge because the
guy turned him gay and they showed up for the next fight with a parasol and like
pink pink clothes.
I like holding a handbag.
He hadn't been the same age and they fucks him.
He just,
someone knocked him out so bad that they turned gay and that it was a,
there was a possibility like you can,
you know he can get CTE.
The idea is it's like you like imagine if sitting,
they were like,
what if it was like,
I think what it was the thing like,
like there was a keep you from breeding.
If you got your ass kicked,
like in the wolves population,
the Alphas and the Betas,
Duke it out.
The Beatty gets kicked out of the crew if he gets his ass kicked.
Right,
right.
Maybe it would be something like that with two guys.
Duke it out.
One guy beat your ass.
He turns you gay every time.
How much movie over the stakes be Nolan's file you love.
No one's fighting anybody.
We were talking about like how much do you remember the conversation?
I forgot.
Here's so high.
So we were like,
how much more dangerous would fighting B would if you lost you turn gay.
Oh,
you'd kill people that carry helmets.
Someone Kod you if you became gay.
Uh,
over him.
Just trying to everyone because that's true.
He's been knocked out more than anyone know fighters ever.
It's like starting to slur.
That worked it.
You start seeing the signs of like the fucking leg up,
but they're going full.
You'd see signs of it,
but they're trying to hide it
slowly with like wooden beads,
exiting shirts.
There's nowhere to trips like the one I'm wearing.
Right.
You got to start.
You got to sit them down and have that Brendan shop talking to me.
You got to stop
my dick now.
Start Looking for alternative careers.
Ma'Am.
You're looking at like Dick.
Every time we hang out.
It'd be more.
It'd be more something you'd be like,
I think over in this is plucking his eyebrows.
Do you know it's like he's contouring
ice baby shaves in them.
Beautiful Vanilla ice slices.
Did he get,
did he get a facial?
What's going on with,
he's smiling at me.
We'd all be fucked up over attorney.
All the shots.
It's clear,
but maybe you have to get a wind back to get your heterosexual back.
This is the worst idea.
Shoes you can see they're out.
It's like,
Oh
hey ladies and gentlemen,
two of us in this conversation are almost 50 and how old are you now?
yeah,
we should definitely be more grown up.
I know,
I think so,
but you know the crazy boy.
I'm fucking 46 I'm an old motherfucker.
50 is right there.
I have a kid.
I'm sitting there at the fucking breakfast table with my son and my wife and I
feel like I'm 19 I'm like,
man,
I feel like I'm acting in this.
Like I feel like a little kid,
but I'm 46 I'm old as shit.
I don't feel like you're growing.
Growing up on,
on,
on TV.
You see that guy reading the newspaper and he's got his kids and he's only 38
like five.
Well you could be nobody who gone and I'm way older than that motherfucker
that's in my head.
How would you define,
and I feel like a little kid raising a kid.
I feel like a kid raising a kid.
It's so weird.
How would you define what an adult is?
Right?
So here he goes.
No,
but I mean,
well,
I mean you would think like,
hey,
someone that does it lose their wallet and 49 God Damn,
I bet you're supposed to be like,
well,
how would he would define like,
well I'm now I'm an adult.
Well,
I guess that would mean what that I have people I'm responsible for,
um,
that I make my own money.
And you're not dependent on your parents.
You have your own pillow depend on other people,
right?
I mean you kind of really in a way like just,
oh,
it's a boring conversation.
All right,
cheers boys.
Dude.
Cheers.
Tonight can knock down.
Take huge glass.
You just poured yourself.
You poured this?
Am I going crazy day?
No,
it's these fucking voices.
Hey,
slow down child now.
I was how his boss who's to so far isn't it an amazing,
it's the best man.
Well it like the first couple of months like,
yeah,
he needs his mom.
It's whatever.
It doesn't recognize me now he'd finally recognize them.
You know what I'm saying?
He loves the Shit and we look identical yet so go and show him the picture
better and better.
I see a picture of him and better and better.
I've seen a few pictures.
It's awesome.
It's not,
there's nothing like it.
Nothing daddy hold.
I want to squat.
I want like five and what?
Five?
Yeah.
I'm not the guy that tells people that they needed in their life because a
smoked it.
All right guys,
we're going down a weird rabbit hole.
Hey listen,
I'm not the guy to tell stucco.
I say live single and and,
and experience everything and travel the world.
And then when you,
once you do all that shit,
there's good shit.
The kid stuff.
It used to be when I'm,
when I was growing up getting a girl pregnant.
What's like fucking hell,
you're life is over.
Everyone's like,
your life is over nowadays.
It seems like people were having kids and,
and their,
their life means more than ever.
You know?
It's also the people you hang out with,
the people you're hanging out with.
But you know what,
man,
I've come across a lot of different people in this world and I think at a
certain point in time,
I personally think we've got to stop like thinking everybody's got to live the
same way.
Yeah.
You know?
And if,
if somebody gets pregnant at 18 and they marry the,
the their high school sweetheart 18 that shit sometimes worked.
Hell yeah.
It just like hell yeah.
But we're immediately as men will like that fucking dude.
Damn,
he
is so pure.
Well,
you know what man,
it's not just that,
but it's also everybody's fucking different.
You know?
That's like for some people they find the right person like real early and they
just grow together.
They figure out a way to be like really open and friendly really early and they
grow together.
There's also nothing worse.
When I meet a 50 year old and we have a friend like this who's not married,
has no girlfriend,
still playing the field and he's lonely as fuck.
Like that's how this movie ends my mat.
Not everyone's fucking George Clooney Buddy.
Right,
right.
It looks fun.
But once they were lonely,
men were,
there were times in my life and,
and me and Joe discussed this many times before we had kids like,
do we really want,
kids are like,
do you want,
I think I don't want kids,
but not now,
but maybe.
And then a lot of these like,
fuck,
I don't want kids.
Fuck that.
And then you'd,
you'd see fathers on planes with their kids are like full.
We're lucky we're not them.
So there were times,
or I,
I thought like,
man,
I don't want any kids.
I think I was afraid that I was going to feel the same way about my kids is my
real dad felt about me and that would have been a nightmare.
So I'm like maybe I got that same shit that my dad has that he don't give a fuck
about us kids.
So I'm like,
I'm afraid to have kids cause I'm afraid that my kid is going to feel about me
like I feel about my dad and that would make me want to fucking hang myself.
So there was a lot of times,
no kids,
but I'm like maybe kids,
I don't know.
Same thing Joe.
Joe,
there's no kids this,
I will say this,
let me finish real quick.
Let me finish this really quick.
If I was,
if I was,
if I find out I was going to die in five minutes,
one of my messages would be to all of these kids growing up and everything than
me.
Like my,
my version of the meaning of life really after all this shit after no kids,
kids full Kevin kids,
I want to be free and all that shit.
I live single up to,
I'm 40 I would say having kids is the meaning of life.
It's,
that's what I would say.
Maybe I'm wrong,
but that's what I would say.
So the reason why we're here,
I would leave,
I would leave my advice like you're all confused and all that shit.
At the end of the day when you,
when you're getting old and everyone's going to get old unless they die young,
but when you get old,
watch,
your kids are everything there.
You're fucked there.
Everything.
And then your grandkids.
Ah,
without kids.
If you're going to grow old and alone in my,
if I was going to die,
I would say don't do,
try to have,
don't die old and alone.
You only have one though.
Yeah.
Don't I want more?
Yeah,
for sure.
Let's pop out more than yes.
First is this huge speech.
Know Right now,
man,
I'm,
I'm super crazy.
Ultra family man.
Right?
And that's an everything to everything.
My life is,
I every day remind me because sometimes you get so busy and got all these
decisions and there's so much shit going on.
Why don't you adopt like six after you're with your kid and you're thinking
about this is what the orphanage
tend to play with the kids.
There's 10 I'm going to stop with this.
Sometimes you're with your kids and you guys out there,
you know,
you might feel the same way if you're with your kids and you feel sometimes
you're with your kid and you're spending these beautiful moments together,
but you're thinking about all this stressful shit and all these decisions you've
got to make in your life and fucking Ebi aids coming up September 11 you you're
like,
fuck,
but then I thought I just plug.
Yeah,
I saw it.
I thought this was all that fight pass.
This is stressful shit and I'm thinking I'm here,
I'm on the beats today.
I'm at the beach with my son and I'm like,
these are the moments I'm going to be thinking about when I'm dying and I'm
fucking thinking about some bullshit right now.
This is,
this is a moment that I would want to come back to if there was a time machine
and I can get back,
I would appreciate that and I wouldn't be thinking about any of the bullshit.
I would be thinking about every millisecond I had with my son on the beach
playing in the water and shit.
I'm like,
and I'm thinking about other ships,
so I constantly remind myself what is the most important thing?
That motherfucker right there,
he's the most important thing.
That little mother fucker right there.
Yeah,
like you know what I mean?
So I'm going to stop.
I'm not,
you know,
I'm done for sure.
Any more kids though?
If you're like,
I do,
I do.
I want more.
Well,
I'm done
to what you're saying is all beautiful.
For sure,
man.
I'm worried.
That's the most important thing.
When I find myself,
I'm like,
shit,
I got all this shit.
I'm like,
no.
US.
I think for all of us,
like living in the moment is very important and it's tough to do.
It's hard.
It's hard to do.
It's like something you've got to be real conscious of because it's so easy to
get trapped up with your thoughts.
Your thoughts can get gummed up with some unnecessary patterns,
even plans.
Right?
We see the future.
You got to remind yourself what the most important thing is and the most
important thing.
If you got kids that is every,
that should be your,
your fucking,
that should be the base of your existence right there.
It's not something's wrong.
Besides having kids like there,
there are those moments.
When do you think like when you were in your thirties and you had that,
that one switch where you decided you were going to check page demands.
Antler spray commercial.
No,
this is that bullshit.
A mobile phone.
It's like cricket but for UFC,
Oh huh.
Metro pcs.
They're only in the hood.
She's adorable.
99 flood flows.
A sad like there's,
they're like diminishing.
That poor man has to chase her and she's not tired and he's exhausted.
Metro pcs.
Metro Metro.
Metro is cricket.
Right?
Like if she,
if he tried to give fucking crazy,
she would beat his ass.
Maybe that's the connection to black belt.
No,
no,
no.
In that commercial,
that girl beats at Duke.
He put me in that commercial.
I'll sprint pass that bitch.
Brendan champion mean anywhere in the world to like three years ago.
God,
Dude,
you got to let her be.
You ain't fucking Hammon man.
Two or three years ago,
guys would there MMA fans or experts or whatever they,
there would be a big movement on how no matter how good an MMA female fighter
is,
she could never beat a normal man.
It's totally different.
Like,
well I think shit's different now cause you know it depends on the culture.
Ready.
Oh,
competitive culture come when Claudia Spain look up a dude who doesn't train a
dude who doesn't train,
which is how big it does.
Well it does matter.
It always matters and everything within experts in Jujitsu it matters.
It always matters.
But on 2,250 pound dude,
but he's like 99.99999% of the population who doesn't train.
I'll put my fucking Claudia who you talking about?
Cologic a Dale.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
The answer with the right hand,
he's 250 pounds.
If he doesn't train,
I would,
she would still get his back and still chuck the fuck.
I'll put my,
my maybe cause she's got Jujitsu.
It's possible.
250 pound guy that doesn't train against Claudia today.
If you're going to put your money on,
Claudia will get her,
but she'll guide that kind of guy.
Hey listen,
like ray Lewis doesn't try and
mad,
but you know what I'm saying?
[inaudible]
doesn't drain.
Kwania touches him.
He's gonna flicker to f back talking about 250 beds.
Ray Lewis,
I'm talking to some guy
population.
Just trying.
Yeah.
I'm trying to just see what kind of trail clear.
My point is.
The top UFC female fighters today will,
I will.
Oh,
I like triple h doesn't train on them over a guy.
Any guy on the planet that doesn't train.
God bless you.
In all my money on a professional UFC champion.
Come on one night
on the street and then you're talking about a champion hundred and 90 pound guy
who's talking about who are you going to put your money on it?
There was a confrontation
going to go show me the fucking guy.
Oh,
come on.
Generally I'm not talking about technically what are you going to get that
grounding and what he did growing up and all that shit.
I'm talking about the high school football is 250
pounds.
He's in shaped us crossfit.
You're going to put your money on a crossfit guy who's never trained martial
arts Holbrook over Joanna.
Come on.
Who's wearing some caterpillar?
Doesn't give a fuck about.
Yeah,
you hate women.
I love
diamonds.
I'm done.
I'm done on my money on cloudy.
If they have,
Claudia got to see the guy.
Eddy.
Johan is 115 pounds and she was going to go against a 200 pound random dude who
she's going to
be a little,
that's what he talking about.
Jesus fucking Christ this perfect.
These are professional killers.
Just cause the girls like no guys.
The Guy,
oh,
a guy just smashed that.
Brendan.
It's a background person.
It depends on what kind of guy you're talking to.
Professional.
It just depends.
I'm with you 100% if the guy played high school football and he's fucking a
state champion,
I would take a Stacy state champion.
Come on.
That's where I,
I disagree.
Oh,
you're going to put your,
oh,
those got big.
Never trained.
Now they never drained.
Know how to attack this.
If you have like you've got a college football guy or don't want to throw you
the train to throw punches and he got a train
in all earnestness in all our studies
has to be some sort of a like a weight that you're talking about.
Like if there's two,
if there's two people at 115 pounds.
One of them is you on a young Jay check and the other one it's Mitch Frickin
fuck at Kinko's from fucking West Chester,
New York.
He's going to sleep.
Yeah.
This guy who works in an accounting office and eats McDonald's every weekend.
He's getting his head kicked cause he's getting to know,
he's getting to know and he's a man but the about a non training athlete or non
athlete male.
The same size as her.
She's going to kill and lesbian community.
Listen man,
we're just trying to establish some parameters here.
What what she's capable of doing is,
if you,
you're talking about there's like there's a,
there's,
there's a spectrum and there's the non training non-athlete male that's the same
size as her.
She would kill him.
He's going to get fucked up.
He's going to get fucker at most likely,
right?
But then as you get procedure in bigger you get is different.
You get different things.
What is the guy wrestled in high school?
Does that count as being trained?
Did he wrestled tarsal?
Okay,
what if,
what if?
What if he took some karate classes when he was in high school?
What if he knows that he can punch,
but he also does crossfit and he's 250 fucking pounds shredded.
Then it gets weird.
You know it gets well done here where?
Cause you're not gonna hurt him.
What if he's just fighting Barb
local Taco?
Claudia,
I put my money on that.
You're going to
195 pound high school,
a football player,
not combat everything.
High School football player against Claudia.
He might win,
but you got to go.
Shit,
you don't know what's going to happen for sure,
but you might get
trained.
She's going to get this dude.
I've seen big dudes come in class all the time.
They get direct by my girls and my total is that all the time.
It's totally possible to,
they're starting in a guard.
That verse,
that Big Dude on his,
on his feet.
Yeah.
That's where he lands in opera cut.
That bitch is going to think she's not another dimension.
He knows where to punch at all and he's a big giant.
Never trained.
They've never had,
it has a point.
99% of the population was grim or tray.
I'm agree with Eddie.
If they're the same
chicks.
Oh No,
Eddie's right.
If you guys take draw now this Claudia guys in on it,
if it's Claudia or if it's your honor and they're fighting 195 pound male who's
never trained,
the mail's going to be in some trouble for a lot of reasons.
One on the ground,
he's going to have some trouble.
Hold on.
Let's stop the sex thing altogether.
Let's just go with the size of humans.
If mighty mouse has to fight ray Lewis in his prime,
there's a fucking problem.
Correct.
Kay Ray Lewis,
mighty mouse hacking.
Fucking giant problem.
Put my money on my book.
Okay,
but Eddie.
but let's stop saying male or female thing.
You want to Nj check weighs 10 pounds less than mighty mouse.
Correct.
Okay,
and she's a woman.
It's not,
there's not saying that women can't beat the fuck out of men.
They absolutely can,
but at a certain weight,
it becomes weird.
And it depends on what kind of athlete you're talking about.
Yes.
It depends on,
it depends if they have any,
any experience in moving their body at all.
And we were totally uncoordinated and they have no one couldn't with all that.
Honestly,
honestly,
what kid grows up with zero knowledge of how to throw a punch?
Who the fuck are they?
I want to meet these people.
Most people can't throw punches.
You may know shitty.
They know how to throw a shitty dog shit.
If it lands and you're way smaller than them,
you're fucked.
If you're a 110 pound accountants and there's a 300 pound Samoan dude,
this never get some,
okay,
listen,
David talking about the odds and bedding and it's at 100% you're right.
You're talking about,
of course you're going to,
you're never going to bend.
Go 1000000%.
I'm going to win.
If that big dude lands that crazy looping punch that he learned from watching
Chuck Norris movies,
yes,
he will knock 'em out,
but the money,
you've got to put the money,
the money's on,
Claudia.
Claudia is not going to get hit by overhead.
Shitty
loves move out of the way.
That dude's back.
You and I are feminists.
You guys are fucking children.
This is the point.
This is what we love about MMA.
This is the point and what I love about martial arts,
you might be right.
Yeah,
you might be right to pretend you know you're right is ridiculous,
right?
But you might be right,
but it's entirely possible that collage a good deal.
You could fuck up Ray Lewis and that they could have a crazy wild scrap.
Not Ray Lewis don't use
super.
She catches him.
Good athlete radio skills are the same.
When I,
when I think of a guy who's not a fighter buddies,
just off fucking soap here,
your ass,
he's going to do whatever he wants.
I think of Mary Lou because I don't know shit about football,
but
I run through people.
Herschel Walker less than Ray Lewis.
Ms Ass away from me.
No matter what.
You weigh their point.
Oh,
what percenters?
Those guys,
nobody's going about Betty.
Stop.
He'll run right out at you.
Eddie [inaudible].
He tackle these people audio with fuck him up.
I don't know what you smoked.
Eddie.
Connie would fuck up.
Ray Lewis said,
dude,
I can't call on Claudia.
Here's the match.
The match.
Cologic Adelia versus Ray Lewis.
The middle of a football field.
Ray gets a running start.
How about the CYBORG versus dark
side?
Who would you put your money?
Ray like Ray Lewis.
Smash her on her head.
Like a wrestling move.
You actually think so?
No.
Maybe 170 pounds.
You can't put money on that.
I'm going to leave this room.
I'm a cyborg rounds brand.
Louis fight.
We got to really stop talking over each other and we got to really like open up
this discussion
flow.
Look at telus ladies right now.
Take a fight break guys is gonna take a five break?
Hold on.
[inaudible] got Chris Kamozi is Barry taking a five break?
That's bad news for Chris.
Yeah.
This is a world champion,
Ray Ray Lewis is a superior athlete.
I just picked the best.
He's one of the best cars,
but he's one of the best players of all time.
Well,
that's what I'm thinking.
I'm thinking of soup and history.
Well,
you against Claudia.
here's the thing.
You can't say Herschel Walker,
Herschel Walker,
Herschel Walker
from the Utah Jazz.
John Stockton versus Claudia Goodell.
John Stockton,
that fucking wheel.
Kick her in the face.
Come on.
He's John Stock.
You're going to put money ever in the NBA guys.
You're going to go with John Stock.
Seriously,
Claudia show.
Oh my God.
To please everybody,
Claudia.
Good day.
Yeah,
Brian,
you fought taekwondo.
You think you'd be cloudy up.
You're 170 pounds soaking wet.
Her name's Claude.
Joe,
who would you put you?
Who would you put your mind?
He beat her up.
Who would you put your money on bringing in?
I don't want to cause you think you're going to beat her up and know each other
like this is ridiculous.
No,
but John Thompson has never done anything.
He never wrestled.
Never told him he might've been in bar fights though.
So you think you're doing a few years of taekwondo,
you're getting a few years,
but keep going.
You could beat her up.
I had never said I could beat up anybody.
Stop putting words in my mouth.
I'm asking if a grown man has never had skin.
Kim.
Brian Callen.
Fuck.
Did we go for Ray Lewis to Brian Calendar?
Yeah.
John Dean Cain in the mix
is a great name.
Herschel Walker Walk Dean can
get Dean Kane.
What do you guys bridge?
Mario Lopez?
Or we might need another guy all the time.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
You're right.
There's Dean Cain.
Yeah.
Now you might have to have a guy between me and Dane.
Just try and be nice.
Thank you.
I appreciate that gang of people.
There's the gay people between you two.
They're probably,
what about Jason Statham
to sidebar?
Oh No.
How about Ben Affleck?
Who Ronda versus who?
But Brett
see you.
I can bring you a gang of bitches that can fuck up banner
to say jump.
I'll make a call.
I'm going to make some shit right there.
We'll get your ass.
Ain't never seen you more.
We'll get your ass kicked,
but we let each other talk.
This is one,
right?
One of those things that where it does really does come up like you're talking
about the difference between a trained fighter and an actor.
Yes,
he did work in Batman.
Who would you put your money on?
Ben Affleck or Cyborg right now it's all so come on site.
That's what I'm telling you.
What everything
represents.
The average man.
Yeah.
We start off with buggies.
The average.
You May,
well,
let me say Ben Affleck looks athletic and I don't know how much he did in
Staunton Batman.
He can move.
He's a big guy,
strong guy.
That giant difference between him and a Cyborg.
Let me ask a question.
I want to ask her.
This is the bread and the MMA fights Batman and he was in good will.
He did do some light for real.
This is this a real question.
Let's get scientific.
You guys ready to get scientific?
I'm serious.
Here.
Ready?
Okay.
Brendan Cyborg at 175 pounds.
You put her in the octagon against Ray Lewis and I'm talking about Ray Lewis
when he was playing.
Okay.
Now we know Ray Lewis.
He's a freak athlete when greatest football players of all time.
Hold on.
Hold on now.
Wait,
wait.
Keep going.
Explain to me though how ray Lewis deals with cyborgs striking and her Jujitsu.
So how bout he picks her up and throws her to the fucking moon?
What would it
hurt to the ground?
I'm going to do Brian.
He's so,
let me explain.
Let's get some bread board brawls,
right?
Let's say Cyborg tax and not to knock them out.
Sure.
He Lands One fucking Baltimore Park.
The trained she like,
she says she gets hit all the tongue.
She might slip her weave a tale of the tape with Cyborg versus Ray Lewis.
Here we need one.
Here's issue number one.
Okay.
We're dealing with almost a hundred pounds of difference of pure and the man.
Yes.
Okay,
so we're dealing with a super athlete and Ray Lewis guest who's a good solid two
40 versus a woman who fights at one 45 but really is one 45 is also a hall of
Famer.
Some say the best linebacker on both sides,
but we're making good live wrestling experience.
Huge difference.
That's a giant deal.
You guys are making this point.
Just yell guarantee you ray Lewis has beat someone's ass before
you got to train to throw.
One of his friends are allegedly,
he was involved in an altercation where,
man,
hold on
guys.
Hold on.
Lewis.
Ray Lewis.
Ray Lewis could also,
he could pick her up,
throw out of the ground.
Ray Lewis Cross start punching in the face and get arm barred and we know that
you're talking about readiness is huge arm.
Hold on.
He know he takes her down.
Okay.
He takes her down to listen.
Can he learn about this fight a week before it happened and so that just
happened in here.
Answer to that question sir,
is no,
listen to me.
If I could get Michael Irving the game.
Michael,
this is Michael Ervin.
Know,
40 something I could just get six weeks.
Any,
any woman in the world that wants to get crazy could step up
and bring him to for us the hobby.
No training camp.
We're not talking about a fucking train again.
What does you just Ray Lewis,
you took my training
ass.
He finds out.
Okay,
and then you fight cyborg versus rate.
My money would be on Ray Lewis 100% of the time.
Amazing.
I'm shocked.
Really standing.
You're shocked with my do not want football.
Watch football.
Okay,
but let me tell you this.
I got my money on Cyborg 100% a hundred times in a row against Ben Affleck.
Throw down a house on the Brazilian Dow.
Hundred percent a hundred percent gotta reset.
You would Paul the money on Ray Lewis though.
Ray Lewis is so much bigger and I think he probably knows how to fight.
It's not totally unskilled.
Now,
Matt,
you got listen to the shot.
Do you think she can stop the shot?
Ray Lewis is a bad example.
You can stop the shot if a staff champion Rashad,
he's trying to tackle
the Superbowl.
Ray Ray though.
Sit Bad example.
He's just such a freak athlete.
Yeah,
it's in that,
hey,
here's your huge x factor is you saw it in this bitch.
Cause then they're both Jews to the guild.
A looking like she's looking very natural
world.
She's been tested as much as anybody.
She's 100% clean now.
She's,
she's not,
she's not crazy up no more cause cyborg get beat Louis like this.
Absolutely not Sir.
Why not?
Because not because we live in the real world,
but he does not have stopped.
Dan,
the difference between you,
Brian,
just you,
you and a ray Lewis [inaudible] imagine jail fight.
Brandon Ray Lewis would give me some problems.
That's not true.
You would kill him.
I don't think.
Stop Him in less than a minute.
I can't tell you why.
And I'll tell you why.
If he'd never trained,
you would choke him.
We till he's trained.
Well,
ray did some wrestling
training camp,
but hold on,
hold on.
But hold up the training camp.
But let's be realistic.
You don't think someone has shown great Lewis had a choke people to sleep.
How do I hold it like this?
Yeah,
you're probably like,
this here mean,
just do this on the captain of the fucking deep
breath is coming in on.
Oh Shit.
He's a smart guy.
Champion rest.
He's also a smart,
he's asked Jesus Christ.
If you're a captain of a defense team.
He was explaining me how intricate football is.
You got to have a brain.
That dude is smart.
Ray Lewis.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Make no mistake about it.
Maybe the fact that he ain't gonna learn no fucking rear naked.
He's not going to be weird to you guys are not being respectful that MMA
discussed it.
Maybe five months into Jujitsu.
You know,
maybe your Shit Kamasi with it,
right?
[inaudible] scraps.
Fuck Moz is so tough.
He's fine.
You and really Louis Theroux is way better know.
One of the things I liked the most about Kamasi is he's maintains a steady pace.
Like if he chose,
look at these charts.
Him Out
at his pace just destroys PT.
Bravo just went to the bathroom.
Let's talk shit about them.
Motherfuckers on tonight.
I'm gonna focus on one.
He's so passionate,
super passionate,
and you know what I think,
I think the moral of the story at night and he needs that more kids dot.
Some little afternoon kids.
Well,
it's beautiful.
I love hearing that.
I love hearing that now.
All 20 minutes.
I love,
he got a little crazy 20 minutes after a while.
I got it in the first day.
It was just sweet though.
There was no way it was going to end.
I tried even jumping in,
man,
he's a passionate guy and he,
he's,
what he is saying is what is on his mind and he's so overwhelmed with it,
but that's why he's so great at everything he does.
He's also right,
gets obsessed with things.
He is right.
He's also right.
But he gets obsessed with things and it's why it's why he's this Jujitsu.
Um,
yes.
I mean that's really what it is.
And his mind works like that with everything and it's,
it's working like that with parenthood too,
which is a beautiful thing if you're not obsessed with a kid that I kind of
suck.
A lot of people aren't.
It's uncommon for sure to think that there's said that we don't really care and
they don't love people that are with them and they're don't,
don't love their families.
Brian,
a lot of people,
I brightened their day.
You can't,
that's not fair.
Hey Bro.
I said it twice in a really weird way.
Like in a movie I went,
a lot of people aren't Brennan Brennan.
When you say something twice,
it's always kind of like one of those things.
I
know it means something else that you can take.
Watch this.
Ready Joe?
Rogan's a strong hold on Joe Rogan's a strong guy.
He's a strong guy.
You're dead.
Yeah,
there's a way to live.
You can sarcastically expect,
especially if you flatly,
yeah,
you can do a lot of different things.
What I thought sometimes it's dead serious if you like overemphasize the second
time.
Did you like Conor McGregor is a bad motherfucker,
dude.
Conor McGregor is all bad.
Period.
Yes.
Hold on.
Fuck.
Here's an acting job.
Can you say it three times and change the third times?
Meaning
like what do you mean Greg is Bama is bad.
That mother fucker is bad.
You see I'm just pulling boat.
Super Black.
That's how I talk.
I'm from Aurora.
What we do,
remember when Kimbo slice asked you if you were black,
you know,
it's like one of my favorite steps.
The way,
say mostly stuff that he was black.
They had heard that there was a guy on the podcast or on the podcast on the
ultimate fighter.
Oh Shit.
Tell slate does us Kamozi he taps
Dallas's Jujitsu's legitimate farts.
Kamozi he gets joc rate twice.
And then as
ladies,
that's a big win for [inaudible].
Yeah.
I haven't seen him in a long time.
So there was a guy on the ultimate fighter that was a possibly a Nazi.
He went full,
full rogue,
racist.
And they got together and they were,
they were,
they were all talking about it.
And they went to Brendon cause it said,
uh,
you know,
they thought that Brendan was black and Brown is like,
dude,
I'm not black.
So you ain't black and Kimbo so what did he say?
He goes,
that's why
I love the chuck is until,
what the fuck you
Thomas latest always had a nasty joke,
has always had a nasty Cho.
Joey's had a nasty,
you know what?
If he would have held that in for 30 more seconds,
he would have turned them into a vegetable.
Get chance.
That's why there's rafts.
They're red here.
There's a play,
a sick play called the Toyer and it's about this guy who has been coming into
women's houses and he sticks a needle in their back that caused them to become
vegetables like you're talking about.
And then he like dresses them up like galls bevy.
Look up there.
Oh no,
that's awesome.
Did you Jamie,
Jamie,
Jamie.
There's so ridiculous,
amazing fucking calendar.
Can you a Photoshop ray Lewis and full football gear like tackling somebody in
the octagon with side cheese and it says this ain't the Superbowl bitch.
That's a lot of work.
Listen to Photoshop,
Steve.
They're already doing it right and there people are doing it right now.
When you get out of here,
you're going to have 40 of them
too much.
I apologize.
Just regard that
request.
Nate Diaz,
Conor McGregor too.
What's your call and give a call it,
I don't ever yell.
I'm just,
I'm being dramatic.
Listen man.
Nate Diaz has a full camp,
but he also has all that goddamn press.
He's also got all that pressure and Connor has an opportunity to prepare
exclusively just for him.
And it's not like he didn't have some success in the first fight because a lot
of pretty much dominated the first round.
He looked beautiful,
but the problem was he tried to use those one hitter quitter punches.
He tried to just crack them and drop them.
And Nate is a bigger,
stronger man than most of the people that Connor's fought.
And he knows how to absorb punches.
And he's sparred with a lot of world class boxers like Andre Ward.
It's fine.
It's fine tonight.
Don't tell me the results.
I don't know the results.
I'm not touching my phone until you get back mean to you guys are great.
I love Andre Ward.
He's one of my favorite.
Awesome.
He's so fucking smart.
That's what I like about Andre Ward.
Pound for pound.
Damn.
He's so God damn smart.
When he breaks down boxing,
like when he does a the analyst position on each photo,
you realize like,
oh,
okay,
this is dude.
It's just a super smart
undefeated gold medal
in the Olympics.
Yeah,
yeah.
What I was talking to hiring
very high last night,
Andre Ward,
because no,
is that football?
Andre Ward.
The ward play for the lions.
You're right.
That's what I'm,
that's it.
There's a boxer now.
Yes.
He's there to wear boxing.
I'm like,
is that guy like 45 now and fighting and fighting like burnt on the ward.
You're talking about played for the Detroit Lions Yas.
Good.
Call it.
I had a conversation with Andre Berto in camp confused.
I'm sorry,
go ahead.
I had this conversation with Andre Berto.
What about Andre Ward and because they're in the same camp and their buddies,
they came together and he was telling me that he learned a lot just watching
Andre Ward,
like when the wave version of hunter has him do it.
If you watch him warm up,
he'll do things.
He's so technical where he like literally will just,
he won't throw punches when shadow boxes.
He spends a lot of time literally just doing the perfect kind of hooks.
Like everything is like he's obsessed with people and not watching it.
You do it.
Everything super slow in the air and she has everything.
He's obsessed with perfect technique,
like every detail where his feet are and he always does that and he obsesses
over exactly where his body is going to be in almost slow motion for a long time
and then he'll start doing things.
But well I didn't fundamentals when I was a kid.
I used to think that forms were stupid and I should think that like even
throwing kicks in the air couldn't compare to doing things like throwing kicks
on the bag and they're like a lot of the decorative aspects of martial arts like
you know,
throw a side kick and you hold it up there and then you throw second sidekick
and then you do all these different combinations that you'd have to do in these
forms.
I just think they're stupid,
but now understand that it's almost like you're doing like a form of yoga.
Yes.
Throwing those kicks out there and you're holding them in place and even though
that's not how you would ever fight,
these are all important movements.
If you could figure out how to do that and make it beautiful.
Float while also body control.
Yeah,
control body control.
Hey Jamie and bring up to Andre Ward for like sidekicks.
That is like one of the most important aspects of throwing a sidekick is
throwing it in the air.
Learning how to throw it in the air while your body is moving forward because if
you use a bag prematurely,
you grow up customed to bouncing off of it and that's the difference between
someone who bounces off of that technique and drives through it and the person
who drives through it,
when they drive with their hip,
there's so much more power and it takes the same amount of time.
There's no difference in the amount of time,
but the amount of force that someone who knows how to really drive their hip
forward,
that you developed that a lot of is by kicking the air cause you snap and you
extend that side kick out and you pull it back and you snap and it's all about
doing it as fast as you can.
And then once you developed the technique perfectly,
then you start moving to kicking things.
And usually it's a person with a cushion.
They moves towards you slowly or it's a really light bag and you slowly develop
ability to move your weight into it.
But if you don't do it right,
you can develop.
This is this one aspect of that kick that most people have,
which is they kick off of people.
They kicked him and they push off.
That's right.
The woman,
um,
in this,
in who's responsible for the Russian revolution and tennis,
like she came out with a sharp pauvre off and all the,
uh,
Sarah Poba and all these movies,
these amazing tennis player.
She will have her students in a group before they even hit a ball.
Just slowly,
you know,
literally just practicing their stroke in a really slow manner.
It's the same exact thing that clutch goes.
Does the same thing the first week there?
I think the first two weeks of the camp is all basics and super slowly.
Yeah.
Jamie put bring up Andre Ward like shadow box and warming up.
It's really wild to watch.
Nobody upset a bit going on right now though.
Yeah,
it is really interesting man.
It really interesting like though the idea of what is the best way to learn how
to execute certain techniques,
which there's always,
there's always a lot of debate about it,
man.
There's a lot of debate about how much sparring you should do versus how much
you know simulation drills you should do versus how much bad work you should do
when this might be it.
I don't know if this is the one we're watching them right now.
There's another one where he's,
yeah,
he's being watched right now so he's going to go faster.
Well just doing regular shuttle them off to them,
but bringing up man,
fuck.
Bring up the other one.
Bring up the other one where he's,
you'll see it going to be,
Holy Shit.
Look at how specific or too though I'm interested in.
I don't want to know who won tonight,
but if Andre Ward wins,
I'm very interested in him versus the one that's the plan.
It's for sure a cola has a fight.
War has a fight.
And then next is Covello very interested enough.
I can't walk man,
if I,
if I had to put my money on.
So right now it's Cova love Kovalev is Cain killed a guy he did and he,
you know what?
I was really most impressed with what he's done.
Boxed pornography.
He's doing right.
Don't look at this.
Got He was boxing them up.
It was going pretty fast.
No,
he's tried.
Some of it was slow.
Yeah.
No,
that's super slow.
There we go.
So now he's the most impressive shadowboxing I've ever seen.
I thought he's awesome.
He's so good.
Interesting.
Cause he's stolen those punches with power.
You could tell them in the snap.
It's all,
what's the perfect word?
Like when we were
caught up,
oh,
you want to forums called bubble.
People talk shit on cotton for so long.
This is just caught up.
Yeah,
it might be even better even than Catia.
You know what's interesting when you watch a guy like him do that as opposed to
that Russian gentleman that we were seeing earlier,
that's learning how to box.
That's where you see the difference.
We're talking about best in the world for us,
the guy who just had last week,
but those movements,
they're not unattainable.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like watching someone do a move,
right?
Like say if they're doing a,
they're choreographing Michael Jackson's thriller when all the dunes would do,
all the zombies are doing.
That was like a choreographed thing,
right?
So the idea that there's similar movement,
everybody has similar movement.
That movement that he's doing is not attainable.
What he's doing is things that everyone can do.
They just can't do it the way he's doing it.
He's just,
which is what makes it,
what makes it so special is nothing.
He's doing his crazy acrobatic ridiculous movements that the average person
can't do.
Like your Air Rodriguez,
who are going to watch fight tonight.
This fucking dude does.
Why you old shit flying knee bars flying round kicks and jumping double round
kicks.
He's fun.
He's ridiculously,
yeah,
no,
he's a talk with no guy can do the regular Mexican.
Yeah,
he's a bad motherfucker.
No Mexican is fuck.
Oh Shit.
So,
so the what he's going to do the big differences.
What he's gonna do his shit that we can't do.
Like you look at him throwing those kicks in like fuck,
like look at this crazy guy.
Like he's for jumping,
spinning cartwheels through the air and roundhouse kick and dudes in the back of
the neck.
Like it ain't for everybody.
It's not fair.
It's not for everybody.
Just most people have never gone that far with the Reps.
I don't think also some people aren't,
even though it's not like Cirque du Solei stuff,
what he's doing,
they take some genetic genetic.
My point is that no one,
he's Mexican.
Come on.
It's not genetic.
My point is it,
no one has a problem doing this or this or this or this.
No one has a problem with throwing a normal punch at a very slow pace.
But you can't even do what he's doing.
Like those cartwheel kicks.
You can't even do that slowly.
You can't move the way he's moving.
So the difference between what a guy like yeah here can do.
And the guy like Andre War could do,
I didn't even weigh it makes what Andre Ward can do even more impressive way
more than cause he's boxing guys up and he's doing it based on his understanding
of each different position that might come up.
My two guys are trying to punch each other in the face and also the basic,
the basic superstar.
But those basics,
I could teach my daughter to do it if,
if she just listened to me and move slowly.
I'm not saying that you know,
someone could punch someone to hurt someone like immediately,
but I think you could take like a 60 year old executive.
It never thrown a punch in his life and you have them stand there.
Just make him listen to you.
Make him put his foot here.
Lower your way,
lower your weight.
Okay.
Square shoulders,
hands up,
right?
Reaching bonds are,
and just do this.
I just want you to do this.
Now do this.
Okay,
now try to get this same guy to do a wheel kick.
Yeah,
like clothes.
So you're convert trick is to do is in one way more impressive cause he can do
his physical shit that most people can't do.
But another way it makes what Andre Ward does more impressive because Andre
Ward,
he's way better than everybody else and just doing shit that everybody.
That's true.
You're saying,
but what you're actually saying is that punching is more anatomically natural I
think to a human being walking around.
What's season is ticking.
It's is really hard.
Like understanding I'm really good sidekick are around house her a wheel kicked
back and not natural.
It's
not natural it tastes like,
but it's like everything else,
even though punching it seems to attain,
you can drill it into someone over and over and they can reach that razor sharp
level of,
of efficiencies wherein Andre Ward or Kovalev is I think,
which I can't wait to see that fight.
By the way.
Keep calling.
That's of the most radical taekwondo kicks x that you could do in the cage.
There's some acrobatics taekwondo stuff that Cirque du Solei step when you have
those as forms and dudes will store like fucking,
they'll spin like flies.
Yeah,
that shit you'll never do.
But maybe you will one day.
But I'm gonna.
I'm gonna.
A lot of guys can't do it though because they're not athletic and if they don't
have the vertical,
that's the super crazy shit.
If you could do it in the cage,
anybody could do it.
But listen to my page.
Michael,
page three 60 roundhouse kick in Beltour.
Yeah,
he knocks him.
Do that with a three 60 roundhouse kick in the face.
He jumps spinning ThreeSixty roundhouse kick like he was a fucking dude in is
that video can see that he's the same guy that face.
Oh,
so good.
Michael Page page.
I need to see.
It's fun to watch.
Palatar but I remember him.
He's the breakout star Bell tour.
They need to handle them.
And Lemon Chandler there.
Wonderboy people don't know how good Chandler is either.
We'll Chandler beat Eddie Alvarez.
EOC changes beat Eddie Alvarez.
Do you see what he'd knocked out?
Pitbull and his last fight.
Fucking monster,
dude.
Michael Venom page.
It could.
It's possible.
Look,
I would love that.
I wouldn't want to daddy say Simon the El Toro versus UFC could apply.
What the fuck would you have to do this?
I would listen man.
Guy With the new owners.
Would that ruin,
ruin Bella towards,
but you'll see what I have no reason to listen man.
I don't think it's ruining anybody can be a bad idea and money in it.
I think there might be money in it.
Watch this.
Look at this.
Watch this watch page.
He backs up here,
comes check out.
She got hurt and he got him hurt.
Oh shh.
There
too.
He just stands there and he's white.
He's a monster.
It takes a lot of practice.
You can't just do that and you got to,
they're being smart with her too.
They're being super smart one what they should be.
He's uh,
he's their star man and he speaks well.
He's a character.
He's entire 70 or 55,
77.
I want to see that guy fight like world class fighters.
I want to see that guy fight a really,
he just got caught looting Bella tour.
If the UFC is not going to sign Ben Aspirin Bella tour signed,
Ben asked Grin.
You know what?
I'm string mops the floor.
Know that there's like people who have a problem with the guy who could just
take everybody down.
That's the other Andre Ward thing though.
Ben Africans the best at the bay.
You know exactly what the fuck.
He's new but he's still does it anyway.
Is he not going to it?
I'm not some people down in one FC cause they let him use knees on the ground
and he can use needs in the ground now with the new rules,
Ben asking him and gets way more dangerous.
Mops the floor within Wyndham.
Andre Ward.
Is he knocking everybody out
and he's at light heavyweight like a printout Winokur no,
no,
no.
Watch this fight and honey Jason and throwing down.
Watch.
Watch me mean as he's doing his front kicks to his body.
That's a young Roberto Duran right there.
He's rough.
Cut for boat drill was never that thick to good call and no he wasn't.
But Duran is great.
That's,
it's just interesting.
Roberto Duran crazy as that.
Did you know that they made a movie about Vinny Pazienza.
Have you seen that ad?
I want to see that man's a car accident came back and fought.
What are you watching trailers all day?
Oh No.
Now I don't envy.
I love pies.
Spoiler alert.
Spoiler alert type breaks his neck.
Well,
no,
he did it in real life.
You bastards.
Look at,
look at during this Dennis Bermudez,
he's just crushing them.
He's a fucking monster.
Like seven in a older men are not the loss.
I met her hands in Vegas once and he was wearing this beautiful suit with a
Bandana that was made of the same like materials.
So,
aw,
he's awesome.
It's fucking right.
Beautiful,
beautiful Badass.
He's a bad ass time guy.
I fucking love him.
I went to see that guy fight.
I,
I paid to see him fight a couple of times.
Me and my friend Jimmy Wallace,
we went to Providence,
Rhode Island to watch him fight a bra lawless.
Jimmy lawless.
That's his name is he related to his real name was blackie lawless.
I asked him,
I asked boom,
boom.
Real name though.
Jimmy lost like your name is Eddie Bravo and that sounds ridiculous.
His real name was Jimmy lawless.
My name sounds ridiculous.
Well it sounds cool.
It sounds like a superhero.
Yeah.
Bravo.
It sounds like you picked like bravo was like,
you know,
it's like Eddie awesome.
He's like,
my name's Eddie off,
so it really picked that.
I wish my name was Brendan.
Awesome.
My stage name.
They really,
they think you fucking make it.
Isn't it funny that you can't pick your own name?
I just want him named Marcel something.
Awesome.
Well why can't you?
I did.
I named,
my name is the kid.
Yeah,
you did name itself.
Came to set one day I was doing a movie and I said,
it's my new name is the kid.
I never liked it to Larry.
Larry effect and then him calling him something,
he caught myself,
the kid,
they,
the camera man started saying,
Hey kid,
can you,
and I was like,
what'd you say?
And he goes,
kick.
Can you Morocco.
It's the kid.
So please call me and fucking,
and I was dead serious.
So here's the thing,
Brian and I have been friends for 22 years.
1995 sir,
21 years.
And he always called himself the kid,
the kid back when he was a kid.
I love it.
I mean young.
He was always the kid my age,
you know,
the kid rolls
kid.
He was always calling himself the kid.
It's how the kid is kind of a good Ra.
Pride count always was ridiculous.
I remember the first time I went over to Brian counts house.
He had no door knob.
Okay?
I go to his door,
I get to his door,
there's no fucking door knob.
I'm like,
dude,
you don't have a doorknob knob.
It's like,
Nah,
Nah.
It's like it's fucking homeless.
Lady came in,
she was cooking.
One day I go white homeless lady.
She was cooking eggs and is,
yeah,
yeah.
I called the cops.
Meelod.
Denis Spooner's is beating the fucking Tara and Johnny.
Jason.
I used to walk my pimples with no leash.
They'd kill cats.
Worst thing,
they kill the neighbor.
They killed this cow and I was like,
oh no.
And I grabbed the cat,
ran away and buried it.
There were signs everywhere.
Case Bermudez is just so bad.
I'm so close to a title shot.
You want someone to place,
yeah.
There's some dudes you cannot let posture up and made as a,
certainly one of them.
He knows strong wrestlers,
drivers weight and smash.
You know he has a cooking show for me.
It is done on youtube.
It's a cooking show.
Yeah,
he's,
and he's doing well with it because this guy's face texting.
Nice call from him.
He's on fire,
right about Cummins.
Do the same shit.
I get it.
Even Pat Cummins and make like their own Serratia and shit.
Ride bikes.
Oh man,
that's awesome.
He's came in,
this guy,
this guy I love Pat Cummings,
man.
I hung out with him.
We went to dinner like one of the nights in Brazil before he beat phase Zhao and
he's a fucking good dude.
He's one of the best means.
Serratia hold the sugar free.
Seraching
no,
Pat,
you got to know buy it.
I want other people to fucking Ralph's.
It's making in his backyard.
We got to get,
it's really cool.
It's special to sell his formula to honor and get pat his math.
Sarah.
I'm not manifested yet.
The great,
I thought it was this guy's fucking asshole,
man.
I'm sorry dude.
Sorry.
That man to stand.
And that was good.
That's a funny guy.
It's funny to loose.
One of my favorite people I'm doing their podcast is weak.
The UFC unfiltered.
Matt Serra and Jim Norton have a podcast that was funny.
And so is Dana Dane actually pretty good.
Tammy is the ultimate fighter.
Tet Two.
Why not?
That's oppressive.
Riding the storm pitch,
get it.
And that changed his life.
You know,
but I know why not?
Why not know what if it's like changeovers ex girlfriend.
I know who else is on that chain.
It's Jason from the movie Friday.
That's who's on his arm.
Yes.
And then it's back to his Jujitsu.
I love it all,
man.
I love it all.
And then it was a Reebok sign on his man.
Oh
look at this.
Do you know what box?
Do you know what Reebok's new sang his.
You know what their,
their logo is my bad.
Be more human.
I want to be more human.
I heard their newest one name on a more human.
More like Dennis Bermudez.
Dude's a fucking creative.
Look at them on top of here.
Yeah,
he is fucking Denny's per meeting.
Ultimate butterfat too sweet.
Check this out.
Half Nelson will beat the shit out of you.
Let me let me bully you real quick in front of everybody.
Motherfucking get paid for it.
Damn.
He's tough.
You know you rarely see an MMA fight stopped on cuts.
Kotter has got his hands.
Rarely comes out to 45 would you say?
Kind of got his hands full with tenants permitted as it becomes touching common.
Hey Brian,
Brian,
Brian.
Eddie was talking.
Come on man.
You can't keep it interrupting each other like that's fucked up in the UFC.
Blood is in the big deal like it is in boxing.
It's like you rarely see bite stopped on cuts.
You certainly see that they let it go.
Maybe blood in like in the WWF and WWE blood equals money.
She's like,
guys are cutting themselves off.
It's only three in Brown's.
That's why I think it's,
no,
that's not true bro.
Look at the floor minute.
This is a squirter.
It's based off of time.
Jason's head Dude,
look at his,
his head is literally dripping.
I would have,
I wouldn't as long as learning to do his eyes out of the quarter.
Guys are like a ketchup,
just like blood.
Just squirting people.
If it
goes into his eyes,
that's when this kicks today.
Do you look at these kicks test?
We you're in.
It says beautiful technique dude.
He is fucking this kid up.
Ryan Parsons very high on Dennis Bermudez always has been hell.
He had,
he has been him and Pat.
You know that fight would with chairman Stevens was insane.
What?
I'm crazy fight.
That was what a crazy knee Steven's lands to close the show and think about
Bermuda.
Well I think again Brian,
get that fucking cheese out of my faith.
I can't stop eating it.
I been eating
some or is that the real Santana that brown
him and caught him and pat ride bikes in the orange county like gets their
fucking job.
So these Tan,
you know he's driving with his shirt off.
He's a Mexican gentleman.
So Judas.
So Bermuda's doesn't touch Khan.
He's not well,
he's not bringing enough scarf to get in the door.
I couldn't touch him.
I say don't think it's fake.
So no,
not at all.
But we realize is a nice Mocha Brown all the time.
He's
eight Donald,
he's Mexican,
Puerto Rican,
Spanish,
Cuban,
something like that.
He's got scraped scan.
I just got great skin.
They,
Jason's like,
get me the fuck out of here to be natural.
It's too,
it's too perfect to be that.
I don't think so.
They ride with their bike off in the ocean,
man.
There's big John McCarthy.
Oh awesome.
10 and go under it went under what?
GS?
Fake suntanning.
Yeah.
You can't do that shit anymore.
But did GSB of fake Tanner,
did he just get tanned a lot?
Because 10 makes your body actually produces vitamin D,
which helps you in terms talking about to your anabolic stage.
I'm talking about the industry,
the fake Sun 10 industry.
Did it go under hold on Sam Anymore?
Hold on.
Say That is true.
Tanning,
tanning booths.
When you see people tanning.
No,
it's on,
it's all gone.
There's an athletic benefit to that.
There's an actually athletic benefit.
There's the,
your body actually does produce vitamin D
as well.
Eddie Bravo called Maxwell.
I think Jill was talking about it.
He said the GSP was at the center of this.
Gee,
Steve Maxwell was talking about how Russian athletes have been doing this for a
long time and a lot of other athletes have figured out that Russian,
you know,
we'll just do it in three machines are doing it stores.
Vitamin D there is new research shows.
Vitamin D can dramatically increase athletic performance.
So I know for a second yes,
you can find them and see you get the same raise that you did from the sun.
Just intensified.
Yes.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
That shit.
We did it for bolt.
That's going to be floating.
Who's a marketing.
Well,
GASB did it because he knew it could help us.
Performance for sure.
He looked better,
but yes,
he's very savvy.
Maxwell is like,
he's got his thumb on the pulse.
I mean of the whole like athletic spectrum as far as like people strength and
conditioning,
little little hacks and little things that people do.
He's always got new shit.
He's a,
he's like,
he's constantly on top of it,
so when he was talking about that,
I take everything Maxwell says when it comes to like physical fitness and
strength and conditioning.
He's,
he's a very responsible,
yeah,
I don't think he's bullshitting.
I think GSP was doing it for looks and maybe that,
but I am.
I never heard that.
That's going to be the new thing.
Dudes are going to be coming in fucking Kansas.
Fuck.
They're going to look like they've seen of tape.
You could also take vitamin D,
especially d three and get probably pretty similar results to,
he just wouldn't get the Tan,
but you get both.
You can also could supplement with it.
You could take her on a Tan.
You could.
You could do a lot of different things.
So basically if you come in white and not tan,
you're not coming in at your full potential.
That's not necessarily true because you can take supplementing vitamin D.
See if you'd take it.
I don't know if you get in d three d three is a hard one again man.
You're not 10 do you aint trying.
I always 10
for what?
An uncomfortable moment.
Biases.
Awkward Brian Collins Time.
It's time to start talking and I was going to say I'm waiting to
get with this podcast is going to bring back the tanning
talking.
Definitely not.
You guys are talking about millions of people listen to your shit.
Here's what I was thinking when we created the floating industry.
What were you gonna say?
I was saying as you're talking,
I was thinking to myself,
as people move to higher latitudes,
they lost the melanin in their skin because they needed,
they got less sun so you have to lose melanin in your skin so you can absorb the
ultraviolet rays that create vitamin D.
That's why Russians are so white.
That's right.
So as you get the skin cancer,
right?
That's right.
That was even making it black people are actually,
I mean why people are actually black
people who just need less sun producing mother fuckers you lost.
That's evolutionary biology.
You racist bastards.
White people are just black.
True without the rest.
What was the rest that just need less fighting?
Less sun essential vitamin D,
goddammit.
Well you lost me that white people are just black people.
I'm just telling you what my thoughts were,
dude.
By the way,
I'm mistreated through,
I'm going to start speaking in a seductive voice right now because I'm getting
some wine run into my body and I feel real good and warm.
Nice inside.
I love you guys.
I mean as a group too,
as a clump.
When I think of you guys,
I think you guys is a fucking clump or immune is.
I'm not done.
I don't give a fuck about three minutes.
I think about you guys is one big muscular clump
brown around skilled muscular
tray lends another layer and another one that's a stringer penis.
Chop Chop,
another leg and Rony.
Jason is a tough row column Roadie.
I called him rolly.
He needs less sun.
He needs less sun,
but it was essential vitamin D
it ended right here.
If he had a fucking antiques
were radio band stuff.
That shit.
He's exhausted to his being in his ass whooped.
Throw that Anaconda.
Fuck.
Whoa.
The other color of his shorts are exactly,
the color was settled.
Why Buddy?
It looks like he's naked.
He's a white with the green tattoo.
Come on Ui.
Very fuck.
She's Brazilian too.
It's weird.
He's Brazilian white.
I shorts had the black like crap.
Oh I can't catch like then you could sublimate that.
Why can't guys were skiing?
Coach shores drawn on the front.
Withdrawn us with a Dick with a snake head
like a bikini with your dick puff balls,
but it's a bikini
on the ski mountains.
This app,
you used the word sublimated correctly.
I tried bro.
I went to a Halloween party.
I'm never used that word.
Never sublimated be sure what it means.
I just,
it was legit.
Submitted is a good word.
Industry.
It's real.
It's legit.
If you get your mind can keep that up.
You could print that.
She does that mean?
Oh yeah,
he's,
he's going to get us back cause he's a Russell.
She was going to turn it stand up.
That's trouble man.
Shit.
That is risk.
Oh
it's over.
He got no fuck.
He got 'em he got 'em.
Oh
Gosh.
Dammit.
Fuck out of us
standing up.
Oh Shit.
Offense.
Defense.
Stand up.
Speak.
Oh Brown.
Dan Severn bodyline going right to that shit.
Close that motherfucker.
How tough is Jason Rony?
Jason is tough as
critical.
Tony Blair fucked up.
Missed that under fumbled.
Sublimate or supplemented is to divert or modify,
um,
in the instrument business,
snow and instinctual impulse.
Hey man,
to a culturally higher or socially more acceptable.
But that's infant care,
bro.
Okay.
It's sublimate infant care,
infant care,
reading informed care to.
You weren't reading the same amount.
So how does,
how did,
was it used in this conversation?
I don't know,
but I think he used it wrong and that's all right.
That's all right.
That shows you're a dad tried buddy.
I had a brilliant thought Fox and they came out.
It was he can you share it and then it's fun.
Let's find out what the real definition is.
Sublimate in the apparel business is now they got machines now that you can take
any picture you want and put it on material.
It's not about like,
oh,
like those old school graphic arts and supplement.
Then not sublimate their machines.
A couple other
you see rash sublimate no.
There's a couple of different definitions here.
Sexual when it appears in the apparel business,
it means make rash guards about,
you could take a picture and make a rash guard out of it through the sublimation
process.
Oh,
I see what you're saying is a crystal deposit on the car.
Just so amazing.
Now because of sublimation before sublimation you,
you had to do like graphic arts,
like to color type.
So logos you couldn't do right now you could do anything.
A bunch of different definitions because that one was sexual in the beginning.
Why?
Why did we run out of noises we can make with our face?
Why do we have words mean a bunch of different shit so people can sound smarter
than the other choices we make with our face.
I mean,
did we run out?
We,
why do we have to use something for a bunch of different things?
Like why should it be confusing?
You should be able to go to the dictionary and it's just one fucking definitely.
Sure.
I fucking agree with that.
It's so exhausting.
Fees,
you know like people like words like trite.
That was one of those words where people are also afraid to say they don't know
what it means.
Try it.
I just rolled with it.
You know I tried.
I don't think I've ever used sublimate tried is like ridiculous.
Nonsensical,
like not not important dude.
Do you know what that means?
Yeah.
Cause I watched the Matt Lauer Tom Cruise interview.
He was like,
Matt,
you're being Glib.
Glib.
It's means like he's like dismissing.
Oh gotcha.
You know,
like he's a,
he's not,
it's like a harsh dismissal.
Insincere.
Thank you dude.
You're explaining what cahoots may cause.
I thought it meant enemy a glip when we sang it like that.
You're saying he's being Glib,
but still I think he's saying he's being insincere.
I think he's saying who's being,
is this the actual word of it?
The person speaking fluent and uh,
voluble but insincere in cow.
Let me show.
I didn't want to say it,
but that's what it really means.
Shell.
Wow.
Yeah,
so I had it wrong.
So glib would be B.
When you're being,
when you're not being almost reverential to something that requires Gravitas,
like us with Cyborg fighting railer yeah,
it'd be like,
yeah,
but what we're for basketball is just like throwing a ball and to have,
you know,
a blowout recordings that makes a big Glib runs.
That's not a word that's in my frequent vocale vocabulary.
If we used it,
it would be like if a girl says like you say son all the time,
so I say son all the time,
it's fun.
But if you use Glib,
I'd do that.
Eddie hosted.
Now,
right now you're talking about two different things,
but that's what she went on down a depressant for.
But what happens?
The antidepressant,
all it does is mask the problem.
There's ways of vitamins and two extra educators,
I think.
I'm not saying that that isn't real,
but aren't there examples where it works?
You don't even,
you're granted,
you don't even know what religion is.
He started talking about chemical imbalance.
You have to evaluate and read the research papers on how they came up with these
theories.
Ma'Am,
he's telling us he's kind of schooling last year though.
He's not.
I don't think Matt Lauer's Malik was asking him real questions.
Matt Lauer was asking him questions and he was saying,
Hey,
there are examples when ads are depressants,
you're not a fucking doctor.
Tom Cruise there examples when they work and save lives,
you fucking dummy stick to acting and ag and make them believe.
And that was a sign,
Todd,
that was him on a Scientology riff.
Easy.
That guy.
Come on fuck cause he got a roll over.
You know you hate the guy.
If I'm being clear about Tom Cruise,
don't bring up chem trails cause that's,
that's leave.
This is when he went full batshit crazy.
Oh,
what do you dance like this too little Katie Holmes?
Yeah.
Fuck daddy loves you.
I got divorced.
Tell you something about that guy.
I've met him twice.
He's the nicest human beings on the planet.
What's that?
Are you a fan of Ritalin?
I don't know anything about them.
Ritalin.
Okay.
I don't know.
I'm,
I'm not a fan of any medication that I don't have to give to my children.
But I do think that there are,
there are certain drugs that are made by big pharmaceutical companies that save
lives.
Me,
which lives better or beneficial?
I don't know.
I'm not a pharmacologist,
but I can give you examples of the things that I've seen with,
listen man,
if you need antibiotics,
you need fucking science.
God Damn right section.
If she had staph infection,
you better be listening to fucking doctors and not listen to some food.
Fuck yeah,
fuck that staff.
So I don't think there's a an either or.
I think there's a lot of medications to do.
A lot of people,
a lot of good.
And I think there's also a lot of medications that pharmaceutical companies are
profiting off of people using them in ways that they don't need them.
But especially painkiller,
I grew that and a lot about this stuff.
However you,
for you Brenda,
you had a fucking real issue,
right?
With those goddamn painkillers.
Yeah,
there's a rumor.
I hesitate to Dylan.
You talked about it.
You know it's,
that's scary shit man.
Cause you're a together guy like to hear that you got caught in the grip of
those fucking things.
The most addictive thing in the world they say,
and my doctor was trying to be cool and I was only supposed to have like 15.
He's like,
here's like 200 man.
Just,
you know,
explain what what she was saying.
I was like,
okay,
but explain why what they urge was our addictive.
So when you stop using them and you like,
you're like depressed,
you,
uh,
you feel itchy,
so then you keep taking me.
You just makes you feel better and they're not dependent on it.
So when I'd go out with my friends,
I really,
I knew I had 200 so I was like a mess.
We'll take one of those and not be all cranky and itching and pain.
I was taking one of those,
have one band that's a fun fucking night.
Wow.
And then mixing.
I know every morning I'm just boom,
boom,
boom.
Until my friend and brother like what the fuck are you doing?
And they took him from me.
I was talking to two pretty well known fighters.
Does anyone have any in here?
Why wait til I'm addicted to this fucking Conor Mcgregor,
Nate Diaz countdown thing they're doing right now.
Me Too.
I think Connor,
when am I can't wait.
I think Connor wins a decision.
He might.
Who knows?
Yes.
Nate might my get them.
I mean,
who the fuck knows man?
All we know is Nate got him the first time that I don't know.
I'm just telling you my educated opinion.
I think Conor Mcgregor wins by decision based off that first round and more
knowledgeable training.
Bria.
But he will to about Nate Diaz with zero training coming in with 11 days and
owed five round fight.
Still one to five rounds,
but do you know how like more comfortable Nate is going to be with a full camp
then he's going to be,
I mean you would just assume that given,
okay.
There's psychological variables that come into play,
especially when you deal with the amount of pressure that Nate is under now.
If you deal with the amount of press obligations,
he's now forced to a design done more than he's ever done for sure,
but he's also getting a good long stretch of time to know what kind of shape
he's got to get in before the fight.
Right.
This is a,
I mean if you,
if you thought logically taking psychological considerations out logically would
say,
well if you won the first fight,
if he's got more time to prepare in the second fight,
he's going to be even better than he wasn't.
I could say the same thing for Connor though.
He could say he's never fight at one 70 before he,
all he did is still power punches that first round and kind of murked him the
second round.
He was in trouble cause he gas and got caught.
Man,
if he didn't do in that first round for 25 minutes,
he wins that fight.
Yeah.
Long time.
Sure.
It's your right.
Look at him saying you can play both sides.
You know you can,
you could say he was not without success in the first fight.
He had a very successful first round and he had a very successful minute plus of
the second round.
Then he got in trouble and he got a,
Trump got in trouble and Nate started talking shit and then he started getting
gas and he started getting dinged and then he shot Fred tamped down and know
where the pay downs and right in the paydays if from Mcgregor wins because
you're going to have to have a a three pay three p.
Well the pay day is if Mcgregor and Diaz have an old time shrub or Naca and
Mcgregor wins.
You had,
he has to win or he could have a fucking,
a real close decision loss to then you can't,
you can't do that.
I am obsessed.
I will not stop until I beat Nate Diaz.
Cause you lose two in a row and then you'll see it and go,
Nah Bitch,
go ahead and get down there.
They hit or not.
If you're a little white guy from Ireland named Connor Mcgregor,
that's the pot of gold at the end of the rainbow.
Mother fucker won't have a car.
No,
the UFC is love Collins.
The guy,
he's juice to the gills and here's Brock Lesnar.
That's your leopard.
Because I see other Leprechaun,
the other little guy and he's way bigger.
It's not your typical Leprechaun.
That's a different number.
Got It.
Told us.
That's communist one.
Yeah.
He dominated the first two rounds.
Three rounds a little bit.
This is the main event.
We haven't talked about single fucking fight other than a few random stuff.
We got detailed.
Great.
Until that wine theme,
we went a little off the deep end when the wine came from the way it goes to you
guys.
The gun.
It's not always
hung from masters here.
Ah,
that is hilarious.
So when you put that up on Youtube,
beneficial pool.
Hey Jamie chimp.
Chimp,
Phillip Chimp.
Was that on Youtube when you put it up tonight?
It just put it on.
Someone just made a having a real video.
I think that's hilarious.
What is his name?
Philly chimp.
All right.
Philly Cho.
Shut up.
You Know Ray Lewis trained with Rashad Evans,
right?
We're aware of this.
Yeah.
A bunch with them in Miami.
Yeah,
I didn't know that.
If the new owners of fucking gangster fucking make this happen too.
Hi Sir,
you're too tired.
Very Lewis is retired.
He's a millionaire.
It's to
know Ray Lewis.
Listen,
if you want to make the fight,
you make it with Herschel Walker because he actually still fights.
I'm not going to see those two old fucks.
Walker Herschel.
Hershel Walker's ready to fight the matter of millions.
It's just here's 20 let me make a ton of,
here's 20 million.
Make It.
If it was an APP,
if it was anybody else that was 50 years old that said he wanted to fight,
I'd be like,
man,
you got to stop.
Anybody else?
I would say I don't want to see that.
If it's Herschel Walker,
I'm like,
where do I,
how do I sign it?
Too High,
no duties.
You saw him when he was 47 just jacked,
so I believe he was 48 I stopped fighting at 31 two but dude,
commercial walker is a four re he's seen athletic.
Yes he is.
Dude.
You see the video of him fighting strike force.
Did you ever watch?
I've watched every single fight he ever did and it is shock.
His ass would get eaten up like a fucking offsite care porno by cyber jumped in
the UFC.
You
see man,
Oh,
you're talking about like someone fc or some shit.
I'm talking about him just as us,
a freak specimen.
Like if he was going to have to fight Cyborg.
We were talking about Ray Lewis,
like Ray Lewis.
We know he is a wrestler,
but we don't know how much martial arts experience he had.
That's one.
But Herschel Walker,
Herschel Walker at whatever he is now for 82 years old to 1590 9.9% of the
fucking planet we're going to run.
I agree.
You better except for every guy in the light heavyweight division on the roster
in the UFC heavyweight.
Okay.
Even worse,
he comes to the UFC that everyone's go wow.
But he's 50 years old.
It's more than 50.
I think he's 52.
He's one of the biggest freaks of all time.
You'll 50.
He might show him sprinting.
Show him with a lot of guys in the UFC.
So show him Ryan the hunter in the UFC when he was world class speed.
He had world class Pete,
did you see that guy?
Man,
did you do well,
let's just go back a year or two.
What is like,
I don't even want to name a name.
Think about some uh,
questionable heavyweight performance between a guy that's nowhere near the top
20.
Right?
Some new guy.
Maybe you don't think that Hershel Walker could fuck up some new guy?
No,
not at 50 shows.
We'll watch Herschel Walker Sprint this 20th let's,
let's see him.
This Herschel Walker would,
let's see.
Strike Force where he's getting this video of Herschel Walker fighting in
Strikeforce.
Yeah,
but he's fucking strong as shit.
I can't watch it.
And it'd be stiff walls
made.
It almost doesn't matter when you turn 50 I can't.
Fuck.
I wouldn't never have fights here.
It's faster,
isn't everybody,
dude,
he's one of the biggest freaks of all time.
I'm not saying that right now.
The heavy weights would eat him alive.
Yeah,
of course.
the heavyweights.
But they're lucky he didn't start this shit about 20 years ago.
I agree.
Oh,
if Bo Jackson decided to MMA,
oh,
she can't fucking Dick the Jupiter.
He's a month.
There are some Herschel Walker at 47 I think he was 48 here.
Look at his body.
Was He 48 here?
Yeah,
this is 48 here defending the leg lock.
Beat your ass.
Just
goodness.
Defense man.
Look at this spot around 40 and leave behind his back
and he's a super athlete,
one of the best athletes of all time.
I think a lot of us sort of underestimate the difference between the elite of
the elites and irregular cumin trained.
You look how he just rag tall that due to the ground.
Oh my God.
At too tired either.
It doesn't look like,
oh dude,
he's a stud.
He's such a super athlete.
Yup.
There's the 25 years ago.
Amazing athlete.
Didn't he win a gold medal in the bobsled?
Laugh for a moment.
Let's think for a moment.
What if custom motto existed in 2016 and he found a young 13 year old Mike Tyson
and brought him to for Rasa Hobby.
Yeah,
they'd be amazing.
Brought him to Matt Hume because freak athletes,
every now and then you get a dude like you remember when Mike Tice used to hit
that heavy bag?
You will never saw earthly Mike Tyson couldn't handle Bo Jacksons jock strap if
you get Bo Jackson when he's 13 yeah.
These guys,
we are talking about different endeavors.
We don't know what Mike Tyson's athletic ability would have been if he had been
playing football.
Well,
we do know is what it was when he got into boxing and it's almost better than
anybody ever in a lot of ways.
And the fact that he was so short and he had this crazy style of bobbing and
weaving and ripping ridiculous fucking power and speed punches at you.
Let me ask you this,
Joe,
who's the best guy that he beat?
Probably Larry Holmes,
but Larry Holmes was out of his prime to Leon Spinks or excuse me,
Michael Spinks washed this thug dude.
I'm just saying compared to the other heavyweights,
I don't think he's the,
he's the best heavyweight.
Well,
it was all before he went to jail,
man.
Awesome.
Best guys beat an old Larry Holmes or Spinks back to think of,
it's the way he ran through the division.
He changed.
He was in the pocket.
But you look at like and Lennox Lewis on banner Holyfield much more impressive.
It's true.
No,
there's nothing more about it.
Ultimately when Lennox Lewis,
when he beats Tyson Tyson,
he beat,
no,
he's those,
those old school boxing shoes he used to wear.
But when he'd be Tyson,
Tyson was an older man and you know,
he had been in the game a long fucking time.
It just wasn't the same.
Once he was disconnected more and more from the original customers.
Look at the body of work compared to a van or Holyfield and Lennox Lewis.
If you look just on paper,
my budget number has the scare factor.
That's what we all remember.
Remember Brendon,
he went out there and fucked everybody up in the first round.
Nobody else's.
He didn't pee.
Fucking had the fear where they fought Mike Tyson.
They were fucking,
and that's why we say he's the best.
That's why you say he's the best.
But if you look at it on paper,
he's really not.
And they were scared was cause he was going through everybody with one fucking
punch.
He was crushing the vendor.
Highfield wasn't scared.
People were,
yeah,
it's true.
Buster Douglas when,
and scared and true.
But it's true.
But,
uh,
but if you look at Evander Holyfield's career,
he wasn't,
he's a gold and shocking the world.
Like Mike Tyson,
Mike Tyson was just a GP.
Mike Tyson blew up paper view people.
They were pissed that he would not do doubt in the first round,
but just know that nobody's,
if you look at it,
that was the problem.
Like book,
you're just going to knock them out on the first row.
That was the proper people were pissed off with the paper view.
My president is going to beat him in the first round and we're going to lose
our money.
Fuck.
That was a problem he created.
Nobody's if you'd like.
No,
no.
He's got everybody up and people were scared shitless.
It was no other that provoked that.
No,
you're right.
You're right.
He was a special force.
So scary side on earth.
But listen with with Brenda is talking about is like hindsight like so when
Brendan is talking about it now when you look back and you think about the guys
he beat,
it's very arguable that holy field was the superior fighter.
He beat him twice and we always want to say,
well,
he wasn't the same guy as when Tyson,
he doesn't matter.
He's still beat him.
When they got together and holy field,
you got to put him on a higher level because he was able to maintain his
enthusiasm for fighting way longer than most folks.
Natural cruiserweight.
So many fights like,
fuck,
we're really low and amateurs,
amateurs,
man who won the gold,
make the team look at the body of work.
His career was amazing.
The fights he was in,
but Tyson was known for going through.
Dude,
that doesn't mean he's a better fighter.
I think you have to give it to a van or calls a vandal beat him twice,
but Tyson is one of the all time greats and they're both all time greats.
I mean,
we're super lucky to have watched those guys fight.
I agree.
You know Tyson and Holyfield x factor because he's so scared of the stock in
these guys out.
Boys,
can we go here we go.
To manifest.
Tyson was more exciting,
man.
It's 10 boy doesn't make you better fight.
Here's Harrison.
Yair Rodriguez,
Tyson main event.
Look at that perfect hook.
It's better than me.
Yeah,
but you always got to wonder like what was,
what was the training like for Tyson then in comparison to the training when he
was young?
What was the mindset like?
I,
I'm a firm believer that a really elite fighter could only maintain a certain
number of Rpms when they're just smashing people.
They can only maintain that for a certain amount of time.
I mean,
uh,
the password prove you right.
You know what I'm saying?
You look get all fighters,
but we don't realize it when they're going through it.
Like if you look at Ronda,
it was like,
yeah,
that's what she does.
You look at junior dos Santos,
you look at cane like certain,
it's weird.
Then you step back,
you'll,
oh,
that was the Ra.
That's the run there.
That's the greatest Rev.
We're going to see him make a call right now as it's happening.
You really don't notice.
I was thinking about that the other days.
You,
uh,
you're accustomed to it and you think that's just what they do and then they
lose like two or three.
You're like,
oh shit.
That was his,
that was it.
That was the run until six,
seven fights.
Which it was pure greatness.
Music is like that too.
Like bands that would come out with their new album but their new album,
it's not like they're old shit.
Their new album is no like the old chick.
But then that new shit is old shit.
Fight,
fight,
washed our rig is how he's better.
Rodriguez is going to reduce is to Sarah's is fucking threatened him a few
times.
This is a heavy favorite midsummer to spinning this.
He shows getting back fast.
Nah.
Oh Cause Harris has to rant.
He's um,
he's athletic but he's,
he's too,
uh,
for sure out.
He doesn't have the fundamentals.
I don't think that Rodrigo,
oh,
mistakes.
It makes big mistakes.
His hands are down.
He's been getting tagged and then wanting to fight with her.
Hands down.
No Rodriguez,
Rodriguez Kellen on this when they're close read because his hands are up.
Defense made a better default is excellent.
But Dude,
cause Sarah's is very good,
very athletic,
very good.
He,
he,
he's,
he needs Brian towns.
Workshops got fundamental.
He's not as good fundamentally.
He's just not as Rodriguez.
He's just not watch your mouth.
I would,
I would disagree with you.
All right.
I would say because Sarah's is very underrated,
is very crafty in our athletic,
very crafty and watching lenses.
He's very comfortable in they Brian Rodriguez a heavy favorite.
Yeah.
I'm not saying that.
My point is be this beautiful leg lock attempt here.
Barbara Drugas it's not,
I'm not saying that he's not going to win.
I'm just seeing you like you saying that it doesn't have good fundamentals.
I'm not being insulting to concerns.
What I'm saying is anything,
I just watched their first one minute guys and I saw and I saw him make big
mistakes where he's coming in and throwing and being really athletic but getting
caught in the face by a,
by a guy who was a really a better counter punch.
I don't see that and I fought for it.
Yeah.
Well I did cause you weren't watching.
You were talking the whole time,
dammit.
Are you a fan?
If you ever watched a fight before?
I have fight with Sergio Pettis.
Great.
What happened to the fight was her job,
but I didn't see that fight.
He beat him.
He was the first guy to beat.
Not saying he's not really good.
I'm saying he doesn't have the fundamental is that to fight in the Harris is
listened to me right now and don't ever say anything different compared to
compared to rugby again.
Please.
Alex Harris is a bad motherfucker.
I never seen her.
Rodriguez is a bad one of the foul.
Have Fun right now.
You fuck.
Hey.
I said [inaudible] has better fundamentals.
That's what I said.
You sit here,
no fundamentals.
You need the movement.
You see how he evaded that high kick and then watching what y'all,
he's evading every stop trying to control my eyeballs.
Bryan Harris was very good.
I've of course,
he's very good.
I said he's not as good as Bermuda.
Fuck.
His fundamentals are not as good as [inaudible] as Arab,
not Bermuda is you?
Fuck,
sorry man.
Jumping.
Don't tell about Oh,
good fundamentals.
Good fundamentals.
Oh my God.
There it is.
Look at the fundamental grip.
We're like a bunch of children with the example of how not to behave when you're
on a live podcast.
It's so true.
What does that going to be equally,
I don't think they an issue for men.
I think it's an issue for women.
That is,
at least as far as what I read,
I loose loosely looked over it and see if you can find it.
Jamie with the new regulation is about women's clothing.
If I just made that up like Joe doesn't say anything about women,
we put something in my coffee bro.
That's what's so said,
man.
She's fucking Bro.
Cause I lose shit.
What does the Holy Shit do for us?
Nothing.
It's just
because of wardrobe malfunctions.
Someone
was hanging out recently.
Sorry.
Maybe I'm talking about the fight before.
Maybe I was thinking about Bermuda has just now.
Oh,
because Sarah's powerful sugar ray Leonard still fucking whack in that bag.
It's still,
he's still fuck you up.
It's in Skechers each aspect by getting,
you can't the white sox imagine if he's wearing Birkenstocks with socks and beat
the fuck out.
He could
just fuck.
That's George.
Come on.
Wait a minute.
Hold on.
What do you mean?
That's George Hamilton.
I believe that would be George Hamilton is talking fried chicken.
Colonel Sanders.
Now what happened in Norm Macdonald?
No,
it's norm macdonald.
Nope,
that was not,
that was George Hamilton.
I click five different ones recently.
One per commercial kind of.
Oh,
they're getting crafted.
It doesn't take place until January 1st it says to Joe,
if they give you $1 million,
would you be colonel Sanders just for just for one campaign.
Just only three months.
Think about it.
I like chicken.
Female competitors must wear a short sleeved above the elbow or sleeveless form
fitting rash,
guard and or sports bra.
No loose fitting tops are allowed.
Female competitors will follow the same requirements for bottom coverings as a
male competitors.
Oh,
okay.
So they only have to have a tight fitting upper top because did anybody ever
have a loose fitting upper Tom?
You don't.
You can't have your titty slang,
but did anybody,
did they just want to cover their ass with that?
Is that what that was?
Nobody,
but it was never an issue.
Right.
And having dinner.
Oh yeah.
Bra got fucked up and she had to look at the ref.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Dad
doing cartwheels.
His taekwondo is off the charts.
This shows you the chance to talk with us.
This shit.
The guy,
Brian,
you sound like a guy acting like a commentator and a movie right there.
Who Does?
It's like the karate kid.
Seven.
Did I just say
I've never it off the charts in my life and I just did.
Just don't talk.
That's blocked off.
I can't stop laughing.
Get Joe doing the KFC commercials.
You do it for a certain price.
Probably not.
Now that you guys brought it up,
he has thrown some fucking whipping kicks.
Yeah,
man,
it's fundamentals are so sound,
dude.
Tell him you look how good you can say this is defenses man says sliding.
Beautiful young man.
At what point does the APP pro become like a hindrance?
Never.
Never cushion for those fucking hard brand kicks.
The back of the head pushing that is he just did a backhand.
Oh he back.
Can't you?
Punched his knee and then came up with a backhand.
Wow.
You know what,
the reps are probably allowed kids to the back of the head.
Guys of both.
This is a five round fight boys.
This is getting,
Rodriguez happened like really trying to end.
This shit is increasing him down here.
George Hampton has the new car colonel second called it.
How many uh,
kernels or they're going to be Jamie.
You know they have to do a block one.
Right hire is going to spin.
What about a Mexican?
That too.
Can't just have one like all the time wizard it.
Mix it up.
It's racist.
Yeah,
she definitely go a black colonel Sanders.
Yeah.
That would be the best way to sell chicken.
Colonel Sanders,
the real Colonel Colonel Sanders in his white have a black eye take over the
colonel Sanders and it would have it be like a deal.
She ugly character who just makes fun of white people and that's,
that's the new Colonel Sanders image.
Like a hilarious black standup comedian.
What?
Tony Robbins has a thing about carnal sandwich.
It wouldn't do it.
He would demand picks up sort of Latino name outside kick God damn envelope of
just fucking this somehow with someone.
It wouldn't be racist if you got a guy like if you paid a hilarious standup
comedian,
Kevin Hart,
he's too valuable.
He probably wouldn't do it.
But if you hadn't been wanes,
I'm not going to be rude.
Let's come up with someone,
some Richard Pryor,
some notes,
I'm non non real person.
But if you were like a pretty decent standup comedian,
really funny guy,
I ruined book and they were willing to pay you to be deal.
Who?
The new black Colonel Sanders and you had a bunch of jokes where the only made
fun of white people.
Martin Lawrence,
you would kill the bill.
It'd be a great idea.
Do you think he could do it?
What is this?
Campsie taps David Allen Grier's the first African American.
The Fuck Outta here.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
That was a white guy.
You show it and express.
That guy is a letter to Larry.
So fucking we knew it.
That's hilarious.
We were speculating.
Meanwhile this is actually a real thing yet.
Oh cause it has to be a that.
That's just,
how do you think he's lying to Sarah's coming on strong.
Y'All Rodriguez.
Welcome to deep waters.
Alex.
Would no fundamentals going.
Brian Callen coming on strong or said he
never said he didn't have fundamental amazing finds any at bat from him.
I'm not as good as Rodrigo.
I don't remember what,
I just want to be really honest about this.
Yeah,
you probably should have stopped somewhere in the middle.
You just,
I know you feel it too.
Right?
Like you got on a roll too.
You are defending your position and I got to keep,
depending on what we now know that Brenda knows more than Nope,
I'm going to die.
Right.
And the just,
Sarah's is obviously handling himself in his fight against one of the most
dangerous guys in the division.
I'm going down and getting his own shots in as well.
You know about that day.
That year is a fucking beat.
Your case of consent can't really do,
Bro.
You can agree with you and I'll tell you something else.
Two body shots.
Adam was three straight Yas,
right?
I told you her Daniel Allen Greer will not be the first Colonel Sanders.
It's a lie.
He backed me.
He tweeted it lands David Alan Grier.
He's trying to jump in the plot.
You don't have enough fucking contract.
He knew what he did.
He was joking.
No,
he's honey Dicken.
What's it honey in KFC.
You'd be like,
yeah,
that's a great idea,
is a great idea.
Said KFC is racist as fuck.
Like absolutely.
I would like to volunteer to make fun of white people.
If he gets that job too would help.
I will.
I will help write some chokes.
I'll buy the chicken.
You got to keep it white.
They could get ugly.
No.
Well,
Popeye's does it kind of.
I can't wait.
You got to keep it white.
I can't wait until all fried chicken places just make fun of white people suck
and eat fried chicken with zero kilt.
Just muck all whiteness.
I'll make it delicious chicken.
I'll take it.
I'll go through some shit to get that chicken.
Sorry.
Things are the way they are.
I'm surprised he didn't mean for anything.
Anybody that looks like me did in the past.
I don't know those fucking beat.
Both of them do with it.
I don't agree with it all to pieces with a biscuit.
Make Fun of white people and give me some chicken.
Make Fun of Weipa.
I Wa wa anybody please.
Let's level this playing field.
I'll roast them with you guys.
Thing,
thing that something's delicious.
It's fried chicken is in somehow or any way racist.
Everybody should breathe freely.
Enjoy a drink.
I love a nice grape sodas
for real.
There is a not be race.
I'm not trying to be funny.
Try Drinking a grape soda.
I'm just being cool too.
I had some buttermilk fried chicken in a restaurant in Atlanta.
It's really,
it was so good.
That's not racist,
so God damn good ahead it two years ago and I never forgot it.
Fried Chicken's incredible.
Good
white people make chick filet chicken,
but this wasn't chick filet chest.
It's just like a gourmet restaurant made fried chicken.
That's what I'm saying.
The old school way.
While I was just thinking in my head,
I was having a conversation again,
but KFC,
Popeye's,
right?
It's Kinda,
you know.
Right.
And then chick fil A's owned by Mormons.
Is this why they shut down the Mormon?
So there's,
there's some kind of crazy Christians chicken too.
But how about this?
How about there's a,
I don't want to mention though.
Shit,
you guys are missing some great fighters.
T and off on this because it's fun.
It's fun.
Have you ever had that chicken bag?
Get at the ARC light with watermelon?
Have a hat.
I've lived it.
Oh,
nice.
Left hand by
Barb.
Racist at Arc light.
I Riggins is no joke.
I sure haven't.
Rodriquez a style they close on Sunday at site.
They closed on Sundays because Christian beliefs.
What about us?
What about his style?
His style requires a lot of exploding.
Like his style is all like leaping forward and leaping back and moving forward
fast is,
has a lot of like serious explosions.
It's fun to watch what is,
it's no,
it's great.
Amazing.
It's great.
But what I'm,
what I'm saying is like,
it takes a really high level of fitness to fight this style because he's doing
essentially like wrestling.
But like with all these plyometrics built into it,
you know,
he's like leaping forward and backward.
Yeah.
Where's Alex Dream?
Remember this isn't Utah,
so the level elevations high,
but Rodriguez comes from Albuquerque so it's not gonna be as high as
Albuquerque.
So I would assume later in rounds is going to favor Rodriguez.
If you think about that.
He's also been t and off.
Like he's,
he's doing crazy stuff.
It's hard to,
how do you train for a guy like Doris?
But because Sarah's is from uh,
the John Crouches camp and they do do some training up in the mountains.
That's an Arizona.
Yeah,
they did.
They go into those Arizona mountains,
like Arizona does have mountains.
A lot of people don't realize how,
fuck,
hey Brandon,
when he throws this right way,
ways head's going all the way to the side like that.
That's a really interesting thing.
Is that,
is that normal or,
I didn't see it.
Joe,
did you see him throw this right and he,
he ducks his head,
his head,
see what he's doing.
Who?
His head.
Sarah's.
I know a red Rodriguez.
Really interesting.
He keeps punching the needs when he,
you'll see him go down,
he punches the knees just damn.
Although Alex or through a fucking knee had been trouble.
But yeah,
all the way to the side when he does it,
watch what that lesson was it,
it's knowing when he see what he's doing.
It's knowing when you could do something too.
It's like knowing when your,
your opponent is leaning his weight backwards and reveal a time it right.
Or knowing when he's committing to one side or another side and being able to
anticipate it and time it.
It's very one sided fight right now.
Very one sided fun fight though.
Yeah,
but,
but inside you're so connected to help me out with this.
Just think about what I'm saying.
You're so connected to your previous statement that you are not willing to enjoy
this fight as it plays out.
No,
sorry.
You're wrong.
You're wanting this fight.
Turn them up.
Just hit him with a beautiful knee to the body and a nice combination of right
would be there was a good shot.
Rodriguez isn't dominated.
I'm fine.
It's amazing.
Oh,
Sarah's just rang that bell sign might be changing a little bit here.
Please just listen to your,
listen to your voice.
The instinct of the back of my head is telling you right now.
Shut the fuck up.
No,
he doesn't have that and I don't know because no,
she's saying so far in,
in,
in round has been winning this fight.
Handling.
It looks like you sound like a guy in a movie.
Hey Brian handily,
because I use the word handedly isn't handling your headedly triangle a tent.
We get this wrong knee bar.
Oh step Rah Rah.
Slippery,
slippery,
slippery third round.
Hud.
Regus is God.
Yeah man.
So is Alex to Harris who's on top bitch?
No,
they need a real Mexican guys.
A champ
that first round.
And why can Sarah was hard to deal with.
I will admit that I'm thinking about that first round.
He's just making fun of you right now.
Brian.
Whatever was on top,
I didn't take the bait up.
Yeah,
you're Rodriguez and he's making fun of you ignoring your bait.
Cause I see the hook.
I not making pick nor at green cause he's winning this fight right now.
Alex,
you Sarah says winning.
This is a school yard fight and they pulled Alex to Sarah's off right now
everyone would agree that Alex because tariffs one that'd be truth.
Wants to be where he's created all the
travel was being sarcastic.
Ladies and gentlemen just as what he does and you don't want you to know it.
You would assume he's on your side.
What's called honey ticking.
Hey could you do you know what you're doing?
Cause Sarah's won that round.
I'll give it to him.
He's probably two one but it's close.
Doing judge fights ever for fear of your own life,
for your safety to and fighters know the fans listening are going to back me up
on this.
I guess you're the uh,
well it's two one,
yeah I agree with you there.
But I guess a year in the circle of trust her so you can judge the fights bank's
money and I agree with you that first round he did win first and second buddy
first and second.
[inaudible] a nice straight left hand.
Let me look.
Cause Sarah is a lucid to the head.
That was beautiful.
He's not touching.
He's not really hitting cause he was.
Look at it.
Boom.
Hit him there man.
Boom them.
They're a little bit,
a little bit cut up right there.
It's cut.
Cut.
Brian.
That was one highlight from a more than a minute of ground and power when he was
on top.
No big deals.
It's more than a minute.
Two minutes probably.
I guess.
I'm not exactly sure how much time and weapons around two minutes,
but he beat him up on the ground for at least a minute.
Beat up.
Beat him up as a strong,
a strong statement.
It's a strong,
you're strong.
You're being strong and you're being a little strong.
That beautiful round kick their butts.
It gets,
has he whips it man.
Fucking weapon.
Look at it.
Oh he's so quick.
Look and see what he's doing when he's ducking his head like that.
It's interesting.
I haven't seen a lot of people throw writes that way.
He's obviously like super fit because he's recovered from that grappling.
Keeps the next round.
Yeah.
Super feminist values.
Oh,
you have to be a cardio machine.
Have to be.
Yeah,
you have to be so ready to explode for five rounds.
But he's connecting.
I would love to talk to him about like what kind of protocol he follows.
Like for strength and conditioning because he's like all this is so fast.
Like he's relying like a lot of his moves are like countermoves and like,
oh his angles though.
He keeps catching.
It's really interesting.
Well they both have really good angles,
man.
I'm telling you.
Cause Sarah's you,
you like you're looking at that Afro and you're going,
this guy's
silly.
I'm not a bad mother.
Fucking amazing athlete and a great fighter.
It's just to sleep better.
He's also a really cool looking at this stuff,
Alex to Sarah.
I'm not cool being in any way.
I don't think I'm being in any way as one of the nicest friendliest dudes.
And he's,
I love watching them like dance on the way to the,
to his fights too.
Cause I loved when he come out and when he came on the Bruce Lee jumpsuit,
the yellow and black,
this shit was so sick.
He looks he was going to struggle.
It's awesome.
When you guys talk over each other,
look at that.
Aye.
The count.
I mean,
uh,
rhetoric is landed a lot more shots,
but Sarah's is sell tough.
Whoa.
Was that done an assessment?
Is this 55 you're only comfortable if no one's talking about it just feels weird
when no one's talking,
right?
Yeah.
Here is,
he's so good on the outside,
but because Sarah,
it has an excellent idea of distance where if,
you know,
he's connecting like when he's moving forward in particular,
but because Sarah's is able to avoid a lot of the shit that y'all,
you're throwing it bro.
I can't get fried chickens out of my mind.
I love it.
Love Fried Shit.
It's one of the problems with going kio someone have kido fried chicken.
Oh,
can't you do it with like a damn delicious?
Well,
you could,
we could what we could do you get chickens ripped the skin off.
Listen,
it doesn't have to be fried.
Let me tell you something about this fucking place.
This Cuban joint in Encino,
California,
was it called?
Oh my God.
What does that joint called?
It was a place on Versailles to Versailles is everywhere.
They're in Venice.
I know there's a,
there's a couple of them.
I've only been to one.
I've been to the one,
oh my God,
the chicken there.
But they have this garlic checking with onions.
Holy Shit Dude.
It's Quito.
Holy Shit.
No,
I'm sure it's not.
It might,
it might.
It might be.
Hey,
sugar in the song.
If it's can't fuck with the beans.
Fried Chicken.
Fuck off.
It's not fried.
I don't think.
I think it's broiled.
Ever.
Eat the fried chicken and fuck off.
I'm telling you,
these Cubans are masters of the chicken watering their masters of this lemon
garlic chicken with onions,
onions.
I mean smothering,
barely seared onions.
I love a nice son,
Joe.
You are you ever gonna not be,
Kiddo.
Now that you've done it,
thousands of a calmer.
I think it's a,
I think it's very beneficial for your health.
Is that it right there?
Ooh,
beautiful
black beans.
I had a yam today and you'll lead to a black beans as well.
But you know what,
man,
I'm,
I follow.
You don't,
then it's Ketogenic.
I follow the primal.
Do Rice very little,
man.
I just think that your body should at the most,
uh,
get you like a certain amount of car.
Like some people think it's 25 grams of sugar.
They think that's probably the most important one.
Forget about carbohydrates.
Like the real important one in terms of like your own health is never allowing
yourself to get over 25 grams of sugar a day.
For most people,
that's not even a single glass of soda.
That's hard for people to deal with it too.
That's a big part.
It's a big part of Mark Sisson's.
Uh,
ideas shine.
Kini black beans,
you can't even money.
No,
you're not really supposed to.
You could fuck around with it a little bit every now and then,
but it shouldn't be a primary on every day you're dying.
Well,
you want to do is get your body,
eat comfortable with eating a lot of Avocados,
fat,
a lot of healthy fats,
coconut oil,
healthy fats like a mola.
If you,
you're getting protein,
you don't wanna get too much protein.
You know,
you want to have a good,
healthy amount of like lean animal protein.
But you guys,
you guys gotta Watch this many causes fight.
You simply have to have to do anything,
Bro,
come on at a respect for these amazing big kid who kid fighters.
Um,
uh,
some guy came up to me at the UFC and said,
hey man,
can I get your picture?
I'm a kito kid.
I said,
no,
no.
Yourself.
You Fuck,
you can't,
can't tell me you're a kito kid and answer
a bunch of Keto kid a tee shirt.
Everybody.
I'm kidding.
It's so funny.
No,
he can't.
So No,
you're not shut the fuck up.
No,
no,
no.
I'll do,
did say that to me.
But I was running back for taking,
I was running back from taking a leak.
It was in between fights.
I like the idea of two grams of sugar.
That's a really good,
how about at our last show?
I had a old swinger swinger couple asked me to go back to the hotel.
They wanted me to sign dick.
While he watched with his old ass wives.
Sounds right.
Your idea,
if you discuss it with your life and want to kill yourself soon,
I said,
bitch,
you gotta you gotta you gotta be crazy.
I just need something really fucking gross to push me over the edge.
I just see
myself
as long as you're not
sure yet,
fuck her in the ass.
She doesn't share her ass all either.
She's from the 60s.
[inaudible] over the egg.
I love these guys.
These are men.
Men.
Brian keeps showing reverence isn't counter well.
They're huffy each other,
man.
These guys are warriors putting it all out there.
Oh,
just please shut the fuck up.
Cachet machine.
There's no,
Hey,
these guys are out here in the ring.
Yes,
Don Gi Joe.
These guys are sweating.
You call me a cliche.
You should narrate like a children's show about war.
He's never been so into watching.
These men are all,
they're all seniors.
And when the wind warrior,
me and Sam Sheridan Been Eric Apple Powerful.
I like care capital.
Good Dude.
He's a good dude.
Sinews tech guys too,
man.
Eric Capitol.
Petit's uh,
his wrist broke so many times I think I'm going to do this injustice,
but I think they like had to like shorten.
Like one of his wrists,
he shattered it so badly and they had told them like,
there's no way you'll ever be able to punch.
He's like,
yeah,
whatever.
I'm fighting who's like,
he fought with this thing and it's,
but it's,
it's that apparently
when we were doing warrior,
he went and got an extra because his neck was all fucked up and he broke his
neck.
She's just crying.
He's like,
oh my neck broke.
Complete lie.
But Jesus Christ,
I had a chance to hang out with that dude in England.
He's a good dude.
When you,
when you,
when people in the road like Eddie,
you came with us,
right?
Eddie wasn't in England.
We all hung out together.
Oh Shit.
I'm talking about this because here it's on the town.
I don't remember when we all went out trip from the next,
I know there were so many pen cause Sarah's on top.
Oh,
Hammer fist here with Jake is working for leg.
Welcome for the leg.
Oh,
he's fine.
Beautiful.
Beautiful job.
Easing the leg lock.
Fight this.
I'm a pot.
Not so good though.
These guys are using it.
Maybe it's sweet.
Get past the right leg.
Back up to you.
If you kidding me with this fight.
Are you kidding me with this fight?
Wow.
Brian,
you really nailed it and I ain't no
fucking here's turbo.
Whoa.
Hold on a timeout guys.
We've got a time.
You fucks.
Hold on.
Any boring fight.
Brian's going to bring in another attainment.
Whoa.
He's perfect.
You're going to turn it into the play by play guy.
Not Bad,
right?
The mark of the Mike Goldberg.
I should be the third guy in their broken Kohlberg.
Joe would kill him.
Don't get a level one guy or the play by play guy here.
I think so too,
buddy.
You would definitely get your ass kicked.
Someone's going to beat your ass.
It's going to be out.
A matter of time.
I'm going to be like,
doc,
I get me Dad.
I mean by meet your old bull ring.
I mean that's what I mean.
Is that what out of here Brian?
Brian counts and trying to save your life.
Fuck,
because some guy's about to beat the fuck out I and they go,
Holy Shit.
I was just fundamental dad.
I've never answered a boxing buddy that could do you pop.
Pop is,
I've never had,
I've never seen him so nobody could do gel.
Right.
Done.
It's not that good.
You're so out there and you're still pronounced and you've got like such a
character,
but nobody could do.
I could take care of them if I worked at it.
I could do to,
let me see you do it right now.
Brian.
It's feel super uncomfortable as big fights going on right now,
boys.
Oh yeah.
Oh sweet.
Deep Sense.
We take crazy crazy punches to the fuck off bro.
The Fuck Jay was.
Imagine if the Afro did actually protect
mine some more.
[inaudible] don't think it does.
He can't cut his beard.
Remember that they want Kimberly beer cause they said guilty and or a punch on
the chin.
It was cushion it.
There's an art.
Roy Nelson is an argument for chokes.
It get does get in the way.
Yeah.
I mean sure,
you try it again and a little harder to close up.
Correct.
But I wonder if that,
that's a lot of hair that that would act as question,
don't you think?
But meanwhile if,
yeah,
I mean Kimbo slice had a fucking magnificent beard though.
Amazing Beer.
I mean,
for the sake of the people,
you've got to let them have that big asking him to fucking cut.
Hello.
Look gas in Chuck Norris.
Shave his mustache as you guys.
Yeah,
and look at Alex because Sarah's coming on strong.
Solid.
He's missing,
but he's awesome.
Rodriguez.
Beautiful combination.
They're both guys.
They are both guys and this is an amazing fight.
A couple of men,
a couple of men who see,
this is my question about yard,
right?
Yahya Rodriguez,
a style.
It's almost never been employed.
Like all these kind of kicks.
It's almost never been employed this way for five rounds.
What's the question he's,
he's doing,
he's doing stuff that takes a lot of energy,
right?
A lot of it is jumping and leaping and it's not a lot of damage though,
is he?
Well,
he's not as damaged guy.
A really skillful guy.
I mean he did damage to a Andre Fili and his last fight he knocked him out with
the jumping jumping round two.
But before that is two decisions.
Yeah.
But he's fighting tough guys man.
I mean if he lands shit dude man shit.
Wow.
What a whole life.
Fuck.
Wow.
What a fight.
What studs.
Beautiful.
What studs and that was a great fight.
Dad Late racisms duds.
Sorry.
This is a good dude.
He is.
But he lost that fight but he's a great day.
I'm sure he was definitely not scoring that fight.
And I know you were.
No,
no,
no.
There's no question that the only fight the only round cause here's one was one
round and that's no disrespect to cause there's probably shouldn't be talking
right now.
No disrespect.
It's just that Rodrigues is amazing.
He's amazing.
God there was at one round that because Sarah seem to be winning,
right?
At least.
Oh for sure.
Yes.
You could probably get him to fight you for sure.
Three,
two.
I will tell you for sure.
I definitely wasn't paying attention.
I wouldn't put money,
put more money on it and me neither.
He listen to you guys I didn't miss around or a second.
It is super interesting.
The concept of adjusting and changing how fights are scored and the new criteria
for a 10,
eight round.
That could also be a giant new issue and especially three round fights.
You're talking about a game changer.
The guy has to get a finished basically to win.
Well think of those two new moves.
Just the two new moves that we know.
The,
the new uh,
hands down position being a like in order to be where you are off balance or a
off of a bounce for head kicks or knees to the ground,
you have to have both hands,
flat palms flat on the ground.
Anything else?
Even the tips of your fingers.
The guy could punt you in the face,
you know he's saying remember if like Whoa,
we got one down.
You couldn't touch them.
Yes.
Now getting remarried.
They do this,
they do this thing.
Yes.
Now you have to have both down.
Now we've got one blue one hand,
I can you in the face like I can kick you in the face.
Damn,
that's so cute to changes.
And then the new change,
the criteria of how to score ten eight rounds,
they're establishing clearer understanding of what does and does not constitute
a ten eight round.
And uh,
I think that's always going to be open to,
uh,
to people's judgment.
You know,
there's always an issue with the subject kill a motherfucker to get a ten eight
back in the day.
Now.
Yeah.
I've had some ridiculous conversations with people about what does and does not
constitute a 10,
nine round or extending how that works in boxing I year one.
Yeah,
of course.
Powerful Yahya Richard and powerful.
Eric's could Sarah's,
he's a bad mother.
Motherfucker cray fight.
Great fight in boxing.
All you gotta do is knock a guy down.
And unless you completely like,
say if a guy like Andre Ward is beaten your fucking ass all round the ring for
two minutes,
56 seconds.
Split decision.
Oh,
this is one 45.
One 40 45.
Yeah.
So if a guy like Andre Ward's beating the fuck out of you for two minutes and 50
seconds and then you just close your eyes and swing and catch him on the Chin
and he falls down on his ass and he gets up at the count of eight and they dust
as gloves off in the round dance and by ten eight no,
probably be nine nine.
Okay.
But any other circumstance when you are,
it's a close fight or close round and the guy gets dropped.
It's always a ten eight okay.
It's pretty much established.
That's a ten eight so we know if we're watching the fight at home and we know
like say if a Manny Pacquiao was fighting some dude and he knocks the dude down
three times in the first five rounds.
So like that guy's fucked.
You can't win a decision,
you can't,
I mean it can,
but he'd have to knock Manny down round.
So if you knock somebody out in one round that three times,
if knock somebody down three times in one round,
what would the score be usually?
Well,
it's one point for every knocked down.
So it's ten eight for one,
knocked down ten seven for two knock downs and in most title fights they waive
the three knockdown rule so he can have some fucking crazy chaotic shit like
some ass beating some organizations.
They waved that three knockdown rule.
The state in the beginning it was a no three knockdown rule.
K One took it to the next level.
K One had a two knockdown rule.
If you got knocked out twice in a fight,
it was over cause they made you fight like three times a night.
Damn.
Makes Sense.
That's sick.
Yeah,
it makes sense.
But here magic it fells one.
Slice the cheese.
Nope,
I'm good getting knocked down.
You eating a pound of cheese but it's so good.
I knew you'd love this age provolone.
There's nothing quite like and my grandfather,
hundred percent Sicilian.
I used to have a wheel is a shoe.
Is this?
You're for real.
I'm being dead serious.
No,
that's,
it's amazing.
My grandfather would bring it home.
He'd bring a wheel of aged provolone.
Apologize to Alex Cause Sarah's now
you said he didn't have any fundamental,
I didn't.
I said his fundamentals are not as sound.
Essentially.
He said,
Jamie,
did he say his fundamentals aren't very good?
I don't,
I honestly don't remember what I said.
I knew it had something to do with never said anything about him at all.
But look at it.
Go back.
Take a look at the difference there Brian.
It was a split decision,
which means one judge thought that Kiss Harris did enough.
Judge,
you said an idiot.
Oh,
I'm not so sure is it's,
it's no disrespect cause here's he's fighting an amazing fighter and he did a
great job,
but he did get tagged a lot and,
and we'll give that our boy didn't get hit much full and that crazy.
The whole kick does.
I agree with you,
but he lost the fight.
I'm just saying you can't tell from the naked eye that guide and have good
fundamental,
I just,
I didn't say you didn't have good funnels.
You did.
I do.
I said you don't remember what he said is fundamental.
Are Not as good as say.
That's first.
Remember what I said.
I do think what I meant was let's,
let's just give you a chance to clarify right now because this has already been
principally,
so here's the,
here's what I and then a website,
but here's what I,
six wheels,
here's what I say.
All I was saying when I was watching that,
as I said,
Huh,
it looks like when Chris Harris throws the shot,
he takes it in the face and Mrs. Rodriguez,
this is round one and I went and I saw it three times and I'm like,
well and then,
well I'd see Rodrigues throw shot and when he throws shot,
he was in a position where he couldn't get hit.
And I said,
that looks like Rodriguez has better fundamentals then [inaudible] you like
stand by that 100% who?
Well well-read version of the old man at the gas station.
Correct.
Talks to his other old man.
We get together and you're like what he needed to do cause we did wrong.
This is why you don't understand boxing.
Got Some Gay Sam guy that critiques Don Brady stolen motion.
I have to you.
No,
I do some boxing.
I obsess over fundamentals and I love it and I think I'm qualified to at least
know my naked eye.
Oh my naked actions to professional Missouri with my naked eye.
I'm able to quiet sir.
With my naked eye,
sir,
if I may with my naked eye,
I am able to see who is actually a little better.
We'll to
grade you.
What you said to a t,
you said Alex doesn't have any fundamental dude.
What I'm saying at the end of the day is that if you look at funny,
if you have two fighters,
I think there's a sudden you're not qualified to judge the two fighters.
Then I'm able to fucking look at my fucking arms.
I'm going to fucking start doing more curls.
Listen,
yeah.
Years of peace,
no doubt about it.
But I just,
I just,
uh,
just didn't think you were totally fair to what could Sarah's brings.
His life is not fair,
Joe.
I just didn't think it was totally accurate.
I'm not living in a nursery school.
I think you've got a little defensive afterwards and started defending it in
some sort of a weird way.
Guys.
I know had a good case,
comfortable.
I really listen to,
ultimately,
you can walk with this fairly
unscaved because yeah,
you're Rodriguez want a split decision,
so it's all good.
But they're both beasts based.
Sarah Rodriguez,
he's only three,
so 23 five and on the UFC,
he's so good.
He threw up on my holy shit.
He threw up on me once.
It wasn't his fault.
I mean,
it just took some of it got on my shoes.
He threw up on himself.
He like actually threw up underneath his,
uh,
shirt.
It was one of his fights at a brutal fight.
And a while I was talking to him while I was interviewing me.
He threw up Jesus Christ.
Hey,
you should be ashamed of himself to you.
He knows what judge gave off right now.
I'm honored.
[inaudible] Gigas you know,
one judge gave her all three rounds an hour to look at that.
46 49 for Alex.
I might've changed his story.
He might've like throw like a particle might've landed on my foot and now all of
a sudden I'm like,
he threw up on me.
He doused.
You still counts,
Bro.
It was like that fucking blueberry pie eating contest from that Stephen King
movie.
Stand by me back.
Remember that?
Lard ass.
Yeah.
That's my real hard ass lard ass.
That was a fucking awesome movie.
You know.
I wish they would recreate it.
It,
yeah.
I think they were saying that they were going to do something like that.
Marie daily could is redoing the haylage.
No,
that's so good.
Are they really any McBride's in it?
Ooh,
I love it.
That's it.
He's good.
He's,
I love him.
Oh,
it's cause Sarah's,
this is a fucking fun fight to watch highlights.
It is when we're not trying to calm,
calm,
calm down.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
It's called a spinning of that format and that's the last month of the funny
shit.
That's the last move of the fight,
by the way.
That's the same division.
How crazy would it that fight be Connor Mcgregor player?
Rodriguez?
Not right now
to build up too though,
for sure.
Smart thing to build up to a year is 23 years old.
Wow.
Kid isn't even close to his prime.
I make a call right now.
You're looking at,
please don't,
please don't put that division.
No Shit.
He's 23 amazing.
I made,
that's my call.
Everybody while you're going down,
it is highly possible.
Highly possible that at one point in his career he could hold the title though.
I'll tell you why.
I have a guy that talented at 23.
It's fucking nuts.
That's crazy.
So,
so good.
And like,
have you ever seen him hit the pads?
She really kind of interesting because he does all that shit like as a regular
part of his training.
You're like,
you know,
a lot of guys will throw kicks like one,
two left hook,
right leg kick left.
Took Ruffin,
right?
Bodytech yeah,
nothing fancy.
And that's like the majority of the training when Yair Rodriguez does pad work,
it's like Jab,
we'll kick jab three 60 roundhouse kick his flying knee.
Oh yeah,
dude.
His videos online of him,
uh,
at a gym doing pad work or super super trust three.
That's not,
but I'll tell you what,
man,
I'm a,
I'm still a believer in Aleks because Sarah's,
I'm a big fan of the chippy.
I've been saying that from day one.
I was trying,
he has,
I mean,
he is,
oh my God.
What the flu is that it was like,
just see
Brian,
you,
Brendan,
whether you have your,
uh,
your finger on the pulse of American pop culture.
Yes,
he does.
Bristol Bay.
When it's time for a new it and Bam.
You did it totally independently.
I did.
And Colonel Sandals.
Turtle Sandals.
Black girl Sanders,
her sandals.
Turtle sandals out to be a rumor though.
Oh yeah,
that's bullshit.
Yeah.
They need a Bloomberg.
It's probably real.
W W was a room,
but then he started himself though,
right?
Yeah.
It was just,
he was just having fun.
That's some bullshit.
They should do it.
They should,
if they were smart,
they should get George Wallace to do it.
And the shift,
Dave Chappelle it,
that would be good to Chris rock and Dave Chappelle would be willing to do it.
Well,
you got to do it just cause you love chicken.
I don't think it's that hard to get chicken.
Well,
I'm going to have to act when you're a multimillionaire.
If you want chicken,
I'm saying you let them fuck.
No,
no,
no.
I'm not thinking of photos to get chicken.
Dammit.
You love the chicken so much.
I don't care about the money.
So he's doing the commercial.
That's rare ground foul taste.
Just like chicken.
I like your a attempt at recovery.
I liked what he tried to do there.
Of course they can afford chicken.
Michael Bisping looked very fucking well tailored fighting.
Dan Handles and it's true and it's got to fix that.
I,
that's going to be huge to come on.
Is it going to be huge?
Are you kidding me?
After that first fight,
what this means.
This is a fucking crazy.
I imagine when they're about willing to watch this Michael Bisbing about to go
again,
dude.
It's going to be fucking enhance these retiring be barriers,
legendary,
epic,
Iconic Shit,
right?
Oh,
I'm a growth guys.
I love this idea of a title fight.
I think that's one of the beautiful things about the UFC,
being able to make crazy fights like this.
Dan Henderson was like,
you know,
I'm probably done.
I don't know me.
I would fight for the title and
he's the first fighter ever to hold two consecutive titles in two different
weight classes in pride.
Never got the UFC.
One man's never got the UFC one,
but if he,
if he gets it with this and then retires,
oh my God,
it goes down.
Pound for pound.
One of the best ever.
He's already in the running right as like 10 forget about like numerically,
like who's more valuable?
Who accomplished more just straight up hall of fame legends.
Who's more legendary than Dan Henderson?
Randek door,
maybe a day inhaler.
He's right up there.
Randy gets a bit more because Randy won the UFC,
correct.
Heavyweight title.
He won the UFC light heavyweight title,
but at the time when Randy did,
when the light heavyweight title I,
I would,
I would say it's more impressive with Dan Henderson was doing in pride.
The guys who was beating,
it's the drug testing.
Yeah.
Maybe his,
his weight,
his height.
It's great.
One Randy coture knocked down Tim,
he's outweighed by like 50 pounds.
He drops Tim Sylvia with a fake,
uh,
inside leg kick and a bomb of overhand right saint punched by the way that
Henderson used when he fought Bisbing boat.
Remember when he beat the brakes off Gonzaga Gonzaga Brennan choppy.
He beat can taco concise and he beat him with ed cocoa farm memory broke.
Randy's,
our rain was beating him with his fucking broken arm.
And then remember when Randy and I said,
oh,
Captain America.
Cool.
Can I douche tooth?
That was the end of the row.
[inaudible] last fight.
You don't have to bring that up.
Well,
no,
I'm just fighting to bring everybody to bring that out,
bro.
Why you gotta bring that up?
You know what's amazing?
I was not disrespectful.
You are these fighters first and second fight in the UFC right there.
I was doing the backstage.
You and I,
you are not there.
We,
you and I went to the fight between Randy couture when he beat Vito Belfort.
We thought Vittorio was going to kill everybody.
Remember that?
I was powerful.
Veto power.
Papa Joe and I flew down to baton rouge or somewhere like that.
Well,
Vito was so big,
man.
He was like two 40 back then,
and I'm not exaggerating,
he looked like a lion.
Jamie,
he's crazy.
But the Vito Belfort,
Randy couture's traps,
he punched like frank the tank.
He looked like bluedot from,
from Papa.
Well,
Eddie and I worked with Eddie and I used to work out with his trainer,
which worked out with this dude.
We used to call them garden hoses.
You're talking about the Korean guy who is jazzed?
Purple is new.
He was a super nice guy and he a wound up.
Oh Shit.
I don't know.
I don't know what him,
30 minute real young.
Yeah.
We don't have to see it.
Everything.
Look at the sides of them.
Jesus Christ.
So they had some seller to get deep into the fight itself.
Mr. Take Yo girl.
Ready?
Cool.
A,
I think this is like,
is this the actual fight itself there?
There it is.
Yeah.
It started from the beginning though.
Start from the beginning.
That's the end of the round.
He was yelling.
I think it's just highlights fellas.
So angry.
They look very well.
He looks about the same age.
Big is big.
Vittores back is this was,
I mean,
what do you think it'd be tour Wade then to 42 days.
Handsome.
See,
but this is like a prime example of having maybe too much muscle.
Like you almost get too strong and too powerful and maybe it's not like the
right thing for your friend,
not back then.
Look at the size of Woodley would beg to differ.
Joe.
He's built different Woodley's,
thicker boned.
He's got bigger fleet.
Please also recall that he ever look how small vittores feet are.
He's not a big giant guy,
but you know,
he's a super athletic guy and you know,
he's had a lot of issues with his hands breaking cause he punches so hard and so
fast.
He's also been doing it for the,
and he's fucked.
We'll beat,
you know,
v towards had I believe at least eight operations on his hands.
And he also had a PRT path for white shoes.
Oh,
Randy couture was wearing shoes.
That's right.
Jamie.
Powerful.
Jamie and crazies.
One was um,
used to be an option.
You could wear shoes up until,
fuck man.
When I was doing,
uh,
the post fight interviews,
it was always you could wear shoes and early on it was no gloves.
I think the gloves came along later.
Early on,
no one was wearing gloves.
Like the first fights I worked at,
maybe like a couple of guys were wearing gloves,
like Vito was wearing gloves tank Abbott used to wear gloves,
but most guys wear,
I wear gloves,
I have gloves on.
But with ventral fun and he said in this fire and he said,
I'm going to beat him.
I beat him with boxing.
Yeah.
Well he just kept pressure on it till you can't,
Randy's a guy that you,
you can't take for granted and this kind of defense bodies now there and look at
his body when he's 48.
And my keys,
I think if you do that,
granted obviously he's on fucking,
he's juice to the gills.
But if you do that with any 48 year old to 19 year old,
they're going to look different.
This is a pretty technical fight for it.
Back then it was Randy.
Randy was not 48 30 years.
37 I'm saying V tore his body when he's 19.
Anyone from 19 to fucking 39 or 42 cha Randy here.
Randy.
Well,
I believe he had his first fight in the UFC when he was 36 to 34 36 34 I'm
pretty sure it's 36 well,
so he was in his thirties.
Well this was in what,
1999 or may not.
Probably not that late.
[inaudible] 97 98 so maybe,
well,
I came along,
I started doing it at 97 and I did it.
I only did it for like a year and a half until they wanted me to go to Japan.
I was like,
check please.
Was this the first,
this was your first time playing where you call it done?
I didn't call the fights back then.
I just did the,
uh,
the interviews afterwards and I did,
I did definitely did the interview after this one.
We,
you and I went to Ken.
I remember the hospital's Great.
Randy.
Once he got that takedown,
this fight doesn't look dated.
This looks like a fight that could damage
to.
Great.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
And this is so old.
It doesn't look dated at all.
You're right.
You're Randy was a beast man.
I think he probably doesn't get nearly enough respect or credit with today's
fighters.
You know,
not today's fighters,
rather a today's fans.
I don't think the people that are newly to the game,
I don't think a big percentage of them go back and watch the early fights.
It's one of the things about fight pass.
I hate to be a show for the company,
but a free like pass is fucking awesome.
Not as a bypass.
He swam from the UFC son.
Come on.
They don't have on fight pass.
I don't think.
I'm almost positive it all.
His Shit's banned from the EOC.
Right?
He's not in the hall of fame.
Can't come to the events.
I'm sure it's fucking on fight pass.
Is that true?
I'm barely on fight pass and I said,
Fuck Reebok.
I alone Randy couture.
I thought fight pass was all the UFC fights.
It's not.
I would be surprised a he's on there.
Find out Jamie,
you can't.
I don't think you can totally say that without knowing for sure.
Let me this
beat downs with the scarf old.
He's on it.
I just Google it on my phone.
He comes up on it on fire.
You can watch his fights.
He's tired here.
This is technical shit.
All of this.
I know Randy couture control.
Where are you?
Like a sweater but we have fight pass,
right?
Yeah.
Once we get towards the legend,
where are you like a sweater?
You fucking you guys on that shit.
How's his fundamentals?
His fundamentals are sound or sound fundamentals.
You guys,
he's such a stud wrestler.
When I wrestled I go,
I say the guys,
I go,
I'm wearing like a sweater motherfucker and I put my chest on his chest.
Is this happened to other than when you're asleep?
When I train,
when I train,
I always said that I go,
you ready to be worn by like a sweater at this turtleneck?
And then when I had strike with guys,
I say this,
I go,
hey dude,
you ever fight a ghost?
You're about to,
that's what I say.
I like the hope.
He likes swinging it fresh air cause that's what you're about to get.
And then I fucking pull a Rodriguez on him cause my fundamentals are sound.
Does anybody ever a tap to the candle per anymore?
Ooh,
I would mark crusher.
Mark Curry's again isn't that can opener.
Goddamn.
I remember Mark Kirk got this Russian dude in the can,
Oprah and it was so god damn nasty,
nasty pulled on this guy's head and mark her was hi ya Ya.
Yeah.
You know the last one?
You know the last one I remember I'll scroll rooms brother against a ray Sefo in
strike force deleted.
That's right.
Sappho cannot.
When you heard him him or what's up?
That was the last one I remember.
Yeah,
he got it from,
yeah,
it was weird.
The over him.
His brother got him around him.
His brother tapped out.
Randy,
you know that right balance.
I didn't know that.
I'll turn it over.
He was a beast.
He was a really good man.
Was this a three round fight?
I can't remember.
He was a heavy guy.
Back way to the ouster was fighting light.
Heavyweight Valentine was was a heavyweight.
Can't you just hurt those brothers were nightmares and no fucking uh,
the Netherlands,
by the way.
Look at how much time is going on in this clock.
Five minutes and 49 seconds.
Five 55 51 like these are long ass fucking rounds folks.
I have a hard time.
This is not the old UFC.
I don't even honestly remember how long the fucking rounds where.
Well,
I just,
I'm distracted by John McCarthy's boat color.
Welcome.
What happened to Randy coture shorts?
You see what happened to his shorts right there?
His shorts are jacked and ripped open.
Still back to the boat color.
I'm going to have both color.
There you go.
Boat collar.
Tom Macarthur.
Go Regulatory.
I just saw him.
Yeah,
the Lesnar fight.
Oh,
I don't know if you can watch the,
I'm sure if he's done their thing and I'm everywhere.
There you go,
Randy couture,
Brock Lesnar.
But we'll see if there's more though.
See if there's ones where he wins.
It's like,
yeah,
you can watch it.
Here's all of the losses.
You could only watch him get his ass.
He's Randy versus chocolate l one and two.
Oh No.
Two and three.
You want a imagine if it was only when you could need tyrannical tour,
but imagine if it was only Randy versus chocolate.
Dell two and three.
You could watch one watch one cause he wanted one
damn rain eco tourists still taking it to Vito here.
I forgot how long his fight last.
This is seven minutes into the first round.
That's some grueling shit.
And he had the worm.
The worm.
Yeah.
You would think you had a warm to brandy and
Punko cm punk out.
Fucking all kinds of shit coming out of your asshole.
Knock you around like a fucking old teddy bear.
Is there no fucking search on this thing Jamie.
Wow,
Jamie.
And we got it.
We got to get the new version of the bypass.
This version kind of blows,
not,
not the fight pass,
rather the I the a apple ITV version of that because if the tour,
but if you like watching old school fights,
the fucking resource of the fight library,
it's so I'll look at these knees to the head down to punt.
It needs to head illegal maneuver.
Now look at that.
So think about all these things that are taking place in this fight with Vito
and Randy.
First of all,
Randy still beating that ass.
It's seven minutes and 58 seconds in Pete.
He still beat that ass.
He's still got the endurance to beat that ass.
Look at them.
It's just beating the fuck out of this dude.
He's trying to break him and he's,
he's one of those dudes,
man.
If he feels you break in,
especially then so close to his,
uh,
his athletic prime as an amateur wrestler and he's a fucking straight savage
right here.
Here's the flight,
right?
They just beat him down.
Collision course right there.
Randy beats it.
Maurice Smith,
he goes,
go to the bottom,
says related videos.
I think that's Randy verse.
Uh,
toward,
Ooh,
got a stud.
He was back then.
God Damn Randy.
Coture.
Yup.
Some savage El cap it go to go to a Randy,
go to Maury Smith versus tank Abbott.
Go to that fight.
[inaudible] tank Abbott.
Fuck yeah.
How about Mark Coleman versus listen,
every,
everybody needed a dude like tank Abbott around.
Just to let you know that you could think that all martial artists are going to
be the same thing.
They're all going to be like the Yoda one.
Cida balance.
No.
There's some dudes who get drunk every night.
We'll beat the fuck out of me.
Kind of similar take out,
but tank even crazier.
Crazier than Roy Nelson from the looks.
You'd be like,
get the fuck on it.
Oh,
belly.
Yeah,
but he can fucking nuts or face off.
I ran into Mark Coleman after he lost to Maurice Smith and he basically gassed
in that one.
I remember that fight.
It was like fucking,
he was leaning over a hands on his knees and morning since the throne leg kicks
and shit.
He was barely hanging on and he was like panicking and uh,
I,
I was working for a guy who was trying to start a magazine and MMA magazine
called NHP.
And so I interviewed Mark Coleman and ask them what uh,
what has it been doing since that fight and he,
and this is that a bar of this look down brothers look at my feet and I'm like
damn,
I got some running shoes.
I've been running man running.
That's what I'm doing.
That's the difference.
I'm running fucking tank.
Hey Jamie,
go back,
go back to they showed the audience go back.
I wanted to,
I want to point this out.
We'll go back a couple of minutes.
Look how small the audiences,
this is crazy.
We just wash them and meet head to show it back then I,
and this is a fight that I was at to harm or this a couple of yeah cause I
remember people,
Maurice.
Um,
I was really interested to see how tank was going to be able to deal with those
leg kicks as Maurice was so fucking skillful as far as like a real heavyweight
cause Maurice is a real natural heavyweight is a big dude but a real
heavyweight.
That's that fucking good at Moy Tai who comes over into it to MMA and again just
like,
like a lot of guys he came over after a long career in kickboxing.
Super Long career.
Yeah.
I mean he's a legend in Denver.
He'd fought for a long time.
One a one,
a bunch of titles.
You said the weirdest thing after this fight too.
I remember I said,
you said after the fight you are next to him and he said,
I looked in his mouth and it looked like his mouth had different parts in it.
Like he had just all these,
like these thick jaw muscles.
You just looked into his mouth tank.
Yes.
Yeah.
He's definitely built different than the regular human.
What's he do these things.
I was wondering what he's meant.
That was getting money.
The angels,
his wait for anybody to open their fucking pie hole.
God,
you don't want that.
Then a bar with a bad day and he said scared though.
Want it?
He meant something like 600 pounds,
600 pounds.
He's a gorilla man.
Right up.
I like that girl.
Look,
gorilla.
I always enjoyed them too.
Me Too.
I was joining him,
watching him fight.
I always enjoyed talking to him.
I always had a good time with that.
Dot.
Thanks was to fight this year but didn't pass his physical.
God Damn it,
man.
That's unfortunate.
You know what happened to was physical.
He said he didn't pass his physical and they brought is built out.
That makes me feel bad.
Maurice.
Maurice had a great sense of humor too.
Was Maurice The champion?
No,
it was this after he had beaten.
Um,
there was this,
after he had beaten mark.
Um,
Mark Coleman for the title cause Morrie's beat Mark Coleman.
Remember he kept saying come on ground and pound me.
Boom,
boom.
And the way Maurice is more,
it's like the nicest guy ever.
So he's talking,
he's talking like all calm.
Come on,
work grounded,
prompt me.
Ground up homie.
Mark,
what's he like?
What's he doing?
He's got a school,
right man,
I don't know he's doing,
he's a good dude though.
Enormous heart.
He definitely has normally funny.
He had a great sense of humor,
but he's also very smart.
When it came to fighting,
he was very smart and one of the things that he had above everybody is cardio.
Maury Smith used to do co Raisie cardio drills.
He would do like these back and forth sprints in the pool.
Like,
like really hardcore long range cardio stuff.
So when he got into these long fights,
you know,
because you've got to remember,
we're not even talking about a five minute round.
I don't even,
what the fuck the rounds were back then?
I don't remember.
Can you find out what the,
the rounds were?
Two 77 this is back like UFC twelveish 13 ish,
somewhere around there.
UFC 12 is when I started.
This is maybe like 14 UFC 40 charters.
Oh my goodness.
He's a young Bruce.
Crazy.
Can't believe he goes all the way back.
He's an inexorable,
he's such a part of the thing.
You know God,
I gotta get Outta here.
I gotta fucking Gig.
I got to do those store.
Okay.
Scooch this up a hair so we can watch this fight.
UFC 12 as the first one with weight classes and UFC 15 set limitations and hair
pulling and banding of strikes.
The back of the neck and head headbutting small joint manipulations in groin
strikes with five minute rounds introduced to UFC 21.
Uh,
UFC 21.
So I was already gone.
What do you think of the 12 to six rule?
They upheld that,
right?
Stupid,
stupid rule.
It doesn't make any sense.
Go ahead.
Right there.
Right there is good.
Right?
Well,
let's see how far away tax just crapped out such a big giant ass dude.
What's going on with this?
Oh,
see we missed a giant chunk son.
I forgot.
Tanky avid gun on top of them.
Took them down.
I forgot that.
Ooh,
looking for,
sorry.
I had an old school wrestling devil late.
Maury Smith had a very underrated,
very good defensive guard.
He went butterfly a lot.
It was very,
back then it was very hard to pass his guard.
Yeah.
You couldn't just pass this guard.
Well,
Maurice is smart dude.
He's a very smart,
when it comes to fighting too,
he has a,
he had a remarkable ability to remain calm in combat.
You know,
it's one of the reasons why he was so dangerous.
Like you could take him out like we saw with the,
uh,
Ernesto,
who's head kick,
but that's a kicked,
it takes out everybody that ever lived back then.
That was one of those kicks.
That's book.
That's a brutal kick that he did on Maurice too.
Everybody gets Koi by that kick.
But what Maurice was,
was capable of was a,
at a super high world class level.
I mean,
he's,
he's an all time great when it comes to from America for sure.
Just pass Moises guard.
Holy Shit.
I was talking so much shit about Morris Garden Passes Guard.
Maurice put them right back in it and you know what that is?
That's the transition that I did not remember.
Yeah,
technical tank actually technically passed Maury Smith's guard.
Who?
Shit tank it.
Russell.
Do you see this photo up?
There was that tank trying to throw a guy out of the rain that ever happened?
He came close.
You got to go.
Go out.
The guy stayed sort of in it,
but it was an issue.
He almost fell out.
They didn't have a rule then the good question.
You have to open the door.
Let the guy back in
each feel like a real big cheese sauce out of the ring.
You on a walk back,
get in.
Well,
I feel like that guy just wasted a lot of energy and time to go after
good at surviving on the ground as a kickboxer.
I don't really know that many kickboxers with the guard is good.
It says,
well,
you know why Frank Shamrock,
he and frank shamrock,
we're very close and this is when frank shamrock was at his best.
Like when frank shamrock was a UFC champion,
when a frank beat John Lobur that rematch like he was,
he was palling around with Maurice back then think they both helped each other a
lot.
I think more he's helped frank with a lot of cardio,
like really emphasizing how strong a role cardio plays and also with Maurice of
course showing him like real proper kickboxing fundamentals it sees in his
corner.
Yeah.
Frank.
Now he was in his corner for a,
I watched warnings fight once and Draka you remember Draka?
I sure don't.
It was a like MMA,
but uh,
you could take dudes down or kickboxing,
but you could take dudes down.
It was real weird.
It was a just an alternative set of rules.
Yeah.
Do you remember any no.
Drunk?
Yeah.
You remember that shit only terrible because you got to get used to it after a
while.
It was kind of fun to say it again.
Draka and little bell tours any better.
But it's like,
it seems like,
um,
like a kickboxing we take downs is a big part of it.
More ties all about,
you know,
sweeps and the crazy sweeps.
Damn court me for throwing dudes and Dominic steel.
Well,
they're crazy war.
I need to go back home and it,
I made it.
That should've made it.
That's fine.
Then just regular kickboxing.
Kickboxing with throws and Shin.
Yeah.
Interesting to me.
Oh,
Jamie's got it up there.
Is that drop drop?
Yeah.
Oh,
these guys are using MMA gloves.
This is another next level shit.
This is the truck to the 14.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
When I saw this full Lma.
No,
it's Lma.
Draka.
Maybe Draka just moved to La man.
Fuck.
Are we doing with this book?
Oh God.
Guy Has on UFC trumps that he could buy off the website and it's beautiful
trunk.
While why not wear them?
Want to be you upstairs?
It's,
it's the only thing.
Sad.
It's got both the underwear on as well.
See that is the underwear on UFC trucks.
Hey man,
you guys gotta fucking dreams.
Obviously a bad motherfucker.
But the old Draka was,
uh,
it was kickboxing.
They have boxing gloves on and they'd just,
but you could shoot like double lights.
You could do throws and stuff.
It was weird.
Like judo type shows all kinds of throws some more you could do throws.
Oh my God.
I gotta get out of here.
I this,
this fucking,
this podcast has gone on far too late,
ladies and gentlemen.
It's bullshit.
I have obligations and milestones for sleep.
Uh,
you can find head.
He mother fucking Bravo.
Ah,
eh.
it's Eddie Bravo on Twitter.
Right?
And at Eddie Bravo 10 on Instagram.
Yeah.
Eddie Bravo 10 Instagram.
Brian Callan is br.
Why Br?
Why ain't Brennan Shab Not Brandon.
You Fuck Brendan.
Brendan Shop.
You could find Brendan Trump.
S C h a u B.
Anything boys and any dates to plug a August 18th 19th 20th comes comedy store
Wednesday night,
Wednesday night comedy store,
Brendan shrubs,
actual comedy Sorta Kinda debut,
but he's done it already debut.
Anytime you do the comedy stuff for the first time,
it's your debut Ebi,
eight September 11th,
the middleweights downtown Los Angeles at the Orpheum.
He could watch it on UFC fight pass.
Here it goes.
Hold on a second.
Wait a minute.
Before there's a tiny habits coming out,
something happened and it's seven minutes,
55 seconds into the fight.
And this is where,
where it comes,
these fucking brutal leg kicks and you've got a guy like Maury Smith standing in
front of you and you're exhausted.
Oh,
that's it.
We don't need to see any more of those.
Bye everybody.
Thanks for tuning in.
Appreciate Ya.
See Ya.